WILL COME TO ORDER. I LIKE TO
NOTE THAT SENATOR LEYVA FROM
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
BOB WILL NOT BE JOINING US
LATER TODAY IS THAT CORRECT.
YES OKAY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO-
THANK THE OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHO HELPED PUT THE
HEARING TOGETHER TODAY WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU PUT OUT INTO MAKING THIS
HAPPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING. GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
TODAY WE EXPECT TO HAVE A ONE
MEMBER PARTICIPATING REMOTE
REMOTELY. AT SOME POINT LATER
ON THIS ASSURING WE WILL HAVE
SENATOR WIENER. HERE BUT HE HE
AND HIS IT THANK YOU SIR WHERE
WALK ON. AND LATER ON WE WILL
ALSO HAVE- WITH THIS REPORT
TWO- THREE SENATOR. AND BY
STRESS JOHN. WE ALSO HAVE PANEL
CORPORATE WITH VIA ZOOM OR CON
CALL FOR A PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
ME YOUR PHONE ARE COULD. THIS
GREATLY AID IN THE LIMON ANY OF
FEEDBACK ASKED THE EVERY TIME
WISH TO WRECKED THAT YOU USE
THE RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO. YOU KNOW.
CENTRAL TO THE. HE PLEASE A NEW
YOU BE DOES OUR EIGHTY PER PUT
YOU BACK MUTE YOUR ONCE RECORD
JUST PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN ARE READY
ADDRESS COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE-
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO HEARING. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
OF IS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
ONE THREE FIVE- DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HEAR FROM ALL OF THE
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA PRIOR
TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
ONCE WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE WITNESSES ON EACH PANEL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE PANELISTS.
AFTER ALL OF THE PANELS HAVE
FINISHED WITH THE PRESENTATIONS
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE FOR WATCHING.
ARENA ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
INDEED ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAPPIER CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE MAKING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
MATTER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY'S HEARING AS FOCUSED ON
FIGHTING HUNGER. WITH FOOD
ASSISTANCE FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS DURING COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BAMILEKE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA PREPARING FOR
THANKSGIVING NEXT WEEK. TWO
POINT NINE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
WITH ONE POINT TWO MILLION OF
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS HAVING
CHILDREN AND THEM. WILL BE FOOD
INSECURE NEXT WEEK. I WANT TO
TALK TO TAKE A QUICK MOMENT AND
THINK ABOUT THAT. TWO POINT
NINE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS. AS
PAINFUL AS PAINFUL AS IT IS FOR
ME TO THINK ABOUT THAT IT'S
ALSO BEEN A PERSONAL MISSION OF
MINE TO USE THAT PAIN AS A WAY
TO HEAL. FIVE YEARS AGO I HAD.
A BEST FRIEND THAT CAME AND
KNOCKED ON MY DOOR. THE END
THAT KNOCK FOREVER CHANGED MY
LIFE- SHE CAME SHE KNOCKED AND
SHE SAID SHE WAS STRUGGLING TO
FEED HER INFANT CHILD SHE
NEEDED SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE AND- BABY
FOOD FORMULA. IT IT IS THAT
THAT IS WHAT LED ME TO RUN FOR
CITY COUNCIL INDIVIDUALLY TO
STATE SENATE IT FOOD INSECURITY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS LONG
BEEN AN ISSUE. COBEN NINETEEN
HAS MADE IT SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE
AND THIS IS NOT JUST A STORY
THAT IS TRUE TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY MY SENATE DISTRICT. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS CHEAP TOO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH
COLBERT NINETEEN ACROSS THE
NATION AS WELL. SO TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE LIKE
MY BEST FRIEND. WHO HAVE FACED
CHALLENGES OVER OVER COLBY
DURING COAL BED AND EVEN PRIOR
TO THAT WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
WHOSE HOUSEHOLD NUTRITIONAL
NEEDS WERE AFFECTED BY COOPER
NINETEEN AND I THINK THEIR
STORIES WILL ELIMINATE THE
GROWING IMPORTANCE OF FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK TO FIGHT HUNGER
BE A CALFRESH. OUR FOOD BANKS
SENIOR MEAL PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL
MEAL PROGRAMS I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR
PANELIST. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR SCHEDULE SPEAKERS I WOULD
LIKE TO. INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE CALL IN
NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE. FOR SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ONE
THREE FIVE. OUR FIRST PANEL IS
GOING TO DISCUSS HOW COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED
NEED FOR NUTRITION ASSISTANCE.
FOLLOWING THE CONCLUSION OF
EACH PANEL I WILL OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OUR FIRST
SPEAKER TODAY IS DIANE WHAT.
SHAWLS AND BACH DIRECTOR
INSTITUTE FOR POLICY RESEARCH
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY. DIANNE
WELCOME AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH IT'S WONDERFUL TO
BE HERE VIRTUALLY WITH YOU ALL
TO TALK ABOUT STUDENT SECURITY
AND CALIFORNIA I'VE CALCULATED
ON NUMBER OF STATISTICS FROM
RECENT. THAT WILL HELP US- I
THE EXTENT OF FOOD INSECURITY
ONE STAR BY SAYING STAGE. BUT
STUDENT SECURITY IS A- HIGH
INCOME AND NATIONWIDE DURING
COLD AT NINETEEN SAID. THERE TO
PREVENT OF HARD THAT I PRISON
HERE AT THE IS SECURITY WHICH
OF THIS MEASUREMENT THAT YOU
FAMILY HAVE AN RESOURCE. TO BUY
THE FOOD THAT YOU. TO LIVE AN
ACTIVE AND HEALTHY LIFE. IT
DOESN'T S. INCLUDE ME THAT YOUR
HUNGER. I COULD MEAN THAT YOUR
YOU'RE HAVING TO REALLY CUT
CORNERS YOU KNOW STOP BUYING
FRESH FRUITS BUT THAN LIKE THAT
THAT'S WAS BROUGHT MEASURE FOOD
AND SECURITY. AND WE'RE ALSO IN
TO LOOK HUNGER WHICH DURING THE
PANDEMIC BEEN MEASURED BY
ASKING FAMILIES. DO YOU HAVE
ENOUGH TO EAT AND A FAMILY SAYS
I WE SOMETIMES ARE OFTEN DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT. THEY'RE
CODED AS- AGAIN HUNGRY. THE
JUSTICE OF THE STAGE ON THE EVE
OF THE CO PANDA. FOOD AND
SECURITY IN OTHER MEASURE OF
GOOD HOW. WALKWAY LOW THE TEN
PER WELL. ARGUABLY STILL TO BUT
A 10% OF CALIFORNIA OVERALL
WE'RE- THAT. AND LITTLE LESSON
4% WORKS. HUNGER. DURING COLD
ED. DOES ARE OUR CORE ELEVATED.
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC FROM
APRIL TO JULY ALMOST ONE OUT OF
FOUR ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
REPORTED THAT THEY WERE FOOD
INSECURE AND 11% REPORTED THAT
THEY WERE EXPERIENCING ACTUAL
HUNGER IN OUR HOUSEHOLDS. THOSE
NUMBERS HAVE COME DOWN A LITTLE
BIT IN SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER IS
THE ECONOMY STARTED TO REBOUND
A LITTLE BAD. AT CETERA. UP TO
ABOUT 22% OVERALL AND 10% BOB
EXPERIENCING HUNGER. THIS IS
WHAT FOOD HARDSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE IN
SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER FOR
DIFFERENT GROUPS SO WE START
WITH THE OVERALL GROUP WHICH I
SHOWED YOU ON THE LAST LINE AND
WE CAN COME OVER TO FAMILIES
ADULTS WITH CHILDREN. YOU CAN
SEE THAT ADULTS WITH CHILDREN
ARE MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
FOOD HARDSHIP- NEARLY THREE OUT
OF TEN ARE REPORTING THREE IN
SECURITY 15% ARE REPORTING
HUNGER. AMONG THE ELDERLY WHAT
THEIR RATES ARE LOWER THEY'RE
STILL QUITE ELEVATED 16% OF THE
L. OF ELDERLY CALIFORNIANS
REPORT THAT THEY'RE FOOD
INSECURE. ABOUT 6% SAID THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT. THIS
IS WHAT THOSE NUMBERS LOOK LIKE-
BY RACE AND ETHNICITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN SEE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT FOOD SECURITY.
ABOUT 15% OF WHITE AND ASIAN
RESPONDENTS SAY THAT THEIR FOOD
IN SECURE AND THOSE RATES ARE
ABOUT DOUBLE. FOR BLACK
FAMILIES AND FOR HISPANIC OR
LATINO FAMILIES. WHEN WE COME
OVER TO THINK ABOUT- ARE YOU
SOMETIMES ARE OFTEN NOT GETTING
ENOUGH TO EAT. THOSE RATES ARE
ABOUT 6% FOR WHITES AND ASIANS
AND OUT. MORE THAN MORE THAN
TWICE THAT FOR BLACKS AND
HISPANICS OR LET'S MEDINA
FAMILY. I CAN ALSO SHOW YOU
THIS- FOR ADULTS WITH CHILDREN
AND YOU CAN SEE IS VERY SIMILAR
PATTERNS BUT I'LL JUST POINT
HIGHLIGHT ONE NUMBER HERE.
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF. THE
HISPANIC OR LATINO ADULTS WITH
CHILDREN SAID THAT THE FOOD
SECURE AND NEARLY ONE OUT OF
FIVE SAID THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH FOOD TO EAT IN THEIR-
AND THEIR HOUSES RIGHT NOW.
HERE'S WHAT THE- RESULTS LOOK
LIKE FOR ELDERLY ADULTS YOU SEE
THAT SAME PATTERN JUST A LITTLE
BIT LOWER BUT STILL VERY VERY
ELEVATED. JUST FOR CONTEXT- THE
RATES IN CALIFORNIA TRACK THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE QUITE CLOSELY
SO WE'RE SEEING THIS ALL ACROSS
THE NATION SOME STATES ARE
EXPERIENCING A WORSE SOME
STATES ARE DOING A LITTLE BIT
BETTER AND CALIFORNIA'S JUST
RIGHT AT THAT AVERAGE. IF YOU
WANT THINGS TO NOTE THERE IS A
STRONG RELIANCE ON FREE MEALS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC ABOUT ONE
OUT OF EIGHT CALIFORNIANS
REPORT RECEIVING A FREE MEAL IN
THE PAST WEEK. AND HERE'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE FOR THE OVERALL
OF FILMS WITH CHILDREN ARE MORE
LIKELY ABOUT ONE IN FIVE. SAID
THEY GOT A FREE MEAL THE LAST
WEEK AND A LITTLE BIT LOWER BOB
FOR THE ELDERLY COMMUNITY. AND
WHEN WE COMPARE THAT TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC IN
THE RATES ACTUALLY LOOK QUITE
SIMILAR. TO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS A JUST A TREMENDOUS DEMAND
FOR THREE MEALS A TREMENDOUS
RELIANCE ON CHARITY FOOD-
THAT'S BEEN SUSTAIN FOR QUITE A
LONG TIME. JUST SO YOU GET A
SENSE OF WHERE THESE THREE
MEALS ARE COMING FROM. THE BLUE
LINE IT'S THEIR THE BLUE BARS
ARE FROM THE SCHOOL AND THE-
RED. BURKE FROM UP FROM A FOOD
BANK AND THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS AS WELL THAT THESE ARE
SLIPPING TO AND YOU CAN SEE OF
COURSE FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO SAY
THAT THEY'VE GOTTEN A FREE MEAL
FROM OF FOOD FROM A SCHOOL. AND
OF THE BANK IS BASICALLY PRETTY
CONSTANT ACROSS ALL SORTS OF
CALIFORNIANS. THIS IS WHAT
THOSE NUMBERS LOOK LIKE BY RACE
OR ETHNICITY. YOU CAN SEE THAT
I'M GONNA GET RID LATINOS IN
ADDITION TO EXPERIENCING MORE
FOOD AND SECURITY ARE ALSO
RELYING MORE ON ON CHARITY SAID.
COMING TO A CONCLUSION IS
SERVICE QUICKLY AS HE CAN. THIS
IS JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
MANY CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
YOU. ADDICTING THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO- EXPERIENCE
HARDSHIP THIS FIRST SET OF BARS
IT SAYS- ASKS ARE YOU CONFIDENT
THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THE COULD YOU NEED OVER THE
NEXT MONTH AND THIS IS THE
SHARE OF CALIFORNIANS WHO SAY
THAT THEY'RE- EITHER NOT EITHER
MODERATELY OR VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO. AFFORD
THE FOOD THEY NEED YOU CAN SEE
YOU KNOW THOSE NUMBERS ARE YOU
KNOW MORE THAN ONE OUT OF THREE
OF FOR BLACKS AND HISPANIC OR
LATINO ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA.
SIMILARLY WE CAN THINK ABOUT
THE SHARE OF PEOPLE WHO SAY
THAT THEY ARE. NOT CONFIDENT
THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO PAY
THEIR NEXT RENT PAYMENT OR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS THESE ARE
VERY VERY HIGH NUMBERS YOU
KNOW- ALMOST ONE OUT OF FIVE
CALIFORNIANS OVERALL. A SIMILAR.
MORE THAN ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIA. FAMILIES REPORT
BEING BEHIND CURRENTLY ON THEIR
HOUSING PAYMENTS NOT EVEN
THINKING ABOUT THE NEXT PAYMENT.
RELIEF PAYMENTS HAVE CERTAINLY
HELP I KNOW THAT OTHERS WILL BE
TALKING MORE ABOUT THIS.
CALFRESH RESPONSE HAS BEEN
STRONG AS HAS SNAPPED
NATIONWIDE. THERE WAS A SHARP
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES. SERVED BY THIS
PROGRAM UP 20% BOB BY JUNE IT'S
COME DOWN A LITTLE BIT SINCE
THEN BUT STILL QUITE ELEVATED.
THE PANDEMIC EBT PROGRAM. HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE. FOOD
HARDSHIP FOR FAMILIES THAT
RECEIVE THAT IT ALSO BRINGS IN-
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
THE STATE. AND THEN FINALLY I
WANT TO SAY IT'S A QUICK THING
ABOUT WEST. OF THE PURPLE BARS
HERE ARE EIGHT. U. S. WICKS
CASELOADS AND THE BLUE BARS OUR
CASELOADS IN CALIFORNIA YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT. IN RECENT YEARS
WHICH CASELOADS HAVE BEEN
DECLINING. ALL ACROSS THE
NATION WITH THE DECLINING MORE
QUICKLY IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
THESE NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP WITH
PARTICIPATIONS GONE UP IN
CALIFORNIA BY ABOUT 11% OF ITS
AND MORE RESPONSIVE THAN THE
REST OF THE NATION HAS DONE BUT
IT'S STILL. YOUR LACK QUITE A
BIT COMPARED TO THE NATION AS A
WHOLE IN TERMS OF WHAT
PARTICIPATION. JUST IF WE
CONCLUDE. THIS PANDEMIC AND
THOSE SORT OF LONG REACH OF THE
RECESSION THAT IT INDUCED ME
WITH US FOR A LONG TIME THIS
IS- THE FOOD IN START SORRY
THIS IS THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
OVER TIME THERE'S A LITTLE A
GREEN BAR GREEN LINE HERE AT 6%
GENERALLY WE THINK OF ANY TIME
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS ABOVE
6% THAT WE'RE IN A RECESSION.
THIS IS WHAT THE CONGRESSIONAL
BUDGET OFFICE PREDICTS IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WE KNOW THAT
UP LOW EVERITT WORKERS WITH LOW
LEVELS OF EDUCATION BLACK
WORKERS HISPANIC AND LATINO
WORKERS GENERALLY EXPERIENCE
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AND
THOSE COME DOWN MORE SLOWLY AND
SO THAT MEANS THAT THESE
FAMILIES ARE GONNA BE IMPACTED
BY THE RECESSION. FOR MUCH
LONGER. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED SUPPORT FOR MUCH LONGER.
LOOK FOR THE QUESTIONS THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU DIANNE UP
NEXT WE HAVE KERRY FIGUEROA
CLIENT OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
FOOD BANK. HI THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. KERRY PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I JUST WANT
TO START BY SAYING- WHEN TWENTY
TWENTY STARTED I NEVER THOUGHT
THAT FOOD INSECURITY WOULD BE-
PART OF MY VOCABULARY- WHEN
TWENTY TWENTY STARTED I WAS
WORKING FOR CLOSE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND MY HUSBAND
WAS WORKING FULL TIME WE HAD
BENEFITS AND WE'RE PLANNING ON
BUYING A HOUSE THIS YEAR- BUT
ON MARCH THIRTEENTH. EVERYTHING
CHANGED FOR US- MARCH
THIRTEENTH SCHOOL DISTRICT SHUT
DOWN. AND I RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION VIA EMAIL THAT YOU
MEAN THAT AS A CONTRACTED
EMPLOYEE I WAS OFF WITHOUT PAY-
I WASN'T INITIALLY CONCERNED
BECAUSE I WAS DIRECTED TO APPLY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT WHICH I DID.
AND MY HUSBAND AS A PLUMBER WAS
CONSIDERED AN ESSENTIAL
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEE SO I FIGURED
WE WOULD BE OKAY. TWO WEEKS
LATER STILL HADN'T HEARD BACK
FROM UNEMPLOYMENT REGARDING MY
APPLICATION. AND MY HUSBAND
CAME HOME AND INFORMED ME THAT
HIS ENTIRE CREW HAD BEEN LAID
OFF AND THAT THEIR JOB SITE HAD.
BEEN SHUT DOWN- WHEN WE START
TO GET A LITTLE- TO THIS DAY I
AVE NOT GOTTEN A RESPONSE FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT I NEVER RECEIVED
ANY UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
THE TIME THAT I WAS OFF WORK-
AND IT IS ABOUT. THE END OF
MARCH. EARLY APRIL WE STARTED
GOING TO OUR LOCAL CHURCH TO
RECEIVE FOOD DONATIONS WE ARE A
LARGE FAMILY- BETWEEN ME AND MY
HUSBAND WE HAVE SEVEN KIDS THAT
LIVE WITH US FULL TIME- SO WE
STARTED RECEIVING DONATIONS
FROM OUR LOCAL CHURCH IN THOSE
REALLY HELPED TO MAKE ENDS
MEET- BUT AS PANDEMIC SCARE
SPREAD. IT BECAME HARDER TO
ACQUIRE THE THINGS WE NEED
THERE WERE LIMITATIONS ON THE
pAMOUNTS OF MILK MEAT AND BREAD
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PURCHASE
IN THE STORE- SO IT REALLY. IT
REALLY GOT SCARY FOR AWHILE AND
I REALLY STARTED TO WORRY IF I
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS ENOUGH
FOOD FOR MY FAMILY- I NOTICED
THAT THE DONATIONS FROM OUR
CHURCH WERE COMING FROM THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK.
SO I REACHED OUT TO THEM AND I
ACCESS GROCERIES TO GO THANKS
TO GROCERIES TO GO WE WERE ABLE
TO RECEIVE FRESH MILK EGGS
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
MEAT ARM AND IT WAS IT WAS
REALLY AMAZING- I AM STARTING
TO GET NERVOUS AGAIN BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE LEANING TOWARDS
THAT. THAT SHUT DOWN AGAIN- BUT
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT PUTTING
FOOD ON MY TABLE AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT. IF WE DO
GET TO THAT POINT AGAIN THE
FOODBANK WILL BE THERE FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY. KERRY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY AGAIN FILE. WE ARE GOING
TO- ALSO HEAR NEXT FROM AT.
ARENA THIRTY YOU'LL SHE'S A
FARM WORKER AND ALSO A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE UP
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER
FOUNDATION KARINA. WELCOME AND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. OKAY EVEN IF.
NUMBER EIGHT IS GETTING A
COUNTY YOU'LL YOU BRING ON THE
NEXT MONEY THAT EFFORT TO GROW.
YEAH BUT I MEAN IT'S A FAIR YOU
CAN GET IN SORRY OKAY ORDERS BY
T. THE NEW YORK GET ABOUT FROM
BADDIE LARA. BUT AT LEAST.
THANK THE PROPOSAL. OKAY IF-
THE LAW GOING WELL THAT OUT
EVERY FROM THE BODY I OUT OF W.
ME TO. ON THE RIGHT BEST YOUNG
THEY KILEY NATION- YOU ARE YOU
OKAY. I DID MANAGE BE
IMPOSSIBLE ME ASK BEARING WITH
GENESIS THE LION BY YEAH. WHEN
I AM OKAY. HELLO OKAY. YOUR
MAIL AND THIS IS THE THAT THING
I THINK I'VE OR MONEY THAT.
THIS CALL- YEAH THEY DON'T THEY
THEY CAN'T QUITE GET A PENCIL
NOT KATE YEAH THERE'S LOS IS
BLOCKED FROM. IT'S CALL ME THAT
IN THERE YOU'RE NEVER GONNA BE
ALL WORK IT'LL LIKE IT'LL BE A
YOU GOTTA THE END OF GUN BAN.
THE LITTLE CAN ALSO TERMS FOUND
THERE ARE NONE OF THE OLD- IF
BENEFIT AT BOMBAY YELLOW LUCK
BEST YOU ARE HAVE FOR YOU ON
THE ONLY. LISTING CHANGE- CITY
I LIVE. THROUGH BACK. IT MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN BETTER MASCOT YES
IT IS A BIG BENEFIT. THERE ARE
YOUR LEGAL CASE MORE YEAH I'M-
WE ARE BADLY IF IT'S OKAY FOR
YOU TO. AT FEEDBACK. ARTICLE
THIS I THAT WHEN I LEFT. ON A
SCALE AND I EVEN GET BUSINESS I
PRESS ON ASKING. AND THEN THERE
WAS SILENCE I HOPE IT DOES NOT
IT CAN LOOKING OKAY THAT LOCAL
AND IN LAST FAMILY. METARA YET
BUT I MEAN YES I AM YES I AM
THE C. R. ARMY CAVA GOT UP BUT
I BOOK OUT I. GOT BACK OUT OF
IT BAD THAT I MADE. IN LAND BUT
I NEED TO MAKE IT UP TO YOU'RE
A PART OF. YES I'M THE IN. YOU
MAY STUDY ACTIVITIES MY YOU.
ARE AT IS DO WE ALL MEDIA IS
I'M GUILTY THAT YOU. ANTICIPATE
WHAT FROM THE NEXT ALL THE WAY
I'M WILL. YOUR. THE LITTLE THAT
ACTUALLY LOVE ME YEAH. IT A-
PRODUCT OF BUOYANCY WHEN IN BY
BECAUSE THE PHONE. IT'S A
SINGLE PUBLIC SCHOOL KNOWING
THAT WHAT FIVE WIN I LEFT THE
IN A CLASS YEAH. I IN FACT I
DON'T KNOW. YEAH V. STAYING.
WHAT BUT I MEAN YOU KNOW THE
LOCAL BOTTOM MAN I'M NOT YOU
LEARN IT CAN STAND IT CAN I WAS
IN LOCAL MEDIA IN A CM
PROPORTION AND THE STILL
STARTING MAY VALUE IS OK GIVEN
ONE AFTER SOME OF THE LOCAL MEN
BY THAT. S. ONE WILL BE YOUR
RESTA EATER. THE YEAH. SHE MORE
THE VOICE BY ME I KNOW YOU
THOUGH ABOUT SOMETHING THAT YOU
LOVE ASSEMBLY THAT INCLUSIVE WE
BE THE MAVIN. THEY CALL ME.
MACINNES SAID THE ALSO FOR THE
IN IN THE FAMILIAR FIVE YEARS
ALL ESPECIALLY CRASH SITE. IF I
AM C. THANK MEET UP WITH THE
WHOLE. CHARLIE IF I LOOK. BBC.
THE IDEA IS THAT WOULD BE EASY.
YEAH YES BUT OKAY BROWN. IT'S A
YOUR MILES THERE WHAT ABOUT BUT
ACTUALLY I WANT FAMILIES OF
THEM A IS BACK FROM YET. YEAH
LOOKING FOR QUALITY SCHOOL-
ASSIGNMENT. I TALLIED UP I HAD
TO MAKE IT A GET GADI. MINDEL
AMBASSADOR ALL MID DECEMBER
YEAH I CAN I WILL NOTIFY SEAT
IN UTAH. YES THAT IT WILL BE.
IF I WILL IF YOU. ONE ONE JUST
BECAUSE CLEANUP FOR SO AT MORE
WITHOUT WE AT THAT THE THEY- DC
LONG POSSIBLY LITTLE AT THE
WHOLE AND IN ENGLISH AND M.
BERMAN DISCUSSES BORDA A START
WITH THE SUPPORT LIKE A MOTHER.
SHE PACKS- GRAPES INTO INTO
BOXES FOR DISTRIBUTION. SHE'S
BEEN A VICTIM OF COBIT HERSELF-
AND IT'S THE MOST HORRIBLE
THING BUT YOU CAN COME UP YOU
KNOW. GET IN AND GO THROUGH
BECAUSE HE DROVE HOME YOUR
SHELTER YOU KNOW CHARACTER
QUARANTINED. AND YOU'RE ALL
ALONE- THE BUT THE SUPPORT OF
THE COMMUNITY. HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL TO HER AND HER FAMILY
BUT ALSO TO OTHER FAMILIES. IN
NEARBY COMMUNITIES AND- SHE'S
COME ACROSS- FIRST HAND. JUST
THE SIGNIFICANT NEED THAT THAT
COLBERT HAS BROUGHT OUT IN
TERMS OF FOOD AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY IS A VERY
EMOTIONAL THING BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT FOR HER AND FOR
OTHERS AND SHE'S SEEN IT
FIRSTHAND. SHE ALSO- WANTED TO-
MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY TO COULD
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THAT- DOES THAT ARE
DOCUMENTED HAVE ACCESS TO. AND
YOU KNOW JUST ALSO JUST HAVING
A LOT OF FEAR MONTEL FIELD
WHILE MULTI LAYERED PIERRE-
IT'S A SHIPPING SAID. SHE HEARD
IN A PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTION.
DISTRIBUTION AT CHURCHES SHE
SAID THAT SHE ALSO. GOES TO
CHURCH IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
SHOULD LIKE TO SEE- MORE
SUPPORT THERE BECAUSE PEOPLE IN
TIMES OF NEED- OR THE NEVER
COAT GO TO CHURCH- AND- IT'S A
GOOD PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD THERE AND- SHE
PRECIADO BUT AT THE SUPPORT IN
TERMS OF THE GENEROSITY OF THE
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO OF THE STATE
AND WANTS TO CONTINUE TO. IT
THINKS IT'S AGOOD IDEA FOR.
THE FOR THE SUPPORT TO THE
COMMUNITY CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU GREEN I AND I HOPE I
YOU KNOW WHAT ABLE TO
ARTICULATE AS AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE- YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
BUT I WILL- YOU KNOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK. TO MEMBERS FOR
ANY. FOR ANY QUESTIONS OF ANY
OF THE PANELISTS. CERVANTES
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY AND WE
HAVE. SENATE WIENER DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. ON C. OKAY. ALL
I WANT TO THANK ARM YOU KNOW
ALL THREE OF OUR PANELISTS HERE
TODAY SAID IT'S LIKE I SAID
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IT'S A VERY
PERSONAL ISSUE TO ME AS WELL
AND IT'S VERY EMOTIONAL AND NOT
YOU KNOW HAVING GONE THROUGH.
YOU KNOW THE PANDEMIC OF
WATCHING THE LONG LINES. AT
YOUR PEOPLE JUST WAITING FOR
FOOD AND THE FEAR- IT'S VERY
REAL IT'S VERY REAL AND- WE
WANT TO DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN
ON OUR END TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE PUTIN SECURITY IS NOT AN
ISSUE IT'S- SO ON WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY AND-
YOU KNOW THE ONE QUESTION THAT
I YOU KNOW. DO YOU HAVE FOR-
KARINA IS- YOU KNOW CAN YOU CAN
YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT. YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
THINGS WORK WHAT HAVE BEEN WHAT
HAS BEEN THE GREATEST CHALLENGE
IN TERMS OF ACCESSING FOOD FOR
YOU. KATINA. PLEASE ME BROUGHT
UP BUT LISTED. S. QUALITY
POINTLESS AND SO EXPERIENCE YEP
ONE POLICY WILL NOT LACKED OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT SUPPORT AT
THE THURSDAY EXERCISE. COMIDA
BUT INSTEAD IS TO FROM I'M
QUITE. BUT I THINK I MEAN AS-
REGULAR ON THE BACK. NOT FISH
THEY BUT I MEAN IF. I THINK WE
ALL. S. C. THE GENTLEMAN IT'S
GOING TO HELP. WELL I YEAH BUT
I'M EITHER WHAT IS THE LEGAL
ARE. HELLO WHAT I. YOU CAN LOOK
LOOKS CHEAP CAN I MAKE IT OUT
THANKS YOU ON THE THING DON'T
IS THE INTERNET PLEASE. IF I AM
AND IF THE PEOPLE PART OF THE
YEAH YOU LEGAL. CAN YOU SEE IS
BOTH I'M YEAH A LITTLE BUT I'M
FOR COMMITTEE ON THE ORGANIC
WE'LL THAT BACK I OF THAT. I
DON'T EXPECT AT ALL YES THEY
ARE- YEAH I MEAN I LIVE WHERE I
PUT GIVE BAD BATTLE CHEST
MIRABEL JUST BY LOOKING. IF
SAYS THEY IS WHEN I GOT MY YUBA.
BATTLED BACK. THEY PLAY- MIDDLE
STUDY EFFICACY ARAMBULA. FOR ME
THAT LOOK WHERE I AYE BUT I.
ALSO THAT YOU HAVE A ARE. I
MEAN FOR ME. I MEAN FOR I'M SEE
HOLES IT WAS BUT I'M FROM.
AMENDED TO- SHE MEANT THAT- THE
FOOD DISTRIBUTION. AT SCHOOL.
HAS VERY HELP TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. FOR HER TO. AND- IF IT
THINKS IT YEAH CONTINUE THAT
WILL BE. HELPFUL MOVING FORWARD
SHE ALSO MAY. THAT NOT ONLY ARE
REASON. LIMITED AND YOU KNOW
HER- BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT THE
CALL OF FOOD IS GOING SIGNATURE
UP IS JUST AS THAT IT'S ADDING.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH THE CITY OF
THE SAME QUESTION I KNOW I KNOW
THAT- YOU MENTIONED. HAVING
GONE TO CHURCH AND I JUST
WANTED TO SEE IF- YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE ANY IMPACTS YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY DURING. ANY DURING
THE TIME THAT YOU KNOW SCHOOLS
KIND OF SHUT DOWN THE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS. WORK THAT
EVEN OCCURRED IN IN YOUR AREA.
YEAH SO INITIALLY WHEN THE
SCHOOL SHUT DOWN THERE WAS NO
FOOD DISTRIBUTION FOR THE
SCHOOLS- RIGHT NOW OUR ACCESS
TO NEVER USE IT EVERY DAY- WE-
RIGHT THERE EVERY MORNING AND
PICK UP LUNCHES FOR THE KIDS-
BUT INITIALLY THERE WAS
NOTHING. AND THAT'S WHEN WE
STARTED USE LIGHTLY UTILIZING
SERVICES FROM THE CHURCH THEY
WERE PASSING OUT LUNCHES DAILY-
THE HARDEST PART FOR US. WAS IN
THE VERY BEGINNING WHEN THERE
WERE LIMITATIONS- ONLY BEING
ABLE TO BUY ONE GALLON OF MILK
ONLY BEING ABLE TO BUY ONE LOAF
OF BREAD THAT DOES. NOTHING FOR
A FAMILY OF NINE ONE LEFT ONE
RIGHT AS MUCH. SO- I'M
DEFINITELY NOT. PART FOR US WAS
THAT ONE TAKE. RABAL TO BUY- NO
NATION'S FROM CHURCH FILLED IN
THOSE GAPS- AND THE LUNCH OF
HELL SICKENING BECAUSE A ARE
HOME ALL THE TIME- LUNCH- THANK
UPS THIS WEEK- AND THE KIDS ARE
BACK IN SCHOOL 50% OF THE TIME
SO THE FUTURE STILL UNCERTAIN
AS FAR AS THAT GOES. JUST AS A
FOLLOW BY NOT AT IN YOUR TEST
YOU MENTIONED- YOU KNOW THAT
THE- BEGINNING TO COME IN AGAIN
AND- AND IN SECURITY RIGHT TO
FRONT OF THE INSTABILITY WITH
WORK AND THE PANDEMIC. WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY IT'S IS- THE
GREATEST FEAR AT S. AS AS WE'RE
MOVING ALONG AND WE KNOW THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE RISING. OF KOBE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE NATION. AND SO I WAS ABLE
TO FIND ANOTHER JOB- DURING THE
SUMMER YEAH IT'S AN ESSENTIAL
JOB BASICALLY STILL ARM MY
EMPLOYMENT I FEEL LIKE IT'S
PRETTY SECURE BUT MY HUSBAND
HAD TO FIND AN ALTERNATIVE JOB
AND IT'S NOT A SENSUAL- AND I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN A REALLY
AWKWARD PLACE RIGHT NOW WHERE
THE STATE COULD SHUT DOWN AGAIN
AT ANY TIME- CIRCLING BACK TO
BEING A SINGLE. INCOME INCOME
HOUSEHOLD WITH. NINE PEOPLE IN
THE HOUSES IS REALLY SCARY-
PANDEMIC IN EIGHTEEN HELP WE
ARE IN A FREE DISTRICT FREE
LUNCH DISTRICTS ARE KIDS
AUTOMATICALLY RECEIVE PANDEMIC
AB T. BUT WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
ANYMORE AND YOU KNOW WE JUST WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT NEXT WHAT NEXT
WEEK LOOKS LIKE NEXT MONTH
LOOKS LIKE IT'S EVERYTHING IS
UNKNOWN RIGHT NOW. AND IT'S
SCARY. AND KERRY MY SEX FOLLOW
QUESTION I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
LIMITATIONS OF YOU KNOW ONE ONE
MALE YOU KNOW PER FAMILY- I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFANTS AT HOME I KNOW I
MENTIONED EARLIER MY- PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND PUT MY BEST
FRIEND FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND-
AND THE NEED FOR. FORMULA FOR
HER CHILD FOR HER INFANT CHILD
AT THAT TIME- JUST WANTED TO.
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING IN
TERMS OF THE LIMITATIONS AND
THE IMPACTS TO YOU KNOW TO YOUR
FAMILY AND YOU KNOW IF COUNTIES
AND- YOU KNOW. IN THE AREA.
OKAY I'M SO THE KIDS AND MY
HOUSEHOLD RANGE FROM SIX TO
SIXTEEN I'M SO INTENSE WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT FORMULA
FORTUNATELY- BUT IN. EARLY
APRIL- WHEN TOILET PAPER AND
EVERYTHING ELSE GOT SCARY ADAM.
SANDLER WHO AISLES WERE BARE
AND- YEAH ESSENTIAL FOOD ITEMS
FOR OUR HOUSEHOLD WERE LIMITED
SO YOU KNOW WE CAN BUY ONE
GALLON OF MILK ONE LOAF OF
BREAD ONE PACKAGE OF MEAT- AND
FOR A LARGE FAMILY. AND THAT
JUST. IT DOESN'T EVEN COVER THE
DAY- WHAT. I RIGHT. THAT WAS
HARD. ALL YET THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHARING YOUR RESTORING YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND I KNOW THAT-
HARPER MISTER VICE CHAIR JOINED
US AT SENATOR JONES I WANT TO
GIVE HIM AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
IF HE WANTS TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY. R. AND WE HAVE
A QUESTION FROM SENATOR PAN.
NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION I JUST
WANT TO THANK OUR WITNESSES FOR
TESTIFYING- AND- JUST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURAGE IN SHARING
YOUR PERSONAL STORIES IT'S NOT
EASY TO DO SO ESPECIALLY THIS
VERY PUBLIC SETTING AND- BUT
WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY IS VERY
IMPORTANT I JUST WANT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR DOING SO. AND I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE- ONCE
AGAIN- MY APPRECIATION TO ALL
OF OUR SPEAKERS TODAY AND IT.
WE WERE LIVING A DIFFICULT TIME
AND I KNOW IT'S A CHALLENGE TO
IT IT'S DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE DIFFICULT EXPERIENCES SO
THAT WE ALL GO THROUGH AND-
YEAH WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
YOU SHARING WITH US FOR
EXPERIENCE. THANK YOU UP
KAREENA KERRY DIANE- FOR BEING
ON OUR PANEL TODAY AND FOR AT
TESTIFYING ON A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. SO AT THIS MOMENT WE
WILL. MOVE ALONG WITH OUR. OUR
SECOND PANEL. AND OUR NEXT
PRESENTER WE HAVE A RYAN
ANDERSON FROM THE ALLEY YOU
KNOW WHEN HE WILL DISCUSS
RECENT STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
YES HELLO. I'M RYAN ANDERSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AND I'M GOING TO BE
PRESENTING FROM A HANDOUT THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE SENATORS
BRIEFING MATERIALS AND FOR
ANYONE. LISTENING AT HOME IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SEE THE HANDOUT
IT'S AVAILABLE ON THE RIGHT
HAND SIDE OF OUR WEBSITE. WHICH
IS L. A. O. DOT CA DOT GOV.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE- A FEDERAL
AND STATE PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
NUTRITION ACCESS. TO HIGHLIGHT
SPECIFIC ACTIONS THE STATE HAS
TAKEN IN RECENT YEARS TO
AUGMENT THOSE PROGRAMS AND ALSO
TO INTRODUCE SOME OF THE- POST
CODE RELATED NUTRITION ACCESS
FOR INSTANCE THE MAIN WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT IN MORE DEPTH
AND THE SUBSEQUENT PANEL. FIRST
TO. JUST GIVE A BROAD OVERVIEW
OF NUTRITION ACCESS PROGRAMS
AND CALIFORNIA. A VARIETY OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OFFERED THAT
SUPPORTED PRIMARILY THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- CONTEXT
YEARS SAID OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYS THIS IS THE WAY
OF PROMTING HUMAN WELFARE BUT
ALSO AS A WAY OF PROMOTING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION SO
WHILE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY OVERSEEN BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE. THAT
INCLUDES OUR TO BROADEST BASED
PROGRAMS- EACH SERVING ABOUT
FOUR MILLION LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THOSE WOULD BE
CALFRESH WHICH PROVIDES A CASH
LIKE BENEFIT. AN ELECTRONIC.
EVERY MONTH- THE AVERAGE
BENEFITS FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLARS PER PERSON PER MONTH
BUT IT VARIES BASED ON FAMILY
SIZE AND INCOME. AND THEN- FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE SCHOOL MEALS
WHICH REACH. NEARLY FOUR
MILLION LOW INCOME- K. TWELVE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS SOME AND
MARGINALIZED GROUPS SUCH SALAS
FOSTER YOUTH OF COURSE MANY
STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM BOTH OF
THOSE PROGRAMS. THERE'S ALSO A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS SUPPORTING-
VIRGIN SIXTY PROVIDERS ON FOOD
BANKS THOSE INCLUDE SOMEONE
STANDING PROGRAMS LIKE THE
EMERGENCY FOOD ACCESS PROGRAMS
WELL SOMETIME LIMITED PROGRAMS
SUCH AS- TRADE MITIGATION AIN'T.
THERE'S ALSO SEVERAL PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT TARGETED
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS THE WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN'S PROGRAMS
AND NUTRITION PROGRAMS OFFERED
UNDER THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT.
OF WHILE MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE PRIMARILY FEDERALLY
SUPPORTED THERE ARE SOME STATE
ONLY PROGRAMS WHICH INCLUDE
LEADING CALIFORNIA FOOD ACCESS
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES A
CALFRESH LIKE BENEFIT. TO ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND-
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE INELIGIBLE
FOR NORMAL CAL STRESS DUE TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS THESE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
THESE ARE LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE NOT RESIDED
IN THE COUNTRY AND- LONG ENOUGH
TO QUALIFY FOR CALFRESH- WE
ALSO HAVE THESE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
THE TRANSITIONAL TRISTIAN
BENEFIT PROGRAMS WHICH SERVE
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. AGAIN WITH THE
CONFERENCE LIKE BENEFITS THESE
ARE HOUSEHOLDS WHICH INCLUDE AT
LEAST. ONE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
RECEIVING SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME. NOW IN RECENT YEARS THE
STATE HAS MADE SEVERAL EFFORTS
TO AUGMENT THESE PROGRAMS
IMPORTANTLY THIS IS INCLUDED
ANY OF THOSE- EFFORTS TO
INCREASE CALFRESH PARTICIPATION
RATE WHICH- STATE HAS
ACCOMPLISHED BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT RATE INCREASE
FROM. 51% 271% BUT ALL THOSE
THINGS SUCH AS RE BRANDING THE
PROGRAM ELIMINATING ASSET
REQUIREMENTS OF PROMOTING NEW
WAYS TO. APPLY AND BE.
CONFIRMED FOR THAT PROGRAM
THOSE CHANGES TOGETHER ABROAD-
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS INTO THE PROGRAM
WHO WERE ELIGIBLE. UNDER
PREVIOUS REGIMES FOR NOT
SIGNING UP. THE STATE ALSO
EXPANDED CALIFORNIA SHE TO A
NEWLY ELIGIBLE POPULATION THOSE
BEING INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SSI
OR S. AS HE PAYMENTS- THIS
ATTENDED A PREVIOUS POLICY
KNOWN AS THE SSI CASH SHOW. IN
THE STATE ACTUALLY DID THIS IN
SUCH A WAY THAT EVEN THAT
MINORITY OF HOUSEHOLDS WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN HARMED. UNDER
IN THE NATION SSI CASH OUT
WHICH PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING AND SSI- EVEN THOSE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN HELD
HARMLESS THAT WAS THROUGH THE
CREATION OF THAT ASIN B. T. N.
B. PROGRAM I MENTIONED EARLIER-
UNDER THIS CHANGE WHICH WAS
MADE JUST A YEAR AGO- OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
HAVE. NEWLY ENROLLED CALFRESH.
THE STATE IS ALSO PROVIDED
ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS TO A
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS MADE
EFFORTS TO. INCREASE THE
PURCHASE OF LOCALLY GROWN FOOD
ESPECIALLY AMONG LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND IT'S MADE
VARIOUS OTHER DOCUMENTATIONS
NUTRITION ACCESS PROGRAMS OVER
THE YEARS. MORE RECENTLY AS WAS
NOTED BY PREVIOUS SPEAKERS-
NUTRITION ACCESS HAS BEEN A BIG
CONCERN- IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES FOLLOWING AND- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE A LOT OF
AID AVAILABLE AND THE STATE
HAS. HAS MADE EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORTS TO UTILIZE MUCH OF THAT
AS POSSIBLE MORE PARTICULAR
THIRTEEN FROM. IRMA'S SO
SERVICES WHICH YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM THE NEXT PANEL
THIS IS INCLUDED IN- PANDEMIC
EVG THIS WAS A ONE TIME. AND- A
LOT OF- ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS PER STUDENT THAT
WAS DELIVERED TO THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION K. TWELVE
STUDENTS THAT WERE AFFECTED BY
SCHOOL CLOSURES IN SPRING- THAT
HAS SINCE BEEN RE AUTHORIZE
FOR. THE FIRST TWO MONTHS OF
THE FALL SEMESTER AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO PLANS FOR EXTENDED
EVENING. THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
YEAR WELL TOGETHER THAT PROGRAM
IS BROUGHT IN SEVERAL MILLION
DOLLARS. TO CALIFORNIA FOR
NUTRITION ACCESS. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO RECEIVED
WAIVERS EACH MONTH TO INCREASE
CALFRESH BENEFITS TO THEIR
MAXIMUM FOR EACH FAMILY SIZE.
THIS HAS AGAIN DELIVERED MORE
THAN A BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION FUNDING
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS-
THE STATE ONCE A NEW MAIL
DELIVERY SERVICE FOR OLDER
ADULTS THE GRADE PLATES.
SERVICE AS USUAL STRUCTURE IN
THAT IT IS SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED TOWARDS INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE NOT ENROLLED IN ANY
OTHER NUTRITION PROGRAMS SUCH
AS- THOSE OPERATED UNDER THE
OLDER AMERICANS ACT- IN
ADDITION TO THAT FEDERAL RELIEF
BILLS HAVE AUGMENTED. OF
FUNDING FOR MOST OF THE MAJOR
FEDERAL PROGRAMS OF WOMEN
INFANTS AND CHILDREN EMERGENCY
FOOD ACCESS PROGRAM OLDER
AMERICANS ACT NUTRITION
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA RECEIVES
MORE THAN MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND
AUGMENTATIONS- BUT THEY JUST
THOSE PROGRAMS. AND THE STATE
BUDGET- THIS MOST RECENT STATE
BUDGET PROVIDED AUGMENTATIONS
AS WELL. BOTH TO- AUGMENTING
THAT MINUTES FOR CALIFORNIA SH
WHICH STATUS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DOCUMENTATION WAS. ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
ALSO AUGMENTING THE FUNDING FOR
FOOD BANKS AGAIN BY ABOUT A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION IT SHOULD ALSO BE
NOTED THAT- THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED SOME ASSISTANCE ON
DOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS LARGELY WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR ANY OF THE
FEDERAL. PROVIDERS FOR THESE
EFFORTS UNDER THE DIRECT RELIEF
ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS
PROGRAM THEY WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
A STATE FUNDING OF UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER INDIVIDUAL
OR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
HOUSEHOLD BUT PROGRAMS.
SUCCESSFULLY ALLOCATED MORE
THAN SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. OF
STATE FUNDING. THAT WAS VERY OF.
SOME RECENT ACTIONS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK MASS TRANSIT THIS PHONE
I'LL TAKE I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SERVICE
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION MISTER
ANDERSON AND- CERTAINLY WE AS A
STATE HAVE TAKEN MANY STEPS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS FOOD INSECURITY
I'M SURE THERE'S MORE WE COULD
TRY TO DO AS WELL- BUT CAN YOU-
WELL FIRST OF ALL I GUESS I
JUST WANTED MAYBE HAVE YOU
COMMENT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
I CALFRESH FOR PEOPLE ON SSI
ASSIST P. IT'S A FAIRLY RECENT
A PROGRAM THAT WAS PASSED-
AFTER DECADES FOR WE DIDN'T DO
THAT AND HOW'S THAT IMPACTED
THOSE FAMILIES ESPECIALLY NOW
THAT WE'RE IN THIS KIND OF DOWN
BUDGET CYCLE- AND THEN MAYBE
PERHAPS- ALSTALK ABOUT- DO
YOU DO YOU HAVE CONCERNS
ISRAELI- IN TERMS OF- FURTHER
FEDERAL FUNDING NEXT YEAR TO BE
A FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
EXPIRING. THAT AT LEAST SO FAR
BECAUSE THERE'S A LACK OF
ACTION AT- THE FEDERAL LEVEL
DATA WE MAY EITHER THOSE
CAPSULECONTAINING SISTER WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO. SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO A STATE THOUGH OUR OWN
REVENUES ARE DOWN SO PERHAPS
YOU CAN SPEAK TO THOSE TWO
ITEMS. THIS COURSE- OKAY. BY
SEVERAL ON THE SSA CACHAO. THE
INDICATIONS ARE POSITIVE
INSOFAR AS- AWFUL LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS SIGNED UP. ELIGIBLE
UNDER CALFRESH AND BELIEVE THE
LATEST FIGURES ARE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND I BELIEVE THAT
WAS WAS CLOSE TO THE MAXIMUM
PARTICIPATION THAT WAS
ESTIMATED AS FOR THE BENEFIT TO
THOSE FAMILIES- AS YOUR WAY
FROM BEING INVOLVED AND A LOT
OF THE SMITHS THE TRICKY PART
WITH PENDING THE SSI CASH ON
POLICY WHAT IS THAT. WHILE MOST
FAMILIES WOULD NECESSARILY BE
BETTER OFF BY RECEIVING THE
ADDITIONAL CALFRESH BENEFIT.
MINORITY FAMILIES WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BECAUSE THE
SSI INCOME RECEIVED BY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE COUNTED AS
INCOME FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND IT WOULD EITHER
REDUCE OR BENEFIT OR A
LAMINATED- THE S. N. B. T. N.
B. PROGRAMS WERE SPECIFICALLY
CREATED TO TARGET THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND- AND AS FAR AS
I KNOW AND I'LL BRING YOUR
QUESTION BACK TO THE ANALYST
WHO PRIMARILY COVERS A PROGRAM.
BUT AS FAR AS I KNOW THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE FUNCTIONING AS
INTENDED AND SO ALL OF THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE NEWLY
ENROLLED IN CALFRESH OR OR
EARNING AT LEAST AS MUCH AS
THEY WERE ON. THE OLD POLICY.
AND MOST OF THEM ARE EARNING
MORE- THE OTHER QUESTION ABOUT
X. THE FEDERAL AID. I DON'T
THERE IS STILL SOME ISSUES THAT
WILL PROVIDED THROUGH CARES
ACTING LAST- CORONAVIRUS
RELEASED FOR- THERE WAS PASSED
BY CONGRESS- THAT WOULD BE ON
THE PANDEMIC EBT SIDE WHICH IS
AGAIN. THE- ONE TIME PAYMENTS
TO STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY SCHOOL CLOSURES.
EXPECTATIONS AS YOU'LL HEAR
FROM DSS ARE DEAD WE WILL. BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THAT PROGRAM
THROUGH THE END OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR AND WE ARE ALSO EXPECTING
TO RECEIVE THE INCREASED
CALFRESH BENEFITS THAT'S
PROVIDED- MONTH BY MONTH WAIVER
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE
EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
THOSE AND TELL THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN
FROM THE CURRENT PANDEMIC- A
LOT OF THESE OTHER. GOOSE AND
IN PARTICULAR THE FUNDING
INCREASE THAT WAS OFFERED TO
OUR EMERGENCY FOOD PROVIDERS
SUCH AS FOOD BANKS WERE ON A
ONE TIME BASIS SO THERE IS SOME
CONCERN THAT- AND I THINK THE
NEXT PANEL SPEAK TO THE ISSUE
OF. SOME ADVOCATES ARE CALLING
THIS THE- T. SHIRT CLICK. AND A
LOT OF THAT FUND WILL BE. BY
THE END DISCOUNT YEAR AND ISN'T
AT THIS TIME BEING REPLACED IT
WOULD NEED TO BE FURTHER.
AUGMENTATIONS FROM EITHER THE
FEDERAL OR STATE GOVERNMENT- IF
DEMAND REMAINS HIGH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WANTED TO GO AHEAD
AND- YOUR FURTHER ASK AT WATER
SOME OF THE IT JUST IN GENERAL
SOME CONCERNS THAT. YOU'RE KIND
OF EXPECTING OR LOOKING INTO
ARE JUST KIND OF SEEING HER
COME ACROSS- I MEAN. ALL THE
PROGRAMS AND THE FUNDING THAT
THAT HAS COME IN A MINUTE IT'S
A GREAT THING BUT- BUT WHAT IS
IT. THAT WE SHOULD KNOW ABOUT
IN TERMS OF CONCERN SAID THAT
YOU MAY HAVE HER. THAT WE
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT RIGHT.
CERTAINLY THE PRIMARY CONCERN
IS THAT AS YOUR FIRST PANEL
NOTED JUST TO. DEMAND CONTINUES
TO BE GREAT FOR THESE PROGRAMS
SAID AS MUCH ASSISTANCE HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE. THERE ARE STILL
MANY FAMILIES OUT THERE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY
AND- ALSO TO SENATOR PAN'S
PREVIOUS QUESTION. WHEN A LOT
OF THESE INITIAL RELIEF
MEASURES FOR OR WERE PASSED IN
THE SPRING IT WASN'T CLEAR JUST
HOW LONG- THE UNCERTAINTY AND-
STAGNANT ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
WOULD CONTINUE. FOLLOWING SEND
AND MAKE A I THINK RIGHT NOW
THERE IS SOME CONCERN THAT WE
MAY BE IN FOR A WATCH MUCH
LONGER PERIOD OF STAGNATION OF
THE INCREASED DEMAND FOR THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH MAY SPEAK TO A
NEED FOR FURTHER ASSISTANCE- I
WOULD SAY ONE THING- I WOULDN'T
EXPRESSES A CONCERN BUT IT IS
PERHAPS A SURPRISE- INSTEAD TO
SOME OF US ARE. WOMEN LOOKING
AT NUMBERS HAS. BEEN THAT-
HOUSE CHRISTIAN- IT IS HASN'T
WELL HAS INCREASED SINCE. MANY
FOLKS BEEN ROLLED IN THE
PROGRAM IS HAS NOT QUITE THE
DEGREE THAT WE X. GIVEN.
CURRENT AND NUMBER ARE- I DON'T
SAY THAT OUR OFFICE HAS DONE A
LOT OF WORK AND SAID. ASKING
COUNTY OFFICES LEGAL ASSISTANCE
SERVICES CONSUMERS THEMSELVES
WHETHER- IS RELATIVELY LOW
ENROLLMENT MIGHT BE DUE TO SOME
ACCESS PROBLEMS AND WE HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYTHING FROM ANY OF
THOSE SOURCES THAT WOULD
INDICATE THAT'S A MAJOR CONCERN-
BUT I WILL SAY IT IS STILL
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE. BUT
IT STANDS OUT A LITTLE BIT AND
IN PARTICULAR WE HAVEN'T SEEN A
LARGE CASELOAD INCREASE AFTER
THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF THE
PROGRAM AND IN FACT IN RECENT
MONTHS- PARTICIPATION HAS
DECLINED SOMEWHAT AND WE'RE
JUST NOT ENTIRELY SURE. WHAT
THAT IS. DO YOU FEEL THAT IN
TERMS OF ALL THE- THE FOR THE
RESOURCES AT THE STATE HAS BEEN
GETTING- YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
FOOD. TO FILL THAT THE ALL THE
PROGRAMS ARE BEING. MAXIMIZED
TO THE FULL CAPACITY OF AN- AND
DELIVERING FOOD TO- OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT QUESTION TO ANSWER
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE- CERTAINLY
THE PROGRAMS IF NOT- IN
STRUGGLING TO FIND ENOUGH.
PEOPLE WITH MEAT OUT THERE AND
THEN MANY TIMES IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO GET AND THE SAME WITH THE
DIRECTOR WHAT THE ASSISTANCE
FOR IMMIGRANTS PROGRAM THAT
FUNDING WAS ABLE TO FIND A HOME
VERY QUICKLY A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN THAT HAPPENS RIGHT IS BUT
IF THE PROGRAM ISN'T
UNDERFUNDED AND THERE'S
REASONABLE CONCERN ARE IT ISN'T
OBVIOUSLY OVERFUNDED THERE'S
REASONABLE CONCERN THAT IT
MIGHT BE UNDER FROM. BUT IF IT
IF IT WAS THAT EASY FIND ENOUGH
WILLING- RECIPIENTS. AND MAYBE
FURTHER AUGMENTATIONS ARE
WARRANTED IT'S A LITTLE HARD TO
TELL FROM. IN SACRAMENTO
EXACTLY WHAT THE UNMET NEED IS-
THIS JUST SAY AGAIN THE THING
ABOUT THE CALFRESH IS. WE STILL
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS THERE
AND THAT MIGHT ALSO BE
INDICATIVE EITHER OF THE FACT
THAT NEED ISN'T AS GREAT AS- WE
ARE PROJECTED TOWARD THAT-
THERE ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS OUT
THERE THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM WHO. JUST HAVEN'T
FOUND A WAY TO GET. SO HOW DO
YOU THINK WE COULD AT BEST
FIGURE OUT THIS MONTH YOU KNOW
UNMET NEED. THAT SAYS A
CHALLENGING QUESTION I'M AFRAID
I DON'T HAVE ANY CSU FOR IT NOW
MIGHT BE A USEFUL QUESTION FOR
SOME OF THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR SONG- YOUR EXPAND
WILL. WHAT WE APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US HERE TODAY AND- JUST
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ANY LAST
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEN
NONE OKAY WE WILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS BILL WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL. WHICH
WILL SHARE EFFORTS TO MEET
INCREASED NEED FOR NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE STRYCOVA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
CHANGE THE ORDER OF OUR AGENDA
SO A RYAN BURRIS THE
REPRESENTED FROM THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. WELL FALL
ALEXIS FERNANDES WAS
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US AND- PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. HELLO SELECT
ALEXIS ARE YOU THERE. I AM HERE
OKAY THANK YOU BUT I'M READY
HEARING OKAY HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE CANADIAN THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME SO MY NAME'S
ALEXIS FERNANDEZ AND THE CHIEF
OF THE CALFRESH AND NUTRITION
BRANCH OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES MY BRANCH
OVERSEES THE ADMINISTRATION OF
SEVEN FEDERAL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS SEVERAL
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS MANY OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
TODAY. IMPORTANTLY WE OVERSEE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STATE'S
SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR SNAP I
KNOWN AS CALFRESH IN CALIFORNIA
THE SCALE SCOPE AND REACH OF
SNAP AS AN ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
MAKE IT THE NATION'S MOST
IMPORTANT ANTI HUNGER PROGRAM.
NOT SAID CALFRESH CANNOT DO IT
ALONE- A FULL ECOSYSTEM OF
NUTRITION SUPPORTS INCLUDING
MANY OF WHICH MY FELLOW PANEL
MEMBERS WILL SPEAK TO TODAY
MAKE UP THE NUTRITION SAFETY
NET. I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO OUR
EFFORTS TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY INCLUDING
OUR WORK DISTRIBUTING EMERGENCY
FOOD. EFFORTS TO ENSURE CALPERS
BENEFIT ACCESS DURING THE
EMERGENCY AND ALSO TELL YOU
ABOUT OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
IMPLEMENT THE FIRST EVER
PANDEMIC AB T. PROGRAM SO BEAR
WITH ME QUITE A BIT OF CONTENT.
THE STATE'S EMERGENCY FOOD
SYSTEM PROVIDES A CRITICAL
RESOURCE FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE IT
NOT ONLY ALLOWS FAMILIES TO
MAKE ENDS MEET BUT IT MAY ALSO
BE THE ONLY RESOURCE AVAILABLE
WHEN ALL OR SOME MEMBERS ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL FOOD
BENEFITS. I WANT TO SHARE A BIT
MORE ON THIS POINT BASED ON
WHAT WE LEARNED IMPLEMENTING
THE DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. DRAY PROVIDED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND DISASTER
ASSISTANCE AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WERE
ASKED TO ANSWER A QUESTION
ABOUT UNMET NEEDS HOUSING WAS
THE HIGHEST UNMET. NEED 86%
SELECT THIS OPTION NOT SO. THIS
HIGHEST WAS FOR. FIFTY THREE.
SAID FOOD WAS AN UNNAMED. THREE
RECIPIENTS ALSO REPORTED
RELYING ON LOCAL FOOD BANKS AND
SOMETIMES GOING HUNGRY AS A
PANDEMIC LAST BREADWINNERS
UNEMPLOYED. I SURE THESE
DETAILS WITH YOU TO EMPHASIZE
THE ROLE OF THE EMERGENCY FOOD
NETWORK AND SUPPORTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHEN FEDERAL
PROGRAMS MAY NOT BE ABLE TO.
BECAUSE OUR PARTNERS ARE AT THE
TABLE WILL BE SHARING THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN MORE DETAIL ONLY
SPEND A FEW MINUTES ON THE
SUPPORTIVE ROLE THAT WE PLAYED
THESE LAST FEW MONTHS. BYE NEED
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS WILL
HAVE DISTRIBUTED A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AND-
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
DIAPERS. I WILL HAVE PROVIDED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT FOR CLOSELY
RELATED FOOD EXPENSES. AND
THESE ARE ALL OF THE- EXTRA
INVESTMENTS IF YOU WILL
SPECIFIC TO THE PANDEMIC. MUCH
OF THIS WAS STATE FUNDED AND A
RESULT OF THE LEGISLATURES AND
ADMINISTRATIONS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING ADEQUATE
EMERGENCY FOOD RESOURCES. ON
AVERAGE WERE DISTRIBUTING A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
FOOD BOXES A MONTH AN ESTIMATE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO SO
IT CURRENT FUNDING UNTIL MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THROUGHOUT
TWENTY WE'VE ALSO SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INFUSION OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES RYAN MENTIONED THESE
TOTALING AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
EMERGENCY FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. REPRESENTING ABOUT A
33% INCREASE FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BRING IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
RESOURCES FOR EMERGENCY FOOD
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
WITHOUT FEDERAL ACTION WE
ANTICIPATE A SIGNIFICANT GAP IN
RESOURCES. OR THE EMERGENCY
FOOD NETWORK WHEN YOU COMPARE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND CURRENT STATE FUNDING
WILL BE ABLE TO FILL THAT GAP.
WELL EMERGENCY FOOD IS AN
ESSENTIAL RESOURCE CALFRESH
PLAYS A KEY ROLE IN PREVENTING
HUNGER BY PROVIDING INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WITH LOW INCOME.
CONSIDERABLE MONTHLY FOOD
BENEFITS. IN APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY OUR APPLICATION VOLUME
PEAKED AT JUST OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALFRESH APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED DISTRICT WIDE IN ONE
WEEK. AND SINCE LEVELED OUT WE
ARE NOW ACCEPTING IN THE RANGE
OF FORTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS A WEEK CLOSER TO
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS OUR CASE
LOAD OR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SERVED. THE MONTH OF JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY JUST OVER FOUR
POINT EIGHT FOUR MILLION
INDIVIDUALS- AND HAS NOW-
EXCEEDED. FOR THE MOST RECENT
MONTH FOR WHICH DATA IS
AVAILABLE- FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION. BENEFITS ISSUED IN
SEPTEMBER TOTALED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE ISSUANCE OF
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS WHICH I'LL
SPEAK TO IN JUST A MINUTE WE'RE
PROVIDING A HUNDRED NINETY TWO
DOLLARS A MONTH IN FOOD
BENEFITS PER PERSON. THIS IS
CONSIDERABLE IN TERMS OF
CALIFORNIANS ABILITY TO PUT
ENOUGH FOOD ON THE TABLE AND
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIES- IS THAT
SIGNIFICANT STIMULUS AS
RECIPIENTS TEND TO SPEND
BENEFITS RIGHT AWAY AT LOCAL
STORES. I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO
MORE DETAIL- FROM A DATA
PERSPECTIVE I HAVE SUBMITTED
SOME SLIDES FOR YOUR REFERENCE.
INCLUDING OUR SSI RECIPIENTS
CASELOAD WHICH I JUST MENTIONED
AND- DOCTOR PAN DID RAISE THIS
AND HIS COMMENTS OF FOR THE
MONTH OF AUGUST OR SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY. WE'RE ACTUALLY
SERVING OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND SS I
RECIPIENTS AS A RESULT OF THE
EXPANSION AND DEFINITELY. BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE INFO ABOUT
THAT IS THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
IN RESPONSE TO APPLICATION
VOLUME CASELOAD INCREASES AND
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS TO OUR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS AND WORK
FORCE CAPACITY- WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FLEXIBILITIES
AND PROVIDED GUIDANCE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO
COUNTIES WITH THE AIM OF
MAINTAINING TIMELY ACCESS TO
BENEFITS. OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE IMPLEMENTED SEVEN
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATIVE WAIVERS
RANGING FROM REPORTING
FLEXIBILITY THROUGH WAIVERS OF
THE INTERVIEW REQUIREMENTS.
THESE WAIVERS PROVIDED WORKLOAD
RELIEF FOR COUNTIES FREEING UP
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS APPLICATION
VOLUME AND MAINTAIN TIMELINESS.
IMPORTANTLY ALSO SUPPORTED
ACCESS TO BENEFITS BY OUR
CLIENTS. BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THESE FLEXIBILITIES ARMY AB
ALTHOUGH BY CONGRESS OR THE
USDA WE WILL CONTINUE TO ASSESS
IMPLEMENTATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. RT ALSO GUIDANCE ON
DISCLOSURE AND REPORTING
PROCEDURES AND JUST RECENTLY
ISSUED GUIDANCE REITERATING THE
NEED TO ENSURE IN PERSON ACCESS
TO BENEFITS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
PHONE AND INTERNET BASED
SERVICES. I WOULD HAVE
INCREASED OUR THE LAND OF THE
PANDA WHICH WE'RE STILL IN.
THIS GUIDANCE INCLUDE RESOURCE
AND BEST PRACTICES SHOULD SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
DURING THESE ARE PRESS TIME.
OUR OPERATE TEAM CAN TO CONDUCT
REVIEWS- WE ARE AGAIN.
TIMELINESS AND OTHER ACTOR OF
OUR OFF. AND EXPANDING ACT TO
RE WILL FOR SERVICES THROUGH
NEW REMOTE LEARNING TOOLS AND
THINGS LIKE AN INNOVATIVE
LAPTOP LOANER PROGRAM. TO
ADDRESS BENEFIT ADEQUACY WE'VE
ISSUED AT EIGHT MONTHS OF
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS THUS FAR
AND RYAN MENTIONED THESE
EMERGENCY ALLOTMENTS BRING
EVERY RETAIL FRANCHISE SOLD TO
THE MAXIMUM ALLOTMENT BASED ON
HOUSEHOLD SIZE. SO FOR EXAMPLE
A HOUSEHOLD OF THREE RECEIVES
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH WHEN YOU TOTAL
THEIR REGULAR CALFRESH AND
THEIR EMERGENCY ALONG. THESE
SUPPLEMENTS ARE REPRESENTS OVER
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ISSUE THEM SO
LONG AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MAKES THEM AVAILABLE TO US.
APRIL WE WERE THE FIRST STATE
TO EXPAND IMPLEMENTATION OF T.
V. T. ONLINE PURCHASING IN
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT
WE WATCH WITH TO RETAILERS
AMAZON AND WALMART AND- JUST
THIS MONTH ON NOVEMBER TWELFTH
BY THE ALBERTSON'S FAMILY OF
BRANDS WHICH INCLUDE BONDS AND
SAFE WAY A LAUNCH EDT ONLINE
PURCHASING FOR PICK UP AT
PARTICIPATING STORES AND IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
WANT YOU TO BE ONLINE FOR HOME
DELIVERY. INDIRECT WE'VE ALSO
HAD TO RESPOND TO WILDFIRE
SEASON UNLIKE ANY OTHER. SO IN
RESPONSE TO POWER OUTAGES THAT
RESULTED FROM A PREVENTIVE
MEASURES AND WILDFIRES
THEMSELVES WE'VE ISSUED
AUTOMATIC REPLACEMENT. HOW
FRESH BENEFITS TOTAL VALUE OF
OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- AND
WE'VE REQUESTED WAIVERS
ALLOWING HOUSEHOLDS MORE TIME
TO REQUEST A BENEFIT
REPLACEMENTS AND PURCHASED
FOODS WHEN THEY MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO A KITCHEN BECAUSE OF
A DISASTER. WE ARE STILL IN THE
MIDST OF OPERATIONS THIS WEEK
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED DISASTER
CALFRESH. IN NINETEEN COUNTIES
DISASTER CAL FROM TEMPER FOOD.
FOR IN THE IN FAMILIES THAT ARE
NOT TYPICALLY ELLA FOR A CAL
FRESH BUT TYPICALLY DOES
CALFRESH WILL AN PERSON. INTO
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO SPEAK UP
FOR FEDERAL FLOOD. THAT HAVE
ALLOWED US FOR THE FIRST TIME
TO OPERATE PRIMARILY BY SOME.
INCLUDING IN INTERVIEWS I
THOUGHT. IN ADDITION TO THIS
WORK IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED THAT
WE RECEIVED A FEDERAL FEDERAL
APPROVAL TO OPERATE TO THE
PANDEMIC ET OR PT T. PROGRAM.
IN RESPONSE TO KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED SCHOOL FACILITY
CLOSURES HAVE PROVIDES FOOD
BENEFITS TO CHILDREN. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE SCHOOL MEALS AND WHO
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC RELATED
SCHOOL FACILITY CLOSURE MAY NOT
HAVE READY ACCESS TO THOSE
MEALS. SO BETWEEN APRIL AND
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WE
OPERATED- WHAT WE'RE NOW
CALLING PT ONE POINT OH OR THE
ORIGINAL P. B. PROGRAM. THE
USDA PROVIDED GUIDANCE ON MARCH
TWENTIETH APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
OUR PLAN WAS APPROVED AND BY
MAY EIGHTH WE HAD ISSUED OUR
FIRST PT CARD. THE GREAT
MAJORITY OF FAMILIES RECEIVED A
STANDARD BENEFIT OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS
PER CHILD- REPRESENTING A
SIGNIFICANT BOOST IN NUTRITION
SUPPORT. AND BY LATE SEPTEMBER
WE HAD WRAPPED UP THE PROGRAM
HAVING ISSUED BENEFITS TO OVER
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
CHILDREN OR ABOUT 95% OF THOSE
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE. TOTALING
NEARLY ONE POINT FOUR BILLION.
DOLLARS AND THE BENEFITS.
NUMBER WERE ALSO AGREED TO
ISSUE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS TO
CHILDREN WHO HAVE PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED PTT ONE POINT OH OR
THE ORIGINAL PROGRAM. ONLY
BEGAN ISSUING THOSE BENEFITS ON
OCTOBER TWENTY SIX AND WILL
CONTINUE DOING SO THROUGH THE
END OF DECEMBER. THOSE
EXTENSION BENEFITS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO TOTAL ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
NUTRITION. SUPPORT NO
SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANCE IN AND
RYAN AND ARE OTHERS SPEAKERS
MENTION THIS AT THE END OF
OCTOBER CONGRESS AUTHORIZED THE
SECOND ROUND OF PANDEMIC U. T.
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR THAT'S A SCHOOL
YOU'RE WERE CURRENTLY IN NOW.
WILL BE CALLING THAT TIME AT
LEAST FOR NOW PANDEMIC YOU NEED
TO TWO POINT OO I LIKE THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM IT WILL SERVE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS ARE UNIQUELY THIS
IS NEW. WE WILL HAVE THE OPTION
TO SERVE AS YOUNGER CHILDREN
WHO ARE CHILD CARE AGE AND WHO
WOULD HAVE RECEIVED A FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEAL AT CHILD
CARE IF NOT FOR DISRUPTIONS IN
ACCESS I DO THE PANDEMIC. IT
WILL. A P. B. T. TWO POINT OH
WON'T NECESSARILY BE EASY
EITHER WILL BE EXTENSIVE DATA
REQUIREMENTS WILL BE SERVING A
NEW POPULATION OF YOUNGER
CHILDREN. WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
SO OVER THE LENGTH OF AN ENTIRE
SCHOOL YEAR. ABOUT SEVEN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WE'RE UP FOR THE
CHALLENGE. WE JUST RECEIVED
PARTIAL FEDERAL GUIDANCE
YESTERDAY LATE BREAKING. UP FOR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AND WE ARE
NOW WAITING ON GUIDANCE FOR
CHILDREN WHO ATTEND CHILD CARE.
WILL BEGIN DEVELOPING OUR PLANS
AND HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT TIMELY- AGAIN LOTS OF
WRITING HERE ON. FEDERAL
GUIDANCE BUT- WE ARE STARTING
THAT PROCESS TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT THE NEW PROGRAM.
WHICH WE'VE BEEN QUITE BUSY BUT
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE AS I JUST
SUGGESTED- WE- ARE THE IMPACTS
OF THE PANDEMIC CONTINUE TO BE
FELT BY ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CALFRESH AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
NUTRITION SUPPORTS WILL PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN ENSURING A TO
HELP THE. HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL. I CAN'T TRIP UP
WITHOUT THINKING LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO PREVENTING
EXPERIENCE OF HUNGER AS WE WORK
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND OUR PARTNERS-
WITHOUT THEM REALLY NONE OF
THIS COULD HAVE HAPPENED SO THE
FOOD BANKS COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION OR OUTREACH PARTNER
OUR CLIENTS. ADVOCATES WHO THAT
KEEP US- ATTUNED TO WHAT OUR
CLIENTS ARE EXPERIENCING. OF
COURSE- I SHOUT OUT TO MY TEAM
AS WELL FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE
WORK I KNOW THEY'RE WATCHING
TODAY- SO I RECOGNIZE SUCH
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE MORE
DETAILS AS NEEDED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS RANDA'S
APPRECIATE- THE M. YOUR TASK IF
YOU CAN JUST STAND BY THERE MAY
BE QUESTIONS LATER. WHEN THE-
TRIMMING ITS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. BYE FOR RIGHT
NOW WHEN WE GO ON TO RYAN
BURRIS DIRECTOR OF RECOVERY
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND- MISTER BURSON IT'S TIME IF
YOU CAN. GO AHEAD AND SHARE
WITH US PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF CAL YESS EFFORTS TO
MEET THE INCREASED NEED FOR
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE COMING TO
COPE NINETEEN. ENDEMIC
PREVALENCE OF FOOD INSECURITY
AS WE'VE HEARD AS MEDICALLY
INCREASE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THE
STATE HOME ATER SOCIAL BUSINESS
POLICIES AND ECONOMIC
DESTRUCTION BROUGHT FORTH BY
THIS PANDEMIC. TODAY THE STATE
IS FORTY ONE COUNTIES IN THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE HERE WHICH
IMPACTS OVER 94% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. OVER A
HOUSE FACE AN EVEN GREATER
CHALLENGE TO ATTAIN MAILS AS
MANY MAY BE FEARFUL OF RISK OF
EXPOSURE WE'RE GOING TO THE
GROCERY STORE UNABLE TO ATTEND
GROUP MAYOR WAS AT SENIOR
CENTERS ARE. FAITH BASED
INSTITUTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF THIS AND SEND IT WITHOUT THE
ASSISTANCE OF FAMILY OR
NEIGHBORS TO PROVIDE MEALS DUE
TO THE STATE HOME ATER AT SOME
PLACE. ELSE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE CALIFONIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES HAS MET THIS CHALLENGE
IN A VERY UNIQUE WAY FOR THE
CREATION OF THE GREAT PLAINS
DELIVERED PROGRAM FIRST MY
HIRING AND IT'S IN THE- NOT
ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA BUT THE
AUTOMATION. THE PURPOSE OF THAT
MEETING UP IN NEW GREAT PLAINS
DELIVERED PROGRAM IS TO VOTE
ONE IT WAS A PROVIDE MEALS TO
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER AND
ADULTS SIXTY AND SIXTY FOUR WHO
ARE AT HIGH RISK AS DEFINED. BY
THE CDC GUIDELINES THEN AGAIN
WHO ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS MEALS
FOR STAYING AT HOME AND ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR OTHER NUTRITION
PROGRAMS. ALSO THIS PROGRAM IS
TO SUPPORT LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND OTHER FOOD EITHER IS AN
AGRICULTURE WORKERS WHO HAVE
CLOSE OR ARE STRUGGLING TO
REMAIN OPEN SIX OF THE CODE
NINETEEN MITIGATION- TACTICS. A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM
UNDER THE OVERARCHING
PARAMETERS ESTABLISHED BY THE
EMERGENCY FEEDING PROGRAM
APPROVED BY FEMA ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
HELLO YES AND SEE HHS
DEVELOPING GREAT PLAINS
DELIVERY PROGRAM WHICH TARGETS.
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. BUT FROM AIM TO
SERVICE. WHO ARE AND- FOR EXIST
STATE FEDERAL PROGRAM. ALSO TO
THIS ALSO SUPPORTS LOW REST.
PROVIDERS EVERYBODY WORKER
ANOTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS CLOSE.
AND ARE WHO ARE STILL FROM OPEN.
DUE TO THE PENDING. ONCE THE
FOR WAS CREATED EVERY BY THING.
HELLO YES CJ STAFF LED-
OUTREACH BY MAKING PHONE CALLS
A WEEK. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CITY AND COUNTY JURISDICTIONS
TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN
THE PROGRAM AND ITS EARLY
STAGES. IN ADDITION OFFICE
HOURS CONFERENCE CALLS CONTINUE
TO BE HELD ONCE A WEEK ON
WEDNESDAY TO ENCOURAGE
FEEDBACK. ANSWER PROGRAM
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS RELATED
QUESTIONS FROM LOGAN MINISTRY
THERE'S ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION. HELLO YES ALSO
MAINTAINS WEEKLY COMMUNICATION
VIA EMAIL WITH PARTICIPATING
LOCAL ADMINISTRATORS BY
PROVIDING NOTES FROM THE OFFICE
OUR CONFERENCE CALLS.
NUTRITIONAL DOCUMENTS PROVIDED
BY CDA. AND OTHER PROGRAMMATIC
REMINDERS. AUTHORITIES ARE
MINUTES PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RESIDE
WITH LOCAL WITH STATE SUPPORT.
A LOCAL MAGISTRATE OR COULD BE
ANY OF THE FOLLOWING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AGENCIES EITHER
INDEPENDENTLY OR AS COORDINATED
EFFORTS SUCH AS THE LOCAL AREA
AGENCY ON AGING AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AGENT ACCOUNT
SERVICES A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. OUR
MUNICIPALITY EARLY THERE'S
THIRTY TWO CITY AND COUNTIES
OPERATIVES A PAID IN THE
PROGRAM OF WHICH TEN ARE LED BY
TRIPLE A.'S IN TWENTY TWO A LED
BY THEIR CITY AND COUNTY
COUNTERPARTS. ETHNOLOGY NOT THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL JURISDICTION
AGENCY JUST SERVICE POSH
POPULATION VARIES WIDELY WEBER
MINISTRIES OF THE PROGRAM ARE
EXPECTED. TO BE PREPARED TO PUT
APPROPRIATE PROGRAM SUPPORT
MECHANISMS IN PLACE IS NEEDED
MHL OF THE PROGRAM TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF. THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THEIR PROGRAM. PROGRAM BECAUSE
WILL BE LIVE JUST SIX DOLLARS
FOR A THREE DALY. INCLUDE OF
THE LET PER DAY YES- DOLLAR
FIGURE WAS AGREED UPON AND IS
BASED ON THE AVERAGE OF THE U.
S. GENERAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION PER DIEM RATES
FOR CALIFORNIA. GRAHAM BECAUSE
BREAKDOWN ARE AS FOLLOWS. ABOUT
SIXTY SIX DOLLARS 75% WILL BE
PAID VIA THEME OTHER ARSHER
EIGHTEEN AND THREE QUARTERS.
PERCENT WILL BE PAID THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA DISASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT SHARE IN SIX AND
A QUARTER PERCENT THROUGH THE
LOCAL SHARE. AS OF NOVEMBER
SEVENTEENTH. TWENTY TWENTY A
TOTAL OF FOURTEEN HOW MANY
CITIES HAVE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY FEMA
WITH FEDERAL FUNDS OBLIGATED-
OF WHICH NINE COUNTIES A HARDER
RECEIVED ALREADY HAVE RECEIVED
50% OF THEIR SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OFF IN MY CAR SHARE
FOR COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED 75% OF THEIR 75%
CULTURE. WHEN CITIES APPROVED A
DROPDOWN COLLEGE AS SOON AS ALL
OTHER REQUESTED DOCUMENTS ARE
SUBMITTED IN TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES AND CITIES ARE
PROJECTS ARE IN PROCESS AND CAL
YES WORKS WITH THEM EVERY. DAY
TO GET THIS THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
SIX OUR- OF THE BEGINNING OF.
IN AND- I'M CHICAGO ELEVEN SO.
WE RECEIVED OF LETTERS INTENT A
FEW THREE. I BREAK DOWN OF THAT
IS NINETEEN COUNTIES WERE
INTERESTED IN THIRTY FOUR
CITIES. IT'S COMING NINETEEN
LAB CONFIRMED POSITIVE CASES
ARE RELATED DEATHS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE IN THE STATE THE
CARRIER SCREENPLAYS TEAM WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH COUNTY
LEADERS TO ENCOURAGE PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION AS PEOPLE CAN
STILL SIGN UP. TODAY YOU CAN
PARTICIPATE- THE GREAT NEWS OF
THE PROGRAM TODAY TOTAL LOCAL
MINISTRY DELIVERED FOOD
CURRENTLY THIRTY TO KNOW HOW
HIGH WAS FORTY COUNTIES AND
pINCLUDED 550-003-0090 FIVE
INDIVIDUALS EACH DAY- WE HAVE
SINCE EARLY MAY HAVE ALREADY
DELIVERED SEVENTEEN MILLION A
1-004-900-0500 THIRTY SEVEN-
MEALS- FOR THE GREAT PLAINS
PROGRAM THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
AS FAR AS PROVIDERS CURRENTLY
BEING CONTRACTED SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY THREE. PEOPLE ARE
SUPPORTING- BE CURRENTLY THIRTY
TWO. OUT CITIES AND COUNTIES
BETTER PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM- ACROSS THE STATE- WITH
THIS- PROGRAM IS ALREADY
CREATED. ALMOST TEN THOUSAND
JOBS FOR FOOD PROVIDERS AND
THEIR STAFF THAT OTHERWISE MAY
NOT BE EMPLOYED OR WORK IN
TODAY- IN A PRETTY REMARKABLE
STAT AMONG THE CURRENTLY
CONTRACTED FOOD PROVIDERS OVER
HALF 58% IDENTIFIED AS
MINORITY. OWNED FOOD PROVIDERS
IN CLOSE AND I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU. IN FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING FOOD
ASSISTANCE FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS UNDISCOVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. OF THE PANELISTS MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BYRD- MOVE ON TO THE-
PANEL AND MUST AND- QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW- FROM THE- MANY OKAY-
AND IS NEXT IS A- KATHY CENTER
LEE MCDONALD'S ARE CORRECT. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR NICE TO CEO
TO CHANGE EVERYONE THANKS TO
THE SENATORS AND THEIR STAFF
FOR PUTTING THAT THE HEARING
TOGETHER OBVIOUSLY A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND I THINK
THAT PERTH THE PANEL ESPECIALLY
THE TO- INDIVIDUAL CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE SUFFERING. FOOD
INSECURITY REALLY I THINK
BROUGHT THAT MESSAGE HOME FOR
ALL OF US TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN DO. EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO
SUPPORT OUR OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND IN THE CASE OF
THE WTA SUPPORTER HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING OUT THERE
ARE DOING THAT OUR REGION
MAKING AS MANY. FOLKS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH- ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT AND HELP THEM NOT ONLY
GET ON THE PROGRAM BUT ALSO
RETAIN THE PROGRAM. I WANTED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE COUNTY HAS.
SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN IN SOME OF THE
INNOVATIONS AND THEN SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN A FEW IDEAS FOR
FLEXIBILITY THAN THAT OF COURSE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. AS
THE- ALEXIS HERNANDEZ NOTED
FROM PDFS WE DID SEE QUITE A
SIGNIFICANT SPIKE IN
APPLICATIONS VERY EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC DURING A FIVE WEEK
PERIOD OF ABOUT MID MARCH TO
LATE APRIL WE RECEIVED ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS JUST ALL IN THAT
FIVE WEEK PERIOD IF YOU COUNT A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AROUND AS IT
WAS HE CAN GOING DOWN A LITTLE
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. WHICH IS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT HE TYPICALLY WE
WOULD HAVE SEEN THAT TIED A
STEADY PACE OF AROUND FORTY
THOUSAND A WEEK NOT THE NINETY
THOUSAND TO ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT WE'RE SEEING
DURING. THOSE FEW WEEKS IF YOU
AVERAGE THEM OUT. I MORE OPEN
SEEING ANYTHING OVER. I AN
INCREASE CASELOAD OF. IF YOU
THINK I WHAT WE EING PER. BY
IS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. BACK IN JANUARY
BEFORE ALL OF THIS HAPPENED AT
THE PET PANDEMIC HIT IN MID
MARCH. THE ORIGINAL JANUARY
BUDGET PROJECTED A DECLINE.
THAT CAN'T DECLINE IT ACTUALLY
STARTED BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
FOR CALIFORNIA. WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF LAST YEAR AND THE
EXPANSION OF THE EFFORT BY
POPULATION. THEY'RE GONNA STUDY
THE QUIET AND THE REASON FOR
THAT WAS LARGELY DUE TO THE
IMPROVING ECONOMY. THAT HAD
BEEN LONG SUSTAINED OVER THOSE
YEARS. SO OVER NINETEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND- NEVER BEEN UP
PROJECTED DROP OF ABOUT THREE
POINT THREE PERCENT. AND BY
NEXT JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ARE- CASELOAD PROJECTIONS OF
THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS NOT
INDIVIDUALS. WAS PROJECTED AT
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION. AS OF.
THE END OF LAST MONTH THE MOST
RECENT DATA- UPDATED- IN LATE
OCTOBER. WE WERE CARRYING TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CASES THAT
YOU CAN BE QUITE A SUBSTANTIAL.
DIFFERENCE NOT JUST IN SORT OF
ABSOLUTE GROWTH BUT ALSO IF YOU
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE WERE
EXPECTING TO SEE THAT CONTINUE
TO QUIET. NOW HAS REVERSED AND
GONE WELL ABOVE WHERE WE
THOUGHT THAT WE WOULD BE. AND
SO- COUNTY FOR THAT SAME KIND
THEMSELVES WORK WERE.
STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE DOING- FOLLOWING
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. TO TRY TO KEEP
THE DOORS OPEN EITHER LITERALLY
OR FIGURATIVELY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN STILL GAIN
ACCESS TO THE AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE OPERATE. THE
MOST OF THE COUNTIES TODAY HAVE
AT LEAST ONE OFFICE OPEN AND
MANY HAVE ALL OR MOST OF THEIR
OFFICES OPEN. AT TIMES- THEY
MAY HAVE LIMITED HOURS OR
LIMITED SERVICES OR REQUIRE
REQUIRE APPOINTMENTS. FOR
SERVICES THAT MIGHT TAKE A I
BIT LONGER ACTUAL FILING APPLE.
OR ENTERED FOR WHO ARE TO COME
IN AND THAT- AND IF YOU- HAVE
STAFF ON HAND TO DO. IN PERSON
TRIAGE OR END OR SORT OF WALK
UP WINDOWS AND WALK UP SERVICE
FOR FOLKS TO COME TO THAT- LAW
OFFICE EVEN AT THE OFFICE MAY
NOT OTHERWISE BE GENERALLY OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC. THEY'RE ABLE TO
HELP THEM IN A DISTANCE AWAY
THAT WILL ENABLE THEIR SERVICES
TO BE PROVIDED TO THEM. WE'VE
ALSO SEEN A PRACTICE USED
INCREASINGLY ACROSS THE COUNTY
THE FACT I KNOW OF ONLY ONE
COUNTY HAT DIDN'T HAVE IT IN
PLACE- IN A RECENT SURVEY. AND
THAT WAS A SMALL COUNTY THAT
NEVER CLOSE- IF THE USER DROP
BOXES. SO BOXES WERE
INDIVIDUALS CAN DROP
APPLICATIONS VERIFICATION THAT
ARE NEEDED TO COMPLETE THAT
PROCESS SAYING- INFORMATION
ABOUT CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED REDETERMINATION. AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO THEY CAN
LEAVE THAT INFORMATION AT THE
COUNTY FOR SOMEONE TO BE ABLE
TO PROCESS. BOND NUMBER OF THE
COUNTY OFFICES DO HAVE WORKERS-
ON WHAT SHIFT QUITE OFTEN
PRESERVING THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING THAT IS NOT OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC SO THERE ARE PEOPLE
THERE WHO CAN. GET THE
INFORMATION FROM THE DROP BOXES
AND STILL CONTINUE TO PROCESS
THEM AND OF COURSE IN ADDITION
TO THOSE-IN PERSON SERVICES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. WE'VE GOT
ONLINE- BY PHONE BY FAX BY
EMAIL- ALL OF THOSE STILL
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE BOARD FOR.
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SERVICES AND GET THE HEALTH
CRISIS WELL AS OUR CAL WORKED.
AND MEDICAL SERVICES-
OVERWHELMINGLY WHEN WE ARE THE
COUNTY- IF YOU'RE NOT FULLY-
OPEN WHY THAT THE NUMBER ONE
ANSWER WAS BASED WAS DUE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS IN THEIR
COUNTIES. ON END OR ORDERS FROM
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. SOME
DO SO REPORT STAFFING ISSUES I
THINK THOSE WERE MORE IF YOU
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC BUT WE
ARE STILL HEARING THAT COUNTIES
HAVE- A NUMBER OF THEIR-
INDIVIDUAL STAFF WHO MAY HAVE
OVER ABILITIES. TO COAL BED
THEY MAY BE OUT ON LEAVE- THEY
MAY HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET ESPECIALLY THE RURAL
AREAS TO BE ABLE TO WORK FROM
HOME- AND THERE'S ONGOING
CONCERN ESPECIALLY I THINK WE
WOULD BE AT INCREASING NOW. OF
A CONCERN OVER INFECTION AND-
ACTUALLY GETTING THE VIRUS IF
THEY GO IN- AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME LIMITED EXAMPLES OF THEM
TRANSMISSIONS OCCURRING IN OUR
OFFICES. BUT OVERWHELMINGLY
IT'S BASED ON. WHERE THE COUNTY
IS AND WHAT THE PUBLIC. HEALTH
ORDERS ARE AT THAT TIME. I AND
THERE'S AN GOING TO BE. THAT
THE PLACE TO LOOK THAT- IN OUR
THAT'S OF OUR REGION OUT
STATIONING THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING A- BURIED ABOUT BY COUNT
AND BY THEIR COMMUNITY MEANS.
BUT WE- AND I COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOU TO THESE
AS- YOU'RE AT THE MEMBERS ARE
INTERESTED- A NUMBER THEY
COUNTIES REPORTED DOING REALLY
SPECIFIC OUT REACHED A FARM
WORKER POPULATION. WE HAVE- A
LOT OF WORK IN EVERY SPEAKING
DONE WITH PROJECT ROOM HE
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND STREET
TEAM. TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORKS FINING THOSE FOLKS UP AS
WELL- THE IN PERSON TRIAGE TO
BE ABLE TO HELP PEOPLE. GET IN
PLACE. AND ALSO- A NUMBER OF.
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS- THERE'S A
NUMBER OF. THE COALITION TO TRY
TO IMPROVE SERVICE SERVICE IS
AN ACT THAT. THEY'RE WORKING
WITH THEIR FOOD BANKS THEIR
CLINICS AND THEIR PUBLIC
HOSPITALS. ONE COUNTY WITH THE
PUBLIC HOSPITAL FOR EXAMPLE-
NOTED THAT THEY- APPROVED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE
JUST IN THE PUBLIC HOSPITAL
BETWEEN. MARCH AND SEPTEMBER
ALONE. SOME OF THE AREAS THAT
THEY COUNTY THAT. FOR I DO CAN.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT'S
COMING NEXT WEEK SO I THINK
YOU'RE A GREAT PERIOD OF
UNCERTAINTY AS OTHERS HAVE
TESTIFIED AND- AS OF AS OF
COURSE THE THAT YOU'RE IN THE
MEMBERS NOW- CERTAINLY WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE AND THE
NEW. THE INCOMING FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION TO EXPAND THE
FLEXIBILITY AS AND SORT OF
RESTART SOME OF THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT WE THOUGHT EARLIER IN THE
PANDEMIC- THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF STOPS AND STARTS. TO SOME OF
THOSE FEDERALLY ALLOWED
FLEXIBILITY IS AND I THINK
YEAH. UNDERSTANDABLE RELUCTANCE
ON THE PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GO FURTHER
THAN WHAT IS ALLOWED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE WE
COULD LOSE FUNDING- AND HAVE TO
PAY. BACK OR PAY BENEFITS OUT
OF OUR POCKETS AND AGAIN THAT
DOESN'T APPLY IN THE CALFRESH
WORLD- BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT THERE ARE. SOME AREAS
WHERE THERE'S NOT UNIFORMITY
OUR MEDIC HEALTH RULES ARE
DIFFERENT FROM CALFRESH.
UNUSUALLY HELP PRESSING CAL
WORK SO THE SAME BUT THERE'S
EVEN BEEN SOME DIFFERENCES
THERE. I DON'T THINK WE FAULT
THE STATE FOR THE DECISIONS
THAT IT NEEDED TO MAKE IN ORDER
TO DO THAT. BUT STRIVING
TOGETHER FOR AS MUCH OF THAT
UNIFORMITY OF POSSIBLE AND
ADVOCATING FOR PERMISSION TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM'S UNIFORM AND
HOW WE- TREAT YOUR GOT YOU WHY
INCOME AND THE DIFFERENT.
BENEFITS DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN RECEIVED WHICH DIFFER IN
SOME CASES. ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. ON ALLOWING
SIMILARLY FLEXIBLE INTERVIEWING
ACROSS THE THREE PROGRAMS AS
NEEDED- ARE A FEW OF THE AREAS
THERE- AND THEN FINALLY- IN
THAT AREA. THIS KIND OF FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MINIMIZE THE DOUBLE
WORKLOAD FOR OUR STAFF. ONE
THING WE REALLY APPRECIATED.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALLOWED US
TO KEEP PEOPLE ON THE PROGRAM
WE WERE ABLE TO JUST BASICALLY-
CONSIDER. SEMI ANNUAL REPORTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED BY EVERY
HOUSEHOLD TO BE GOOD WE DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE TO ASK FOR THEM OR
PROCESS POUNDS. ON AND WE JUST
BASICALLY WERE ABLE TO KIND OF
STEP PEOPLE FORWARD. TO THE
POINT WHERE NOW WE ARE BACK
PROCESSING THERE IN A
REDETERMINATION. IN THE MATTER
HOW WORLD WAR NOT DISCONTINUING
ANYONE OFF THE PROGRAM AND ARE
NOT- PROCESSING ANNUAL
REDETERMINATION PAPERWORK THAT
WE RECEIVED. SO THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENCES ACROSS THE PROGRAMS
AND AS WE THINK ABOUT. PLANNING
TOGETHER FOR WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE FUTURE HOST PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY- WHICH OF COURSE WE
HOPE THAT THEY COME SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER BUT NOBODY
REALLY KNOWS. INVOLVING THE
COUNTY AND- IN THAT PLANNING SO
THAT WE CAN. SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHEN. A PARTICULAR CHOICE
THAN POLICY MIGHT RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD. OR PRESENT CHALLENGES
HER INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS OR POTENTIALLY RESULT
IN DISPARATE TREATMENT ACROSS
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF OUR
RECIPIENT- WE EXPECT THAT TO BE
INCLUDE YOU KNOW I'VE TO BE
INCLUDED AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT. BUT REALLY WANT TO SORT
OF HIT HOME THAT WE WANT TO-
INCLUDED AS AS WE HAVE BEEN. IN
THAT PLANNING- AND ALSO TRY TO
DO THAT PLANNING TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE ACROSS
THE PROGRAMS. THAT WE OPERATE
BOTH CALFRESH AND HOW WORK YOUR
FOR TV AT THAT. AS WELL AS
MEDICARE FOR EACH YEAH- I KNOW
THAT'S OUT OF THE PURVIEW
SENDING. SERVICES BUT A NUMBER
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALSO- ARE MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
OR BUDGET COMMITTEES. ALSO
BORDER- WITH I- BOB YOUR STATE
YOU. AGAIN FOR THE- AND THEY
YOU TO YOU OUT FOR THE FOURTH.
THAT HAS OUT. TO COUNTY IS THE
TOP AND WHICH THEY'RE IN. THE
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
THAT THEY COME UP. THANK YOU
CAPITA PER. WILL BE MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT SPEAKER NATALIE
CAPLES OF. NKOSI OVER THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK. I
AM HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME. TWEET
YES WE CAN THE FOR TO BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. I'M GONNA
SHARE MY SCREEN RIGHT NOW. OKAY
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE BRINGING AND
BEING ABLE TO BRING OUR UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ADD TO THIS TO THIS
PANEL I CENTRAL CALIFORNIA TO
BANK IS THE LARGEST EMERGENCY
FOOD PROVIDER ANY CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. HAS NO MADERA KINGS
CALARE KERN COUNTY AND WE DO
THIS WITH A NETWORK OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED AGENCY PARTNERS EXECUTE
THREE HUNDRED OVER THREE
HUNDRED RECURRING MONTHLY
DISTRIBUTION. MY SCHOOL YEAR WE
DISTRIBUTED OVER FORTY MILLION
POUNDS. THANK YOUNG SERVICE
AREA SH BECAUSE OF KOBE DO YOU
SEEN AGAIN INCREASING DEMANDS
ON THE EMERGENCY. NETWORKS AND
MARCH OF TWENTY NINETEEN OUR
AGENCY PARTNERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED A ROUGHLY 50%
INCREASE AND CLIENTS ACCESSING
YOUR SERVICES WITH 25% OF THE
CLIENT HAVING NEVER NEEDED TO
ACCESS THE EMERGENCY FOOD
NETWORK BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
STRUCK. SO WHAT THIS IS DONE
AND IT HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
VULNERABILITY OF A LARGE
PORTION OF OUR POPULATION TO
WHAT WE CALL EPISODIC
INSECURITY AND PEOPLE FINDING
THEMSELVES NEEDED THEY NEED A
TAX THE EMERGENCY COULD NOT
WORK I NEED YOU TO THAT
PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC RECORD
QUESTIONS WHICH ARE REALLY.
BEYOND THEIR CONTROL. THREE
THINGS. SPIKE IN THE AND COUNTY
THIRD AREA THANKS MARC. WE'VE
ALSO BEEN EXTRA. DELAYED LIGHTS
AND CHALLENGE AND NATIONALLY IT
WAS BECAUSE END OF THE PLAN AND-
CANNAGROW. AND IN MANY WERE TO
KEEP UP WITH THE G. FOR ALSO
MANAGING SHORTAGES. AND IT WAS
INTERESTING BE. WHILE WE WERE.
A I GEEK. AT CRUDE AVAILABILITY
ON. THE I PRE PAY. IN CHAU
CABLE FIVE WE NEED THOUGHT AND
A THIRD AND- FRESH PRODUCE AND
FROM FARMERS AGRA. PARTNERS SH
AND FALL SERVICE CONTRACT YOU
CAN'T- BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT
WOULD THAT WAS PRETTY SHORT
LEGS- AFTER MAY. I. FARMERS
BECAME MORE NIMBLE DOCTORAL
PROGRAMS COME TO THE RESCUE.
AND THEY WERE FINDING OTHER
MARKETS POTENTIALLY TED TO
DONATE THEIR PRODUCTS ARE TO
GET. TOGETHER THEIR PRODUCT
THROUGH. I WISH I COULD SAY THE
SECOND HAD IMPROVED- YOU KNOW
THANK THANK YOU START OF THE
CANDY ABOUT WE ARE PRETTY PRESS
ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS AND- OUR
ABILITY. TO PURCHASE AND
RECEIVE AND A TIMELY MANNER SO
WE HAVE- DELIVERY UNDERSTOOD NO
LAW THAN MY WE EXPERIENCED IN
THE PAST SO WE CASH HAND RIGHT
NOW. AND TO BE ABLE ORDER AND%
ORDER THE DOUBLE AND HAS A THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED MEET THE
NEEDS TO MEET THE FUTURE NEEDS
I'M FAR FOR OUR CLIENT CARE
AGENCY. NETWORK IN WE CAN. I
SEE LOWER THAN NORMAL AND
DONATE. FROM THE- YEAH. THIRD
CHALLENGE CONTINUE. AND SOME
OTHER SHALL THAT WE NEXT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
DECREASED BY THE ASTON
CALIFORNIA THANKS AND OUR
PARTNERS AND OUR ARE CONTINUING
TO EXPERIENCE VOLUNTEER
SHORTAGES AT THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES- ON A PATH TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BOTH AND UR
DISTRIBUTION PARTNER AND- OUR
AGENCY PARTNER NETWORKS ARE
LIMITING. AND YOU KNOW
VOLUNTEERS TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DOCTRINE THING
AND YOU KNOW PROPER HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. AND A REALLY
INTERESTING FACT AT LEAST WITH
OUR AT PARTNER NETWORK IT IS-
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A LOT OF THE
OLDER ADULTS THAT ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE VOLUNTEERING THEIR
TIME AND TO EXECUTE YOUNG WOMAN
DEEP THEIR DISTRIBUTION NETWORK
AT OUR AGENCY PARTNER PANTRIES
AND THEY CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS
AND SO. I DRIVE BALL AND CHEER-
POOL HAS HAS REALLY CONSTRUCTED
A WALL AND BECAUSE RELYING ON
VOLUNTEERS TO BE ABLE TO
EXECUTE OUR WORK IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING AS FIFTY AND AN
INCREASED NEED BUT A DECREASE
AND VOLUNTEERS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DID ON TO BE
ABLE TO. TAX CUTS A BATTLE. ON
THAT CHANNEL AND I KNOW MANY
COULD BRING THE DEMOCRATS IT'S
HAD TODAY I VERY EARLY DRIVE
YOU'RE JUST TO BE. AND WE I OF
COURSE YOU NEED A LOWER AMOUNT
OF ON TO BE TO ACCESS THOSE TRY
YOU'RE JUST. AND THEN WE-
INTERNAL A LOT OF OUR AND ALLOW
OF OUR AGENCY I. AND STARTED AT
PRE PACKAGING. AND OUR
WAREHOUSE AND TO BE ABLE TO THE
AND YOU ARE ALREADY DONE
HOPEFULLY THAT RELEASED FROM
CHALLENGE IN OUR AGENCY PART
NETWORK. I DON'T WANT TO BE
UNEMPLOYED IN THE LATER COVER
HAVE. I THINK YOU HEARD AT. THE
END OF THE CALL A LITTLE BIT
EARLY. AND BY BUT FOR TO BEING
REALLY SHOW. AND UNEMPLOYMENT
CAL. AND I'M GOING TO. INTO MY
CRATE- AND TELL. YOU KNOW
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWO
TWENTY. AND A LOT OF THAT
REALLY DEPENDS ON WHETHER TAXI
AS AND- ON. SIX ACTUALLY
DISTRIBUTE WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR-
AND SO FOOD. REALLY ARAMBULA
SAYING. FOR AND YOU KNOW
ALAMEDA SERVICE LEVELS. FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT- THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WITHOUT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE IN
THE NEXT YEAR AND SO WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO INTERNALLY
FIGURE OUT. HOW ARE WE
ALLOCATING RESOURCES HOW ARE WE
CAN FIND OUT ON YOUR RESOURCE.
ARE AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO EXECUTE THE
ELEVATED LEVEL SUPPORT. AND
THEN I THINK. THAT YOU KNOW AN
ADDITIONAL COMPLICATING FACTOR
AT LEAST FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. IS THAT WE TEND TO LAG
BEHIND THE REST OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF OUR OUR
RECOVERY AND OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS. WE FACE- WE FACE SOME
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT MAYBE
DOESN'T NEAR. AND THE RATE OF
RECOVERY. FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE. SO BECAUSE THE PROBATE
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGES YOU
KNOW CHRIS BY CAN DOWN THE
WE'VE HAD BE NUMBER WE'VE HAD
TO CREATE A- CAR. AND CARTER.
WITH NEW PARTNERS TO BE TO MEET
THE NEEDS I'M START. WHEN AT
PROVIDING HER TESTING EARLIER
SHE- THAT ACTS COURSE TO GO.
GROCERY GO WITHIN PROGRAM IT'S
A POINT BASED. THAT LOCATED AT
OUR FEET. SERVING TO FOUR
THOUSAND HOW. PER MONTH THEN
THEY GET ONE. HELPFUL ARE
ACTUALLY BEING SERVICE VIA
DELIVER SO ARE. WITH THE
DELIVERY PARTNER. IN. PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND. AD
BOXES PER MONTH. THAT ARE. AND
HOME INDIVIDUALS. AND WITHIN
THE MONTH WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE A- THE GROWTH PICKUP.
INTO TWELVE ADELAIDE LOCATION
AND I WORK. I'M WE WON'T BE IN
KERN WILL BE ACT AND- CARD
NUMBER THERE ARE. KING COUNTY
AND THIS IS TO BE ABLE TO. D.
AND THAT ACCESS CHALLENGE AT
THE END. TO HAS I'M TRANSIT. OR
DOESN'T HAVE BACK ON. I'M COME
PICK UP THE FOOD AT THE COULD
BE FOR THAT GROCERY TO GO TO
WORK WITHOUT THE WORLD. BURKE
TO REDUCE SOME OF THE DAY. THAT
WITH TRANSPORT. AND EXECUTE-
TEST ABOUT A SITES CHARGING
ACCESS. WE AND WE ALSO AND- OR
CHILD PROGRAMS AND THE
PARTNERED WITH- PRESS UNIFIED
AND OR GOLD THIS. THE PRESIDENT.
AS THE BRANCH AND SCHOOL. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE COULD BOX THAT
THIRTEEN WOLF. ITS FIGHT. AND
EIGHT- OR AND CRIED KNOWING. OR
DISTRICT WHERE HIGH ALL- OR
KNOW LIKE THE BACK TO BACK THAT
MY TURN ARE NOT CURRENTLY BEING.
WE ARE WORKING TO EXPAND AND.
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS. I NEED TO
ONE ST CHANT THAT. AND
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE TRY TO
ADDRESS BECAUSE LET HIM DOWN IS-
ACCESS ASSET ACCESS FOR FORMER
POPULATION. AND WE REALIZE
THAT- YOU KNOW DAT THAT THANKS
AND OUR AGENCY PARTNERS
TYPICALLY HAVE SOME
RESTRICTIONS OR LIMITATIONS
WHEN WE ARE ACTUALLY LIKE
EXECUTING COULD DISTRIBUTIONS
THAT MAYBE DON'T ALLOW
FARMWORKERS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT. AND SO WE'RE
PARTNERING UP- WHAT SHEGOT
BACK AND YOUR W. FOUNDATION TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH
INCREASED ACCESS TO RESOURCES
THAT NEED THAT WERE ACTUALLY
I'M YOU KNOW PARTNERING WITH
WITH YOUR W. M. YEAH AND WE ARE
ANDO'S FARMER CAN COMMUNITIES
WERE DOING- DISTRIBUTION THAT
TIME APPROPRIATE TIME WHEN
FARMWORKERS CAN ACCESS. I DON'T
RIGHT WE ARE PROVIDING
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOOD AND
THEN THE LAST- PROGRAMMING BUT
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT WAS AND
COMMUNITY MEDICAL CENTERS HOME
HEALTH PARTNERSHIP AND THIS IS
A COLLABORATION WITH- HOME
HEALTH NURSES TO BE ABLE TO
FEED I DISABLED AND HOMEBOUND I
INDIVIDUALS AND WE ACTUALLY GOT
AN ADDITIONAL GRANT FUNDING
WE'RE GOING TO BE EXTENDING
THAT. PARTNERSHIP OVER THE NEXT
FOURTEEN MONTHS. SO THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOU KNOW
HAPPENING CENTRAL. AND CREEPING
SPECIFIC BUT TO HIRE THAT SOME
OF THAT YOU KNOW OR CONDITIONS
OUR CREAKING CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ARE SHE- BY THE OTHER FOR TWO
MY- OF THE CAL. ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS AND HELP THIRTY AT
THE BANK- HAVE BEEN- INTEGRAL
AND HELPING US- YOU KNOW TAKE
CARE FUNDING AND- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO YOU
KNOW TO OUR COMMUNITY. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE A. F. B. R. FOOD BANK
AND TEN OTHER COULD BEING. AN
AGRICULTURAL REGION ARE
STRENGTHENING OUR CAPACITY TO
ENSURE FARMWORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE FOOD DRINKS- THAT
NINETEEN AND BEYOND. AND THE
SAYS THAT COULD ACCESS FOR
FARMWORKERS AND **** AND
BASICALLY FOOD BANKS ARE USING
THEIR OWN LOCAL MODELS AND
QUICKER SHIFTING INTO
ADDITIONAL FOOD AS I MENTIONED
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
AFTERMATH W. WE ARE SHIFTING
DISTRIBUTION TIMES AND
LOCATIONS FOR SUPPLEMENTING OUR
STAFF TO BETTER REACH FARM
WORKING COMMUNITY. AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS DOESN'T VITAL WORK
BECAUSE- AND THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE EXPERIENCING SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF HUNGER YEAH
THEY'RE FEEDING YOU KNOW THE
COUNTRY IF NOT THE WORLD AND SO
WE REALLY. AND YOU KNOW ARE ARE
VERY SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING
INVESTMENTS ON MAKING SURE THAT
YOU KNOW OUR OUR FARMWORKERS.
ARE A TEACHER AT. AND THEN ALSO
TO HAVE THAT THAT RECENT
CURRENT SURELY. AND OTHER
ADDITIONAL STATE RE ALEX. HAVE
BEEN. AND HOW. BANKS INCREASE
OUR LEVEL OF SERVICE. THANK YOU
TO ENSURE HER. THE SENATE
ALLEGE. AS FOR FIRST FIVE
EIGHTH. AND THESE VITALLY ME
NEEDED RESTORE FOR THANK. AND
ALTHOUGH ONE TO TAKE A SECOND
TESTING. ARE CDS QUICKLY AND- I
AM GIVEN A TIGHT TIME LINE.
BASED WHAT OF ANY TO VERIFY TO
YOU TO INCREASE- DEMAND OUT
STATE YOU TO RESOURCE. AND I
KNOW AND PERSONS OF COLOR CREEK
BANK PRETTY THOSE RESOURCES YOU
KNOW TO WORK RIGHT NOW. AND YOU
KNOW FIRST OUR DISTRIBUTION
CHANNELS ENSURE CONTROL TO PASS
AFTER THE STATE. AND YOU KNOW
IT'S EXPANDED ON THAT AND NOT
DEADLINE. I'M STUNNED FACT AND
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY FOCUS AS THE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT- BUT
WHERE. THROUGH FEEDBACK LOOPS
YOU KNOW HOW MY CLIENTS OR
AGENCY PARTNER NETWORK- I'M
MORE ALSO ALSO PURCHASING I'M
AND CAN FORMULATE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET A VERY SPECIFIC.
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND THE-
POPULATION. AND LASTLY WE ABOUT
EARLIER- THINK YOU KNOW ABOUT
ALL OF US CAN THAT THAT. REALLY
SHOWS NO SIGN OF. BUT IS GOING
TO BE AND AS FEDERAL COURT AND-
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR THE PREPREG-
AND WE ARE FOOD OUR GOING TO
FACING A VERY REAL SCREWED
CLASS- ON THE THIRD FIRST SO
THERE'S A TYPICALLY CHEAPER. I
SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
HELD AND REALLY HOT AND ALLOW
YOU COULD BE BONTA NEED THE
FIRST ONE IS I TREAT MEDICATION.
AND DIE IT MEANS AND HELP WE'RE
GOING. I ABOUT E. TWELFTH
MILLION ONE COUNT A DEAL
SPECIFIC THROUGH TRUE TRADE
MEDICAID- FOR THAT HAS BEEN-
SHOPS. AND PERSONAL I LIKE-
SHEETS ARE CLEAN ARE REALLY
REALLY GOT WE NEED MORE DIET.
AND THEN AT THE FACT PROGRAM
THAT'S GOING TO BE FUN CUTTING
DECEMBER FIRST YEAR. I HE'S GOT
PROGRAM OR FORMER FAMILY- BY
PROGRAM. I NATIONALLY THAT THE
IT FOR BILLION DOLLARS- AND
FEDERAL FOOD. BECAUSE BECAUSE
YOU'RE HAS NOT REALLY PROVIDED
AN LEADING UP TO KNOW THE JOB
IMPACT THE PHYSICALLY FOR. BUT
THERE ARE BANK AND THAT MEANS
ROUGHLY A LAW OF ONE POINT OVER
ONE POINT NO POUNDS OF FOOD- SO.
THOUSAND COULD BOXES HELLO
BECAUSE OF THAT PROGRAM ON
SUNDAY. IN ONE OTHER THING
BEFORE CLOSE AND I. ALTHOUGH
SHE GOT PROGRAM HAS. ON A LOT
OF TEND WHICH FLOWN THE- AND IS
HOW THE PROGRAM HAS HURT
DIMINISH. FROM PARTNERS
FOODBANK HE SB FARMED FAMILY
AND PROGRAM AND SO YOU KNOW
WHILE LOOKING OF COURSE VERY
NOW THE BARREL THE STATE CLASS-
DECEMBER AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
WOULD YOU- REDUCED A- WE ARE.
LOOKING AT HOW WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO READ. OUR VALUE TO GREW
SHIPS THAT HAD BEEN DESTROYED
BY THE- I MENTIONED EARLIER YOU
KNOW WE HAVE SEEN A DECREASE
AND DONATED PRODUCE BECAUSE
AGRICULTURAL PARTNERS AND OTHER
MARKETS. FOR THEIR PRODUCT AND
THIS INCLUDES THE FEEDBACK
PROGRAM AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK THAT WE HAVE TO DO TO MAKE
THAT- TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN GET
THOSE DONATIONS STRENGTH BACK
COULD BE ABLE TO ALLOCATED. AT.
THE PLANT AND I CONTINUE. SO
HIGH WILL- CLOSE THEIR AND I'LL
BE A FOR QUESTION BUT I WANT TO
YOU FOR. THIS HEARING AND TO BE
A THE PANEL WE YOU AGREE ALLEGE.
ONGOING AND INTEREST GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW. GIVEN THAT WE REMAIN
ON THE FRONT LINE- AT NOT TO
CRY AS GOING AWAY AND AGAIN
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE WANT
BEEN ABLE TO. MEET OUR-
INCREASE. YOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NATALIE- WE WILL BE MOVING
ON. OUR NEXT SPEAKER. JUMPED
DIRECTOR VENTURA COUNTY AREA
AGENCY ON AGING. VICTORIA
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. ZERO I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
I'M NOT SURE HER TADO IN ASKING
ABOUT THE REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. I'M THINKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA. AGENCIES
ON AGING. WHICH IS THE MEMBERS
BODY REPRESENTING THE STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF AGENTS ON AGING
CHARGED WITH PROVIDING SERVICE
TO MORE THAN EIGHT POINT EIGHT
CANNELLA. OVER CALIFORNIANS-
MENTION I DO FOR THE COUNTY
HAVE BEEN. ONE OF THE CRITICAL.
AREA EIGHT ON AGING HAVE OFTEN.
NINE SEVENTY IS THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM. SESSION
PROGRAM BUT AS MEALS ON WHEELS.
AND HUNDREDS I CENTERS ARE REAL
THE CORE. OF SOCIAL SERVICES
NOT FOR ALL ADULTS BUT FOR ALL
CAL. TREMENDOUSLY OVERWHELMING
THE COURT AND UNMATCHED IMPACT-
TRIED. GRAHAM IN ADDITION
PROGRAMS OF THE IN NEED A
MAJORITY OF OUR PROCESS AND BY
MY NOR OVER THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FIVE LIVE IN POVERTY ARE YOU
AND NOT NEED WORK. IN THE YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY. OUR
NETWORK PROVIDER MORE THAN
MILLION. TO MORE THAN HUNDRED
OLDER ADULTS CAL. BUT A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WITH THE NOW
IN MARCH OUR NETWORK INCREASE
INTEREST IN SERVICES TO MEDIUM
NEED. INCREASING NUMBER OF
OLDER. BOB I WELL AS NUMBER
MEALS. AS I STATED THAN EIGHT
NINETY WE SERVE MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION MEALS. HOWEVER THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS AND WE MATCH
NUMBER SERVING. NO SEVENTY NINE
MALES AND JUST ONE. WHAT'S
GONNA BITE SHE DOWN HE QUICKLY
HAD THE GRABBING MODEL AS WELL
AS THE NUMBER HOMES. I'M A
MEMBER. ARE ALSO ABLE TO OFFER
MEDICARE PICK UP GROCERIES THE
LEVEL. TO MAKE A ISSUES WITH
SOME OF OUR EXIT YEAH BY AN
AREA. WE WILL COME OF OUR
PARTNER OF OUR OFTEN ARE WITH
WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN. LOCAL
TRADE PROVIDE TO HELP ME NEEDS.
A MENTOR BY RYAN AND TRIPLE A
OFF THE- IN A GRAY STATE COURT
THE GREAT PLAINS- GRAHAM. WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO THAT CALVET COUNTY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. THE OWNER.
CORPORATE FOLLOWING. AND A
FEDERAL LOW BOND. AND I AM
MENTION FORTUNATE AN INTERVIEW
AND MY FOR THE CARE AND FIRST.
COUNTY LOS PROVIDER SOME THEIR
FEDERAL CARE ACT ON THE HELP
YOU CAN. YEAH YOUR DOCTOR
SERVICE WILL AND VOLUNTEERS
IRONICALLY DO EVERYTHING FROM
ANSWER CALLS. AND PACKING BOXES
DELIVERING A THANK COURT TO
OVERALL WELL BEING. SOME OF ALL
AREN'T LONG QUAN THANK THOSE
WITH WHITE GETTING MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND THE LIVING WITH
ALL DISEASE OTHER AND- WE KNOW
THE HUNDRED CONNECT. TO COURT
HELD A WELL AS THE LONG TERM
IMPACT. OF SOCIAL LIFE. ON. FOR
THOSE HAVE BEEN I. AND FOR SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN I
IT SEVEN MONTHS THAT PEOPLE
LESS THE HOUSE FOR JUST BUT THE
HOUSE MEDICAL. THE RESULTS OF
THE- LOCALLY IN VENTURA COUNTY.
MARCH WITH SERVE MORE THAN TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION MEALS. TO
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE AND I HAVE
TO SAY IT TRULY TAKES A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH AND
PARTNERSHIPS ALL OVER THE PLACE
INCLUDING ONE OF OUR LOCAL
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY THE TWO
ONE ONE- BARCLAYS BANK SYSTEM.
THE COUNTY HAS ALSO PROVIDED A
PARADOX FUNDING TO EXPAND OUR
REACH. WE PARTICIPATE IN A
GREAT PLACE TO PROGRAM AND WE
ALSO HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THE
OLD CENTRAL KITCHEN DOCTOR. TO
ALSO HELP. WE ALSO PROVIDE FOR-
HOMELESS AND- THAT ARE PART OF
THE CROTCH WILL BRING SHE-
PROGRAM. WE PARTNER WITH OUR-
LOW TRANSIT PROVIDERS TO MAKE
HOME. FOR PEOPLE ADDRESS.
NIELSEN WILL NOT MEMBER HAVE
REPORTED NUMBER OF TO CURRENT
BEING 69% MORE WHAT THE AGO
SOME VITAL COURTING OUT PERCENT
INCREASE. WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
IDENTA AS THE VERY UNDER ON THE-
IT PEOPLE THAT WERE ON THE FREE.
AND TO A MARGINAL. WE ARE JUST
PROVIDING MORE FOR TO OUR
CUSTOMERS RIGHT NOW FOR NOW
PEOPLE THAT WERE IN YOUR BOOK
THE AND THAT MAKE. BUT THE- IS
WHAT ME FINALLY THEM COME FOR
AND AFT FOR HELP. THE OLDER
ADULT BEING AT. RISK QUORUM
BEING IN OUR- SOME OF THEM HAVE
BEEN QUARANTINE PERCENT MONTHS
I'M ALONG FOR YOU KNOW A COUPLE
WEEKS TO JUST DEPENDS ON END OF
THE- BUT THEY DON'T ADULTS TO
BE DOUBLE. I LACK THE MEANS THE
REASON TO THE BILL THAT THEY AT
SURVIVE GROCERY IN LAST.
MEMBERS ARE NOT AVAIL IN ALL K.
MADE. ALL OLDER ADULTS. ANY OF
THE GROCERY TO LIVE IS REQUIRED
OUT MARK WELL WORKING TO BE
ABLE TO ORDER TO THAT WAY AND
WE KNOW THAT NOT ALL ALL DON'T
HAVE THAT. BUT YOUR NETWORK
BILL FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE CAR NEED A HI AND HELP
MITIGATE GOOD ACTORS BILLION
ISSUES TERM ALL NORMAL ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STATE
ABILITY ONE TO CARE ACT THE
CARE ACT BUNBURY BOUGHT. UNTIL
NEXT ISABEL AND THERE A CLEAR
PATH PROTECT INCREASE OF NEW
PLAN WITH THE WILL BE IN. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME WHEN
YOU'RE IN IN THE IMPORTANT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. THANK
VICTORIA DOES OF BRING THE CAR
THE DISCUSSION TO THE MAIN- TO
HAVE ANY ANY. RECALL FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY HAVE
EIGHT. OF FOR THIS PAN LIGHT I
KNOW THERE WAS A- BIT OF-
MENTION OF CULTURALLY- RELEVANT
IF YOU KNOW WOOD NUTRITION
PROGRAMS CAN. CAN ANYBODY ELSE
SPEAK TO THE PROGRAM SAID THAT-
YOU'VE IMPLEMENTED. TOTAL
VICTORIA- I CAN SPEAK TO IT. SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO AT
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING IF WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT
WERE SERVING IN YOU KNOW
CULTURE APPROPRIATE. FOR THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE SERVING
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT IS.
IT HILLARD'S TO THE COMMUNITY
THAT WERE SERVING IT TOO. AND
YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK FOR
RESTAURANT PARTNERS TO HELP- WE
ARE LOOKING FOR. YOU KNOW
RESTAURANTS THAT NEED A LOT OF
THEM ARE MORE LOCAL RESTAURANTS
IN THAT LOCAL. YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES SO WE'RE NOT
BRINGING IN FROM OTHER
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY NOT BE
WHAT PEOPLE. KNOW YOUR BILL. TO
THE INDIVIDUAL AND WE ALSO DO A
LOT OF SERVE AS WELL TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WHAT WE'RE SERVING
IS WHAT PEOPLE WANT. THANK YOU
VICTORIA M. MY NEXT QUESTIONS
FOR LIKE IT'S FOR LEXUS FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- THE CALPERS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN AT THE FRONT LINES OF
THE FIGHT AGAINST HUNGER AND
ENERGY AND DEDICATION YOU BRING
TO THE PROGRAM IS JUST REALLY
APPRECIATED. I'M CHRISTIAN
ORDER SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED IN THE PAST THREE
MONTHS AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
FUTURE CHALLENGES THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CONCERNED ABOUT.
THIS IS A BIT YOU COULD HAVE A
THESIS ON LESSONS LEARNED. I
THINK. IT'S CLEAR THAT. WHAT WE
SEE IN OUR CASELOAD IS A
REFLECTION OF THE DEPTH OF THE
NEEDS THAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING AND SO- IT IS
CLEAR THAT CALFRESH PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE IN HELPING TO
MEET NEEDS AND- ENSURING THAT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT
CULTURALLY COMPETENT OF FOOD
ACCESS WHEN YOU HAVE BENEFITS
THAT YOU CAN USE AT A STORE
YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES AND SO TOGETHER WITH
OTHER RESOURCES THAT'S HOW WE
HELP. PEOPLE MEET THEIR NEEDS
IN A WAY THAT- SATISFIED
SATISFIED THINGS LIKE CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES I THINK IT
DEFINITELY IT'S CLEAR THAT WE
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN-
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AT THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AND AT THE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN TERMS OF
BUSINESS SUPPORT I THINK WE
LEARNED ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SIDE THAT- THERE ARE
POSSIBILITIES THAT HELPED US
RESPOND AND YOU KNOW IF WE
COULD ASK- AS A KHAKI SUIT
SUGGESTION FOR IMPROVEMENTS AND
WHAT'S AVAILABLE IT'S AROUND
THE CONSISTENCY RIGHT. FOR A
LONG TIME WE WERE ASKING FOR
FLEXIBILITY IS ON A MONTH TO
MONTH BASIS WHICH DIDN'T ALLOW
US TO REALLY PLAN LONG TERM AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
TO RESPOND TO AN ONGOING
DISASTER OF THIS MAGNITUDE
GREAT THAT IS BOUND TO LAST FOR
THE NEXT YEAR OR SO WELL WE
JUST IMPLEMENTED FOR EXAMPLE
INTERVIEW FLEXIBILITIES ALL THE
WAY THROUGH JIM. THAT PROVIDE
NOT ONLY A STABILITY FOR
CLIENTS BUT ALSO FOR COUNTY
PARTNERS IN BEING ABLE TO PLAN
TO THAT TYPE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
RELIEF SO THAT THE MONTH TO
MONTH WORK THAT WE HAD TO DO
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. WAS
VERY VERY CHALLENGING. TO SAY
THE AND WE'RE FOR TO SOME. IN
IN THOSE OPTION BEING A BILL-
AND- THE- ADDRESSING THE
BENEFIT ADEQUACY BUT LOTS OF
LESSONS LEARNED FOR PANDEMIC.
THAT WAS A BRAND NEW PROGRAM
RIGHT WE HAD IT WAS
UNPRECEDENTED. NO NO STATE HAD
DONE THAT RIGHT WE DID NOT HAVE
KIND OF A- ALL OF THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE NOW TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN WE GO OUT FOR
THIS NEXT ROUND FOR AN ENTIRE
SCHOOL YEAR. WE ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO MEET. THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF
GETTING CARDS OUT BUT FOR
EXAMPLE- MAKING SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE BENEFITS
THEY MAY NOT BE ON CALPERS IS
MAYBE THE FIRST EBT CARD THAT
THEY HAD AND SO WE LEARNED A
LOT EVEN ABOUT SOME. BASIC
COMMUNICATIONS AND MESSAGING
THAT WILL APPLY TO THIS FUTURE
OPERATION SO I THINK THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW CAN LOOK ACROSS A
BROAD RANGE BUT- TAKING THOSE
NOW AND APPLYING THEM. TO THE
YEAR AHEAD IS WHERE WE'RE-
PARTNERS. THANK YOU ALEXIS SENT
OUT MY NEXT QUESTION- THIS IS
FOR NATALIE- YOU KNOW FIRST OF
ALL WHAT ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITY- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK YOU'RE DOING A TO
FEED THE PEOPLE OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND- YOU KNOW I'M I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE FOOD
CLIFF AND I HOPE THAT THE
FEDERAL SYSTEMS WILL BE
FORTHCOMING BUT- AND I WANT
YOU. TO FEEL FREE TO ALWAYS
KEEP US INFORMED AS- YOU KNOW
THINGS DEVELOP. I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD GIVE US A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF. INFORMATION IN. THE
EVENT AND THAT PARTNERSHIP THAT
YOU HAVE. THAT THAT WAS BUILT
BETWEEN THE- BETWEEN. YOU KNOW
AG AND THE FOOD BANK AND UP
ABOUT A POTENTIAL WAYS THAT YOU
YOU SEE THAT WE COULD YOU KNOW
FURTHER WORK DOWN THE ROAD
TOGETHER- TO JUSTICE THIS FOOD
INSECURITY IN IN. CALIFORNIA
YEAH I DEFINITELY. AGREE WITH
THE- THE PHYSICALLY WHAT HE
ASKED FORMER CORONATION. WE AND
WE HAVE SOME LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH U. S. W.
AND PREACHER LEAD AND SO.
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY INTEGRAL
AND- HELPING PROVIDE SUPPORT-
AND EFFICIENTLY GETTING
DISTRIBUTION BATTLES FARM
WORKING COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
ASK THE DOCTORS LIKE THESE
ARISE. AND I THINK THAT THAT. I
THINK THAT THEY TIRED THE
TETHER BETWEEN YOU KNOW FOOD
BANKS AND OUR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NEEDS TO BE STRENGTHENED
I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT THE PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED.
SOME SOME AREAS OF OCT AND
GROWTH AND WE CAN GO STRENGTH
OUR COPER YOU KNOW WE HEARING
FROM. YOU AT AND YEAH THAT AND
YOU KNOW THE TIME OF DISTRICT
TO JUST WORK FOR OUR OR THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO TRANSPORT.
YOU KNOW TO GET TO THE DISTRICT
BY WAR AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE AS
IT WAS A THE MAY OF THE
COMMODITIES THAT WE WERE. THAT
THEY NEEDED AND YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT VARIATION OF THE ITEM
SO INSTEAD AND- YOU KNOW
NONPERISHABLE PANTRY SHELF
STABLE ITEMS THAT THEY WERE
ALREADY I'M BUYING IN BULK LIKE
RIGHT THIRTEEN THEY NEED ACCESS
TO GEHRY A TORTILLA- G. AND SO
WE ARE REALLY I AM. REALLY
LOOKING AT TO CREATE A
STRENGTHENS- AND REALLY FALL
INTO FEEDBACK LOOP AND SO
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED THAT'S
WHAT WORKING WITH OUR
AGRICULTURAL PARTNERS THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
ANIMATION YOU KNOW LIKE THE
ABOUT THE UFW DOES IS THEY
HAVE. TO TRY AND DO THAT AND TO
TRUST THEM ACCENTS OF BE-
INDIVIDUALS AND DAY. YOU KNOW
OUR OUR FARMWORKERS ARE ARE
MORE WILLING TO TALK TO THEM
AND EXPRESS THEIR NEEDS AND
CONCERNS AND THEIR CHALLENGES
SH THEN THEY ARE YOU KNOW JANET
JACKSON BANKS UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE STILL SEEN OUR- WE'RE NOT
KEEPING UP WITH A SEPARATE YOU
KNOW NONPROFIT ENTITY WERE SEEN
YOU KNOW AS- PART OF AYE AYE A
COG IN THE GOVERNMENT NETWORK
AND SO THERE IS STILL TIME TO.
STICK AND FEAR AND HOW THEY ARE
COMMUNICATING AND HOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE INTERFACING. AND TO
REALLY FINDING- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAD THAT THE TRUST AND THE
COMMUNITY IS A VITAL PART IN
HOW WE. INCREASE ACT THAT. AND
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS QUESTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SO A
COUPLE MORE PLEASE BERMAN ME
EVERY AT THE YOU- SOMEONE
QUESTION FOR RIDE I ANOTHER
MANY COMMUNITY IN WHICH THE
GREAT PLAY PROGR. IS NOT
AVAILABLE- WHAT KIND OF WORK IS
HAPPENING TO EXPAND THE OF UP
THE GREAT PROGRAM AT IN THESE
COME. ARE GREAT SIZE. SHARE WE
STILL CONTINUE TO- CALL OKAY
WEDNESDAY WE HAVE OUR- MEETINGS
WITHOUT THAT COMPANIES AND
CITIES AND WE ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION ADDITIONALLY-
MYSELF AND OTHER LEADERS HERE
AT OUR HOUSE WE DO STAY IN
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH THE
COUNTY LEADERS TO ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION AND- PARTICULARLY
NOW THAT WE HAVE FORTY ONE
COUNTIES IN THE PURPLE. A TIER
STATUS WE'RE CONTINUING TO
REACH OUT TO CALL THEM DIRECTLY
TO SEE WHAT- WHAT WOULD. THEY
HAVE BEEN MORE IMPORTANT. WHY
ARE THEY- AGAINST INTO THE
PROGRAM A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
JUST STOP MISINFORMATION- HOW
THE PROGRAM WORKS- BUT IN MANY
CASES IT IS BOB FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND- WE ARE
ALLOWING- THROUGH. OTHER PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROCESS THROUGH THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION FEMA- WE'RE ALLOWED
TO ADVANCE PEOPLE- IN BALGOWNIE
IN CITIES MONIES UP FOR THAT SO
WE'RE IN CONSTANT CONTACT. WITH
OUR COMMUNITIES- IT WE HAVE A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE-
TRIP AWAY THAT DOING A GREAT
OUTRAGE CAMPAIGN FOR US- THIS.
B. THERE IS NO DEADLINE OF WIND
STRUVITE JOINED- YOU CAN JOIN
TODAY- YOU KNOW THERE IS ONE
VERY WE HAVE IS EVERY THIRTY
DAYS WE HAVE TO GET EXTENDED OF
COURSE WE ACCESS TO BE EXTENDED
EVERY THIRTY SIXTY NINETY DAYS
WE ONLY GET A THIRTY DAY
EXTENSION- THAT SEEMS TO BE ONE
AREA THAT WE HAVE TO OVERCOME
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT-
WE'RE CURRENTLY. REACHING OUT I
PERSONALLY I SPEAK ALMOST-
EVERY COUNTY ABOUT EVERY TWO
WEEKS JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY COUNTIES IMPACTED BY FIRES
IN EVERY CONCERT I MEAN EVERY
COUNTY IMPACTED. BY OCTOBER
NINETEEN SO THE OUTRAGE
CONTINUES AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO MORE-
WILL BE. GLAD TO PARTICIPATE
NOT. IT AND SO WHAT THE OTHER
QUESTION- WHAT IS PRO. OF A TO
REST PURCHASE A IN AND THE-
GREAT PLACE. ARE THESE LIKE MOM
AND POP SHOPS OR THE TYPICALLY
CHAIN RESTAURANTS. I THINK IT'S
A MIXTURE OF BOTH THEN MAYBE
THINGS ARE YOU CAN EVEN SHOP
AND I KNOW- WE DO HAVE 58% OF
OUR RESTAURANT PROVIDERS ARE
MINORITY OWNED WHICH IS- BIG
FOR ALL OF US PARTICULARLY FOR
THE CULTURAL. ASPECT OF THIS-
AND- IT'S WHAT'S BEEN A WIDE
MAJORITY OF MOM AND POP STORES
WE DID TARGET AT THE BEGINNING
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS MORE
ABOUT SMALL BUSINESS. OUTSIDE
RESTAURANTS AND NOT THE LARGE
ARENAS- WE'RE TRYING TO GET-
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT DO NOT HAVE
THAT- MECHANISM- OR YOU KNOW
BASE- TO COME BACK TO WORK SO-
SERVER CITIES HAVE BEEN
TARGETING THOSE SMALLER MOM AND
POP RESTAURANTS AND- WE'VE BEEN
CONSTANTLY RECEIVING- YEAH
THANK YOU LETTERS ON OUR SIDE
IN SEVERAL CITIES INCLUDING.
SANGER AND- I SAVE UP EARLIER
BEEN UP FOR DISSIPATING- AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ALRIGHT IF
YOU WANT I JUST TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE. FOR US. SURE I
WOULD HAPPY- MEN. SO IN AIR
WOKE IT IS MAINLY AND POP.
THERE MOL WE'RE BLESSED- THEY
ALREADY OF THE- MOST OF THEM
ARE MAJORITY OF OURS ARE-
MINORITIES OR WOMAN OWNED. WHAT
WHAT WE'VE IS THAT. THE
COMMUNITY LOVE THEM BECAUSE
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW NECESSARILY
CHANGE MORE IN PLACE BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY- YOU KNOW THEY'VE
PROVIDED A TREMENDOUS SERVICE
FOR US AND. I LIKE THIS PROGRAM
IF THEY COULD CONTINUE LONG
TERM. IT WOULD IT WOULD MAKE ME
HAPPY BUT IT NEARLY A REAL NEED
IN OUR COMMUNITY WHEN WE LOOK
AT YOU KNOW RYAN MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THE NUMBER OF JOBS IN
THOSE ARE BOTH WANTED NUMBERS
THOSE ARE REAL PEOPLE THAT
WOULD BE WITHOUT A JOB IF IT
WEREN'T THAT. PROGRAM I GET.
YOU KNOW. NOTICE YOU KNOW
PROBABLY EVERY TWO WEEKS FOR A
LAST SAYING YOU HAVE SAVED OUR
BUSINESS PROGRAM BUT THIS
PROGRAM DIDN'T EXIST WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN OUT OF BUSINESS AND
LIKE. APRIL MAY. THANK YOU
VICTOR AND I THE REASON I'M YOU
KNOW ASKING IF YOU CAN
ELABORATE ON THIS I MEAN. IF
THERE'S THINGS THAT THAT THE
TURRET COUNTY IS DOING THAT
THAT. IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S VERY
SUCCESSFUL FOR VENTURA COUNTY
WHAT MEAN WHAT'S THE ADVICE FOR
THE OTHER COUNTIES- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN- GIVE SAVE
THOSE THOSE MOM AND POP SHOPS
AS WELL AND THAT PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE GOING TO PARK YOU.
KNOW GETTING FOOD FROM THE
PLACES THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
RESTAURANTS AT THE TRUST- AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM
AND NEED FOR EXPANDING-
PARTICIPATION SO. IF YOU HAVE
ANY ADVICE FOR YOU KNOW FOR
OTHER COUNTIES ON. WHAT'S BEEN
THAT WHAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR
PRINTER ACCOUNTED. PLEASE
GREATLY. SO I THINK OUR OUR
PROCESS. YEAH I THINK ACROSS
THE STATE WE SET UP. BOTTOM OF
THE GETTING- WE WORK WITH OUR-
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND WE LOOKED AT. YOU KNOW
HAVING THEM DO THE COMMITMENT
FOR RESTAURANT SURE THAT IT WAS
A FAIR- WE TALKED EXECUTIVE I.
PART OF THE. SHARE THEIR
INTEREST IN THE WHOLE. YOU KNOW
RETAINING BUSINESS SO THEY PUT
OUT THE FOR THEIR NETWORK BUT
THAT THERE WAS A FAIR YOU CAN
OF EVERYBODY TO. AND THEN WE AT
ALL OF THE APPS THAT YOU CAN WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT DIDN'T
HAVE CULTURALLY UPON WHAT ON IT
WILL REFLECT IN THE BEGINNING
AND SO. YOU KNOW WE CHOSE THE-
CARE TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE WERE.
IN THOSE PEOPLE THAT WOULD TO
CALL IT DIDN'T WORK THAT- THE
OTHER THING IS IT IS YOU KNOW.
WHY BRIEFLY MY THAT BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS TO CONSIDER IF THE
WE'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW A ON
THE- IS THAT. THERE IS A LOT
MATCH REQUIRED. AND I KNOW IT
SOME AREAS THE MAP OF WHAT HAS
BEEN A- FOR. MANY PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE. AND FAR FROM
VENTURA WE'VE BEEN IN OUR
COUNTING OFFICES PROVIDED YOU
KNOW WITH THE WITH THE. AS A
MATTER WHICH IS. BUT NOT ALL.
MANAGERS MAY HAVE THAT. YOU
THEY DON'T GET THE FEDERAL
EXPANSION ON THE- CARADOC THE
COMPANY COUNTY THAT EXPIRES ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST- YOU KNOW
THAT MADE CHANGES THE VIABILITY
OF THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I MEAN THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE HEARD IS THAT THERE'S FEAR
IN. YOU KNOW THE FOR HAVING A
MATCH. THE FUNDS AND THEN. AT
THE END OF THE DAY NOT BEING
ABLE TO. GET THAT REIMBURSEMENT
BOB BACK. AND I KNOW THERE WAS
ALSO MENTION OF THE TWO
COMMUNITIES THAT. YOU'RE
PARTICULARLY IN MY AREA. OF
SINGAPORE LEE AND I WAS LOOKING
AT THE NUMBERS- SO FOR EXAMPLE
THE CITY OF PARLEY AIR. THE
NUMBER OF MEALS SERVED SINCE
THE PROGRAM LAUNCHED WELL AS-
IS 303-800-0200 FIFTY. NUMBER
OF ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS BEING
SERVED IS TWO HUNDRED THIRTY.
NUMBER OF RESTAURANTS CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN THIS TWELFTH-
YOU KNOW FOR SMALL COMMUNITY
EIGHTY EIGHT YEAR TWELVE IS
PRETTY GOOD- YOU KNOW AND YOU
LOOK COMPARISON TO. THE
NEIGHBORING- COMMUNITY HUB CITY
SINGER AND THE COMMUNITY I LIVE
IN ITS THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
ELEVEN AT. A NUMBER OF MEALS
SERVED SINCE THE PROGRAM
LAUNCHED- NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANTS ONE ON ONE A
NUMBER OF RESTAURANTS CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING ONE AND SO JUST
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE NUMBERS
AND JUST YOU KNOW THE- JUST
LOOKING AT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES HOW CAN WE GET MORE
RESTAURANTS YOUR PARTICIPATING.
YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE GET- THE
END OF NUMBER OF MEALS SERVED
AT EIGHT DO YOU KNOW TO BE MORE
TO BE OUT YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GET
IT IN. AND IT JUST SEEMS.
THERE'S SOME WORK THAT WE COULD
DO AND I THINK THAT YOUR INPUT
TODAY IS VERY HELPFUL AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD PLEASE FEEL FREE.
I'M SURE THIS IS NOW I WOULD.
ALL RIGHT. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
NO I WOULD JUST SAY THAT- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE- LOCAL IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION ESPECIALLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- IN AREAS THAT
ARE REALLY HARD HIT WITH
COLEMAN- YOU KNOW IT I THINK IT
MAY TAKE SOME WORK BUT IT IS
NOT GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN. THEIR
LOCAL OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AT EITHER THIRTY OR
THE TRIP AWAY IN THAT AREA.
STEPPING UP TO BECOME LIKE THE
LOCAL ADMINISTRATOR YOU KNOW
WORKING WITH. YOU KNOW RYAN
AUTHORS WHO'VE BEEN YOU KNOW
HAS BEEN GREAT THERE HASN'T
BEEN ANY DELAY THE PAYMENT. OF
THE PAPERWORK REQUIRED AND NOT
LIKE ALCOHOL OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT IT SHOULD BE. YOU KNOW IN
WHAT. THEY WANT OTHER BARRIER.
TO PARTICIPATING I THINK IT'S
JUST SETTING SOMETHING UP LOCAL
IF NOT. THE BACKEND OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT. SO IF YOU IF YOU
WERE TO TALK ON LINE NEEDS IN
THE STARTING THING AT THE TO
GET A- FEEL FREE TO CONTACT ME.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK. THAT AND UP
RIGHT DID YOU HAVE A CALM. YES
I DID I JUST WANNA- REALLY
EMPHASIZE WHAT SORRY JUST SAY
TRULY AS KNOW- LOCAL STATE
FEDERAL PROGRAM AT ITS BEST- MY
TEAM HERE IT'S OH YES IS
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH- THE
LOCAL WIN A TRIP WHICH UNITIES
AND PROVIDE THEM WHATEVER THEY
NEED I WILL SAY SOME YOU KNOW
ONE NOT NECESSARY BARRIER BUT
IT IS A VERY PARTICULAR IN
CENTER VALLEY AND OTHERS. SAID
PLAY YOUR- YOU KNOW WHAT
DISTRICT WE HAVE A LARGE.
PORTION OF BEING SPEAKING-
AGAIN. AND A LOT OF THOSE
CITIES SEVEN ACTUALLY GO INTO
THE LOCAL GROCERY STORES AND-
AND IN OTHER PLACES WORK WHERE
THEY CAN SEE PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO SEE THE PURCHASE
FOOD OR- ARE JUST GET OUT AND-
THEY'VE BEEN BURKE AND- THE A
CITY THAT SELLS ARE BRINGING
TRANSLATORS- TO TRY TO
PARTICIPATE AND THE ROLE IN THE
PROGRAM AND I THINK THE MORE
THAT WE GET OUT OF THAT. OUT OF
REACH TO THE FINE AND DESIGN
WITH THIS PROGRAM IS HOW IT
ACTUALLY HELPS YOU HOW IT'S NO
COST TO YOU- I THINK THEY'LL BE
HUGE OUTBREAKS THERE'S BEEN
SOME HUGE SUCCESS AS- A FROM
CITIES. WE WENT OUT JUST THAT.
AND OF COURSE WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE THOSE. I HAVE ONE
MORE LAST QUESTION IT IT MAY BE
A QUESTION THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO BE. ANSWERED BUT-
JUST A- AND THINKING OF JUST
THE- THAT WE HAVE. ENDED QUITE
FRANKLY GET JUSTICE COULD TO
GROW RIGHT IN TERMS OF
INSECURITY I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S ANY INFORMATION FROM
ANY. COLLECTED IN TERMS OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DOOR-
DEATHS TO DO IT YES. BLACKFORD
STARVATION. CAN ANYBODY COMMENT
ON THAT. THE MANAGER I DON'T
HAVE ANY STATS OF DOUBTS BUT I
WILL SAY- WHEN WE WERE WORKING
WITH CHS EARLIER IN MARCH TO
DESIGN THIS FIRST EVER- PROGRAM
NATIONALLY- ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS WE DID DESIGN ESTAS
OTHER STATES DID WELLNESS
CHECKS AND THEY WERE-
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE THAT WERE
ELDERLY THAT HAVE PASSED SO
THAT HAS BEEN A DRIVER OF THE
GREAT PLACE PROGRAMS IS JUST
THAT HOW DO WE BEST ENSURE
THAT- THE PEOPLE WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE THEY HAVE NO OTHER.
OPTION FOR GETTING SAID- AND
YOU KNOW THE FIFTY SIX DOLLARS
AND A SHOW IN THE YOU KNOW SO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE BEING FED-
ARE NOT PART OF THAT SYSTEM
STATE BANK I DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFICS I CAN SAY THE DRIVER
OF GRAVESITES. PROGRAM THAT WAS
ONE OF THE MAIN DRIVERS. AND
MADAM CHAIR KATHY CENTER IF I
MIGHT ALSO. IN A THIS ONE FOR
CW. I THINK- WHEN WE- TALK TO
K. OF WHY. WHAT THEY WERE DOING
AS FAR AS OUR REACH. IT WAS
MAYBE NOT COMPLETELY ACROSS THE
BOARD BUT NEARLY EVERY COUNTY
THAT I WAS AWARE HAD A PROJECT
ROOM KEY. PROGRAM WHICH OF
COURSE IS- TARGETED AT SIMILAR
STRUGGLING UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS HOMELESS
POPULATIONS THAT WOULD.
TYPICALLY BE VERY VULNERABLE TO
ILLNESS- AND POTENTIAL THAT.
ARE NOT JUST BECAUSE OF CALL
GOOD GOOD BECAUSE OF OTHER JUST
STRUCTURAL ISSUES- AS WELL DIE
AND YOU KNOW AND A LACK OF
HOUSING SUPPORT. THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT OUR REACH IN CONCERT
WITH THE PROJECT ROOM KEY.
PROGRAMS TO TRY TO BRING THE
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE GET THE
INDIVIDUAL SIGNED UP FOR
CALFRESH. CONNECT THEM WITH
OTHER SERVICES THAT THEY MIGHT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR AND I THINK
IT'S DRIVEN FROM THE SAME KINDS
OF CONCERNS THAT- A ROOF OVER
SOMEONE'S HEAD AND YOU KNOW
THAT THAT PROJECT ROOM KEY- AND
I PROJECT HOME KEY AS IS
MORPHING INTO. IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND HELPS SO MUCH
TO AVOID THOSE KINDS OF REALLY
SIGNIFICANT ELEMENTS SAYS. AND
EVEN PROJECT PREMATURE DEATHS
THAT WE SEE. BUT IT'S NOT THE
ONLY THING WE ALSO NEED TO
BRING THESE OTHER SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO BEAR AND SO ON. I
WAS. REALLY HAPPY WHEN I WAS
TALKING AND CHECKING IN WITH
COUNTIES TO SEE THAT LEVEL OF
OUTREACH TO THOSE. INDIVIDUALS
TO THAT PROGRAM. THANK YOU CAP
YET YOU KNOW I WANNA GO HEAD IN
OFFER ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY MY OF
THE COMMITTEE TO. PASS ANY AT
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND OR
COMMENTS I'M SURE THAT AS I WAS
SPEAKING THEIR YOU KNOW- AND
ASKING QUESTIONS THAT. MAYBE
THERE'S SOME POTTERY IDEAS THAT
CAME UP SO. ANY SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND I REALLY WANT TO%
THANK THE PANEL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY I DID HAVE
A QUESTION- IS WE CAN WE TALK
ABOUT HOW FRESH- EARLIER ON THE%
PRESENTATION AND- AND WE HAVE
THESE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS-
ALTHOUGH I. THINK THAT IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO MEET THE TOTAL
NEED- WE SORT OF WORK TO DO-
BUT PARTICULARLY. IN RELATION
TO THE PUBLIC PROGRAMS. TO WHAT
DEGREE IS THE PUBLIC CHARGE
RULE. AFFECTING PEOPLE NOTS WHO
NEED THESE HELP WHICH THE LONG
LINES OF PEOPLE NEEDING TO GET
FOOD- PERHAPS NOT ABLE TO NOT
WILLING TO SIGN UP FOR COVERAGE
EFFECTIVE JUST A YEAR AGO PRE
COATED DIVERT NEW STORIES ABOUT
PEOPLE DROPPING. PROGRAMS LIKE
CALFRESH AND THEN OF COURSE
THEY MIGHT BE GIANTS FOOD
BANKS- TRYING TO GET THROUGH
THAT WAY SO. APPS AND ALSO MISS
UNDERLING AND- THIS COMPELS
WANTS TO SPEAK TO IS THREE L.
IS HOW MUCH OF A PROBLEM IS
THAT RIGHT NOW PEOPLE NOT
WILLING TO SIGN UP FOR PUBLIC
PROGRAMS LIKE CALFRESH. I
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PUBLIC CHARGE AND THEN
MAYBE HOW HOW HOW DOES MEET
NEEDS BEING MET TODAY TO START
SHIFTS TO FOOD BANKS OR OTHER
TYPES OF- SOURCES. ASSEMBLY I'D
BE HAPPY TO START THAT AND THEN
HANDED OFF TO OTHERS- KATHY
AGAIN FROM CEDAR BDA. I DID-
NOTE DOWN IN MY NOTES SORT OF
PREPARING FOR THIS THAT PUBLIC
CHARGE IS LIKELY STILL BEING AN
ISSUE OUT THERE. THAT
ADMINISTRATION CURRENTLY AND DC
HAS- CONTINUED TO ATTEMPT TO
STRENGTHEN ENFORCEMENT. TODAY
THIS IS. SORT OF AN OFFSHOOT OF
PUBLIC CHARGE THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS. I'M THINKING
IMMIGRATION SERVICES TO THE U.
S. R. I IMMIGRATION SERVICES
JUST OUT TODAY. AND I THINK
EVERY TIME YOU SEE A HEADLINE.
OF ANOTHER STRENGTHENING
ANOTHER- TIGHTENING DOWN OF THE
SERVICES IT DOES HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT WE'VE-
HISTORICALLY SEEN THAT ON THE
PUBLIC CHARGES YOU FOR YEARS.
THROUGH YOU KNOW SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN- AS I THINGS WERE PUT
OUT EVEN IN DRAFT FORM. THERE
WOULD BE- PULLING BACK PEOPLE
SAYING STOP MY APPLICATION STOP
MY COVERAGE- I'M I'M CONCERNED.
AND IT WAS NOT AT THAT POINT
YOU KNOW OUR OUR ORIGINAL
TALKING POINTS FOR OUR WORKERS.
WE STARTED FROM A PLACE OF YOU
KNOW DON'T WORRY TOO MUCH
BECAUSE YOU ARE LEGITIMATELY
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE PROGRAMS. I
MEAN WE ARE YOU KNOW I'M-
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY I
MEAN WE WOULD SAY UNFORTUNATELY
TO A LARGE DEGREE. MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT SERVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A SATISFACTORY IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON THE
PROGRAMS TO BEGIN WITH THEY HAD
TO PROVE THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE. AND THAT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. COULD END
WITH A SATISFACTORY DEFINITION.
FOR NEARLY EVERY PROGRAM THAT I
NUMBERS RUN. AND SO HAVING
PEOPLE WHO HAVE. FOUND
ELIGIBILITY THAT PROGRAM WHICH
CAN BE HARD ESPECIALLY IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ENGLISH AS THEIR-
FIRST LANGUAGE I WE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY. ONLY TO
HAVE THEM FRIGHTENED- THAT THE
PUBLIC CHARGE ROLES- HAVE ALSO
BEEN STOPPED I AND STATE BY THE-
NEW TIMES OVER THE- YEAR AND A
HALF TO TWO. AND THEN WE- AGAIN
AND THAT'S GROW I MEAN THAT'S
CONFUSING OUR WORKERS LET
ALONE. SOMEBODY OUT THERE
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
TO FIGURE OUT IS THAT ON IS OFF
AND I COULD SEE PEOPLE JUST GET
SO SCARED AND FRUSTRATED. BUT
THEY JUST KIND OF THROW THEIR
HANDS UP AND TO STOP AND GO
INSTEAD TO SOMEPLACE LIKE A
FOOD BANK OR CHURCH WHERE THEY
MAY HAVE SERVICES AVAILABLE
WHERE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ASKED THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS SO
YEAH IT CONTINUES TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN I GOT MORE
HOPEFUL THE OUTLOOK FOR THIS
COULD BE IMPROVED IN THE FUTURE
BUT AS OF NOW THESE RULES ARE
THERE AND- EVEN JUST TODAY LIKE
I SAID THINGS CONTINUE. TO
HAPPEN WITH IMMIGRATION AND
IMMIGRANTS IN THE NEWS AND
EVERY TIME WHAT WAS THAT THAT
HAS A CHILLING EFFECT- AS HARD
TO GATHER DATA ON PEOPLE WHO
DON'T. APPLY AS YOU KNOW- BUT
CERTAINLY WE SEE- AND HAVE SEEN
OVER TIME SO MANY PEOPLE TO.
TAKE THEMSELVES OFF THE
PROGRAMMER TAKE YOU KNOW THEIR
FAMILIES OFF THE PROGRAM EVEN
AT THEIR THEIR ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THEM- THAT'S REALLY HARD TO SEE.
THE YOU COME AND THEN AT THE
INTERESTED HEARING FROM FOOD
BANKS AS WELL AS WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING- THESE ARE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
QUALIFY. MAYBE PERHAPS ARE U.
S. CITIZENS WHO ARE PART OF
NEXT FAMILIES WHO ARE
BASICALLY. NOT AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF DESPERATELY
NEEDED. FOOD BECAUSEOF. THIS-
REGULATION. YEAH THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. TWENTY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU. AND THEN
PERHAPS I DON'T KNOW IF TAT IS
COMPELS FROM FOOD TO US CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FOOD BANK ARE YOU
SEEING- PEOPLE WHO PERHAPS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR- SERVICES
LIKE CALFRESH POTENTIALLY UP TO
DRINK BECAUSE- EIGHT. OUR
FREIGHT TO APPLY. DEFINITELY I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
ANECDOTALLY APARTMENT AND I'M
HAPPY JEFF AND KATHY JUST
COMMUNICATED- AND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE- A LARGE- PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE SERVING
IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ARE
LACKING ACT COMMUNITY AND- THEY.
ARE AND- BUILD ARE YOU BY
PUBLIC CHAU AND THEIR ARE
TYPICALLY- I'M THEM SO FORMER
WHERE THE KIDS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR. BUT BECAUSE THERE'S- ONE
INTERSEGMENT GATED BUT FEDERAL
STANDARDS HERE REGARDING- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT- PUBLIC CHARGE
WILL THAT DAY ARE YOU.
ENROLLING IN THE S. AND WHICH
THEIR CHILDREN- OR- AND HELP
NUMBER ARE L. BE BUT. YOU KNOW
HERE OF DEPORTATION OR- OR
RETALIATION. YEAH THE APPLE
MANY EMERGENCY COULD THAT WORK
AND BAD WHICH KNOW QUICK BUT
HIGHER NOT. THANK YOU PARTNERS
BE ABLE TO COLLECT GROWING YOU
COUPLE THAT WITH THE CAN DOWN
ARE YOU GOING AT THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT. HAVE NEVER NEEDED SERVICE
BUT BEFORE I KNEW COULD NOT YOU
KNOW THANK YOU COULD NOT AND-
ANYTHING AND WE'RE GOING NOT
MEETING FOR. FIBER ONE I'M THE
EMERGING YOUNG NUMBER PROVIDE
YOU CAN PROVIDE NINE SO WE NEED
THE PROBE TO WORK I YOU KNOW.
FOR YOU KNOW FOR THOSE THAT ARE
RIGHT EMERGING NOT WORKING NOT
UP- YOU KNOW THAT THE DIFFERENT
TACK YEAH ACTUALLY PROVIDE THEM.
ON THE HEALTH CARE AND PERHAPS
WE CAN ASK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IN THE CURRENT
MINISTRATION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES SO THAT WE CAN HELP AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU UP THANK YOU TO
THE PANEL FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY AT THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IS. VERY INFORMATIVE
SO WE'LL BE MOVING ON TO OUR
FINAL PANEL AND WE WILL DISCUSS
CHANGES IN SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAM
STRYCOVA NINETEEN. AND WE HAVE-
STEPHANIE BRUCE. WITH PETER
TURCHIN CERTAIN NUTRITION
SERVICES DIRECTOR PALM SPRINGS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- AS OUR
FOR SPEAKERS SO- STEPHANIE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THIS
WONDERFUL HEARING AND INVITING
ALL OF US TO SPEAK INCLUDING
MYSELF AND I'D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T THANK ALL OF THE
PREVIOUS PANELISTS FOR. SO
ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBING THE
COMPLEXITIESOF THESE PROGRAMS
AND THE STRUGGLE THAT MANY OF
THOSE WHO- SHOULD BE
PARTICIPATING IN THEM FACE. IN
IN JUST PARTICIPATING IN THESE
PROGRAMS THAT WE OFFER AND BUT
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF NUTRITION
SERVICES FOR PALM SPRINGS
UNIFIED AND WE ARE A
PREDOMINANTLY HISPANIC DISTRICT
WE COVER FIVE CITIES PALM
SPRINGS DESERT HOT SPRINGS.
CATHEDRAL CITY THOUSAND PALMS
IN A PORTION OF RANCHO MIRAGE.
AND WE PRIOR TO COPE ED WERE
87% FREE AND REDUCED- WE ARE
NOW LOOKING TO PROBABLY REACH
ABOUT 96% FREE AND REDUCED POST
CODE ED- AND AS MANY OF YOU MAY
KNOW THAT WE ARE A RESORT TOWN.
AND SO ON MARCH THIRTEENTH MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES LOST THEIR JOB
I'M AND IN MOST OF OUR FAMILIES
I AM STILL REMAIN UNEMPLOYED AT
BECAUSE OF THE INABILITY TO
OPEN UP MANY OF OUR RESTAURANTS
HOTELS- AND OTHER HOSPITALITY.
FUNCTIONS FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO GET BACK TO WORK THROUGH OUR
MEAL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR THEM.
M. 63% OF OUR ENROLLMENT IS
AUTOMATICALLY QUALIFIED FOR THE
MEAL PROGRAM BASED ON THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT CALFRESH SNAP ON
MEDICARE. AND SO AS A RESULT OF
THAT WE ARE A 1100% C. E. P.
DISTRICT SO ALL MEALS ARE
SERVED AT NO COST TO YOU ARE
I'M STUDENT POPULATION. AND SO
WHEN THE SHUTDOWN HAPPENED WE
KNEW THAT WAS GOING T BE A
HUGE NEED FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I'M JUST TO PUT THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE ON A NORMAL SCHOOL
YEAR WHERE WE'RE SERVING
BREAKFAST LUNCH AND SUPPER. AND
WE SERVE APPROXIMATELY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION MEALS AND
SINCE THE PANDEMIC HIT WE HAVE
ALREADY SERVED THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION MEALS M. AND WILL
FAR SURPASS THAT AND BY THE
TIME WE GET TO THE END OF OUR
SCHOOL YEAR. AT SO THEY NEED
ALTHOUGH HAS DECLINED A LITTLE
AND IT IS STILL GREATLY NEEDED
AND FOR ALL OF OUR PARENTS AND
OUR STUDENTS AS WELL. BUT I
WANT TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT A SILVER LINING IN
THIS WHOLE PANDEMIC AND- PRIOR
TO COPE ED OUR GOAL HERE IN
PALM SPRINGS WAS TO REDUCE
PACKAGING AND- TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS. A REAL MEAL AS WE
CALL IT SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO SIT DOWN AND SPEND TEN
MINUTES ON PACKAGING I. TO EAT
ANTS THAT WE CONSIDER THEM MOVE
ON A- ON A PLATE HAND IT TO
THEM AND THEY CAN SIT DOWN AND
SPEND THE TWENTY TO THIRTY
MINUTES EATING INSTEAD OF
OPENING PACKAGES. I'M WE HAD
JUST INSTALLED OUR LAST SALAD
BAR IN OUR LAST SCHOOL SITE- SO
THAT STUDENTS WERE BEING
OFFERED. A VARIETY OF FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THERE
WERE SIX VARIETIES OF
VEGETABLES IN TWO VARIETIES OF
FRUIT EVERY DAY OFFERED TO THEM
ON AN OPEN PRODUCE FAR. MOST OF
WHICH WAS PROVIDED BY LOCAL
FARMERS FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
HIT BE HAD TO SCRAP ALL OF THAT
IDEA INCLUDING OUR BEAUTIFUL
PRODUCE BARS. AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE WERE GOING
TO PROVIDE. YOU GREAT QUALITY
MEAL THAT WE WERE PROVIDING I
THIS PANDEMIC AND- AS LUCK
WOULD HAVE IT A LOCAL DATE
FARMER WHO. AND HIS COMPLETE
SUPPLY CHAIN WAS CUT OFF IN
MARCH. ASKED ME IF I HAD ANY
USE FOR DATES AND YOU KNOW I
SAID WELL I'M I CAN'T AFFORD
THEM ON THIS MEAL PROGRAM. AND
I THINK I HEARD. EARLIER THAT
THE- THE- AND THE FOR THE- WAS
SIXTY DOLLARS FOR THREE MEALS
I'M IN OUR REIMBURSEMENT OF
LESS THAN FOUR DOLLARS PER MEAL-SO. AND WITH THAT IT'S HARD TO
AFFORD- SOMETHING LIKE A DATE
THAT IS USUALLY A HIGH RETAIL
ITEM. WELL HE WAS ABLE TO GET
IT DOWN TO THE COSTS THAT WE
NEEDED WAS ABLE TO. PACKAGE IT
FOR US SO THAT WE CAN
DISTRIBUTE IT. AND MY STUDENTS
WERE ABLE TO GET DATES FOR THE
FIRST TIME ON THE MEAL PROGRAM
AND- THE TWO OF US TO STARTED
TALKING AND I HAD TOLD HIM HOW
FOR YEARS I HAD BEEN TRYING TO-
MEET AND TALK TO THE LOCAL
GROWERS HEARING COACHELLA. AND
SEE IF I COULD GET THEIR
PRODUCE ON OUR STUDENTS PLATES
AND- NO ONE REALLY COULD
UNDERSTAND THE NEED THEN AND
I'M MAINLY BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND. THE PROGRAM
AT THE VOLUME OF THE PROGRAM.
WELL HE BECAME. THE MIDDLE MAN
AND WE STARTED BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE LOCAL
FARMERS WHOSE CONTRACTS WERE
GONE OVERNIGHT. AND THOSE WERE
WHO ARE SMALL FARMERS WHO
DIDN'T HAVE MAJOR CORPORATION-
CONTRACTS WERE GONNA GET PAID
WHETHER THEIR FRUIT WAS PICKED
OR NOT. AND OFFERED UP THEIR
CROPS AND WE FIGURED OUT HOW
MUCH I COULD PURCHASE WHICH
TURNED OUT TO BE ALL OF IT. AND
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE JUST
STARTED GOING OUT TO THE FRUIT
PRODUCERS AND SAYING WHAT YOU
HAVE WHAT CAN I TAKE. AND WE
PUT TOGETHER A PRODUCE BOX AND
WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO WITH
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE FOR THE- THE
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE MEAL
PROGRAM. ABLE TO MEET THE
NUTRITIONAL GUIDELINES ABLE TO
MEET OUR FOOD COSTS AND ABLE TO
PUT A WHOLE FRESH PRODUCE IN
THE HANDS OF OUR KIDS. MUCH OF
WHICH THEY'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE
AND WE WERE DOING DIFFERENT
KINDS OF BIG PLANS I HAD NEVER
SEEN BEFORE I'M A GRAFFITI
EGGPLANT WHICH IS A SMALL
LITTLE PURPLE EGGPLANT. WITH
WHITE VARIEGATED LINES THROUGH
IT DELICIOUS- AND I FOUND IT A
WHOLE FOODS MARKET. FOR SEVEN
DOLLARS PER EGG PLANT AND I WAS
GIVING IT AS PART OF THE MULE
PRO. I'M SO IT. IT WAS A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
ESTABLISHED AND WE CONTINUE
TODAY. I WISH I COULD TELL YOU
HOW MANY WE'VE DONE WE DO
APPROXIMATELY THREE TO FOUR
THOUSAND BOXES A WEEK. OUT TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND HAVE DONE
THAT- SINCE ALMOST THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC AND-
WE'RE HOPING TO MOVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP M. INTO. THE NEXT
PHASE OF THIS. PANDEMIC WHICH
HOPEFULLY ONCE WE GET OUR
STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL WERE
ABLE TO TAKE IT TO SOME PALLETS
AND NOT IN THESE VARIETY OF
BOXES. AND ABLE TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS A OF FRESH. PRODUCE
BAR SO TO SPEAK THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE SERVING TO
THEM AND- SAID OF THEM WALKING
DOWN AN OPEN BAR AND SERVING
THEMSELVES- BUT- YOU KNOW WITH
ALL OF THAT THE COMPLEXITIES OF
OUR PROGRAMS AND- THE- THE- AND
HURDLES THAT WE FACE IN ORDER
TO GET WHAT WE NEED. TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND- JUST
PARTNERING THE PEOPLE RIGHT
NEXT DOOR WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE ON THE PATH THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAINTAIN AND- PROVIDE
A WELL BALANCED NUTRITIOUS
FRESH. LOCAL PRODUCTS TO OUR
STUDENTS ON THIS BILL PROGRAM.
SO JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE THAT AND-
THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
STEPHANIE UP TAX WE HAVE A LISA
KENNY OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. LISA UP.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. ALL. PLEASE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
VIDEO AND YOUR- MIKE. NOW. OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. WE CAN
HEAR YOU AND WE CAN SEE YOU
DON'T. WELCOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF COURSE NOT THANK YOU.
OF SO GOOD AFTERNOON HAIR
WOMAN ALL THE MEMBERS WHAT I'VE
HEARD TODAY HAS BEEN JUST SUCH
GREAT INFORMATION- MY NAME IS
LISA CANNY I BURKE FOR UN
CENTRAL CITY SCHOOLS FOOD
SERVICE I'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS- I STARTED
OUT AS A DELIVERY DRIVER AND-
NOW I'M A THREE MANAGING THE
KITCHENETTE BEHAVE THIS STEP IN
OUR CANAL AREA. I STILL HAVE
YOU GUYS YES WE CAN. SAKE IT IS
ALL. OKAY SO- WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO TALK TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT IS
OUR FOOD SERVICE PROGRAM THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING SINCE THE
PANDEMIC HITS. WE STARTED OUT
ACTUALLY- WORKING OUT OF A BAND
SERVING LUNCHES TO KIDS AND-
WE'RE STILL DOING THAT BUT WE
HAVE A SET UP FOR COMMUNITY
AND- WE HAVE NOW JUST GOT ALL
OF OUR KIDS BACK HERE TO BE OF
ASSISTANCE THEY WERE DOING TWO
SEPARATE WE'RE DOING IN AM PM
PROGRAM. IT'S SO FAR SEEMS TO
BE WORKING VERY WELL- SH ELSE'S
WHEN I JUST HIT THE- TWENTY
THREE YOU. I UNDERSTAND. I
UNDERSTAND THAT- GILROY IS TO-
ADAPTER PROGRAM THAT OFFERS US.
SERVING LATER IN THE DAY TO
HELP THE PEOPLE THAT COME CAN
COME AS EARLY AS A NEED TO COME.
AND SO THAT'S A GREAT THING
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND WE'RE
TRYING TO ALSO DO THAT WE'VE
GOT- I'M KIND OF BABBLING SEPT
AT LEAST STRUCTURE IF YOU'RE
HEARING ME- WE SERVE THE
COMMUNITY FROM TEN O'CLOCK TO
ONE O'CLOCK EVERY DAY. AND WE
HAVE OUR- OTHER- COAT COLOR
CLASSES THAT WE SERVE. AND- I
THOUGHT PROCESS I'M SO SORRY
I'VE BEEN WAITING WAITING TO
TALK YOU KNOW OUR COMPLETELY
LOST FROM GOING. THIS SO ANYWAY
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE FOOD SERVICE PROGRAM. YOU
KNOW WHAT I AM IF YOU'RE DONE
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION I WILL
BRING BE A CONVERSATION BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WE
CAN OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
I'M SORRY SIX HARD TO HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING OKAY. IF WE'RE
DONE WITH YOUR PRESENTATION WE
WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. IT BUT YOU DON'T SEE
WHAT ELSE I WAS GONNA. SO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I WAS
ASKED WAS ABOUT THE- FEEDING
THE ARE THE KIDS LIKE WHEN
AFTER WHEN THEY GO HOME AND WE
DO ACTUALLY HAVE IS HAVE THAT
SET UP IT'S CALLED AND SERVE
SELL. SHELF STABLE LUNCHES SO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
SERVING- LUNCHES TO THE KIDS AT
SCHOOL AND THEN WE'RE ALSO
GIVING THEM A BREAKFAST TO TAKE
HOME WITH THEM. SO THEY CAN EAT
BREAKFAST THE NEXT MORNING
BEFORE THEY COME TO SCHOOL. AND
THEN WE ALSO DO ON FRIDAYS WE
DO WHAT WE CALL WHAT I CALL ON
FRIDAY THREE IT'S WHERE WE-
WERE ABLE TO FEED OUR COMMUNITY
AND ALSO SEND THEM HOME WITH
ENOUGH BREAKFAST AND LUNCH IS
TO GET THEM THROUGH THE WEEKEND
AND A BREAKFAST FOR MONDAY FOR
WHEN THEY COME BACK TO SCHOOL.
ALSO WE HAVE THEN WE WERE DOING
THE- YOU SEE. BUDGET JUST SORRY.
SO YEAH YOU KNOW THE FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING THIS WHOLE TIME TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEY JUST THERE
ARE OTHER AMAZING PEOPLE THE
THINGS THAT THEY DO AND THE WAY
THEY DO IT. IS I CAN'T TELL YOU
IN WORDS- FEEDING THE KIDS IS
JUST SUCH AN IMPORTANT THING TO
DO AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY'VE
GOT THE FOOD THEY NEED TO HELP
THEM LEARN AND- GROW AND- WE
WITH WITH THANK YOU LISA AND
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND- IN AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO- COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OF FOR THIS PANEL-
AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START
OFF WITH. A CENTER PAN. RIGHT
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND- CERTAINLY TRYING TO GET
OUR KIDS THAT IS GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION IS THAT-
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR BEFORE CO
THERE'D. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
KIDS ARE OR HOW MANY KIDS ARE
YOU FEEDING SO DO YOU SEE A
DROP OFF AND HOW MUCH IS THAT
NOW THAT WE'RE WITH CODED AND
DISTANCE LEARNING SO FOTH
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR
AND THEN DURING THE SUMMER WHEN
THE KIDS ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AND
WE HAVE SOME REAL PROGRAMS OUT
THAT'S THE A LARGE DROP BOXES
KIDS WHO QUALIFIED FOR. REDUCED
LUNCH- DURING THE SUMMER SO I
WAS WONDERING AS FAR AS- I KNOW
THAT LAW SCHOOLS ARE DOING
WORKING VERY HARD TO DISTRIBUTE
MEALS OUT TO FAMILIES AND THEIR
KIDS. HOW MUCH OF A DROP OFF
HAVE WE SEEN FROM LET'S SAY
LAST YEAR. CREEK OVERHEAD. TO
NOW IN TERMS OF SIZE OF
FAMILIES OR STUDENTS BEING
SERVED. YEAH I HAVE THAT FOR
YOU ACTUALLY IN FEBRUARY OF-
NINETEEN TWENTY WE DID FORTY
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED LEVEL
INCHES. ELEVEN MEALS AND THEN
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FORTY BREAKFAST. AND IN APRIL
OF NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY WE
DID SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN LUNCHES AND
SEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN BREAKFAST SO THERE
WAS QUITE A DROP. IN THERE THE
NUMBERS AT THE END AND IT'S
HARD TO GET THE STATUS DE DO
YOU- THIRTEEN TERMS OF. WHAT
THE IMPACT OF THAT IN SO THE
EXPECTATION IS YOU HAVE A LOT
MORE KIDS TO- NEEDED THESE
MEALS AND NOW WE KNOW A LOT
FEWER GETTING THEM DO YOU KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS
IN THOSE WAYS DO YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT PART. I
WOULD DON'T IT WAS LIKE-
BECAUSE NOW ARE WE ARE MALES
ARE STARTING TO COME UP AGAIN
NOW. BUT YESTERDAY THE CHINA IS
THE BEST WAY TO CONVERT IT.
PLEASE I MIGHT BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THAT THANK YOU. I'M LIKE I'M
SO SORRY I'M SO BEFUDDLED I WAS
SO WORRIED I WOULDN'TBE ABLE
TO TALK TO YOUR BILL TO HEAR ME
AND NOW THAT I. CAN'T SEEM TO.
ITS OPPONENT. SENATOR PAN SO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- LIKE AT
LEAST IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY OTHER DISTRICTS SAW A
HUGE DROP IN PARTICIPATION. AND
IT REALLY HAD TO DO WITH- THEIR
FREE AND REDUCED PERCENTAGE SO.
THOSE WHO WERE LOWER FRAME
REDUCE ALL LARGE DROP IN
PARTICIPATION IN MAINLY
BECAUSE- OF THE ACCESS. AND
STUDENTS WERE ON CAMPUS AND
APPEARANCE SOME PARENTS WERE
STILL WORKING. AND WEREN'T ABLE
TO GET THE PARENTS TO SCHOOLS
TO GET THEM THEIR FOOD SO. MANY
DISTRICTS CHANGE THEIR
OPERATIONS TO ALLOW FOR EARLY
MORNING OR LATE EVENING OR LATE
AFTERNOON. AND EARLY EVENING.
TO ALLOW THE PARENTS TO COME
AND PARTICIPATE SO THEY STARTED
TO SEE- PARTICIPATION GROW. I
KNOW HERE IN OUR DISTRICT WE
WERE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ANOMALY. WE ACTUALLY SERVED OUR
TOTAL MEALS THAT WE SERVE ALL
LAST SUMMER. THE FIRST WEEK. IN
MAY LAST SUMMER WE DID SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND MEALS IN TWO
MONTHS WE DID SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEALS IN ONE WEEK. M.
AND WE ACTUALLY DID CLOSE TO
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND MEALS
OVER THE SUMMER. AND SO I AM
AND THAT HAD EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAD
SEVERAL SITES OPEN WE HAD BUSES
DELIVERING TO BUS STOPS. AND SO
WE WERE TRYING TO GET TO THE
FAMILIES WHO DIDN'T HAVE
TRANSPORTATION. AND SO NOW THAT
SCHOOL IS BACK IN SESSION AND
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE OUR BUSES
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT'S A
CONTRACTED COMPANY THEY'RE NOT
EMPLOYEES OF THE DISTRICT. AND
WE ARE LOSING OUT ON AND THOSE
STUDENTS ARE LOSING. ACCESS TO
THE MEAL PROGRAM BECAUSE WE
JUST DON'T. HAVE THAT ACCESS
RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE LOOKING
ACTUALLY INTO STARTING AN
ONLINE MEAL SERVICE. SO THEY
CAN ORDER AND WILL DELIVER AND
JUST WILL HAVE. CERTAIN AREAS
OF. OUR DISTRICT. YOUR DELIVERY
DATE WILL BE THURSDAY SO BE
HOME BETWEEN THESE HOURS. PLACE
YOUR ORDER WILL BRING IT TO
YOU. AND ANYTHING WE. CAN DO TO
JUST IMPROVE ACCESS. NO NOT
SOME YEAH. NO THANK YOU AND
THAT THESE LESSONS THAT WERE.
THAT NOT ONLY OF COURSE WILL
HELP DURING CO THAT HOPEFULLY
WHEN WE'RE ABLE TO GET CONTROL
OF IT AND- SO FORTH THE NAVY
WITH ACCION AND WE GET. PEOPLE
TO YOU KNOW SHELTER AND WATER
MASKS AND SO FORTH. I THINK
THESE ARE YEAH WE WERE DEALING
WITH THIS PROBLEM CREE COVE IT
GOT WORSE WITH CODE BUT- NOT
EVEN AS WE'RE GETTING HOPEFULLY
EVENTUALLY GONNA GET COVERED
UNDER CONTROL THESE ARE THINGS
WE SHOULD PRICE THINK ABOUT.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONTINUE
AFTERWARDS TO- THAN IMPROVING.
THE OUTRAGE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PAN AYE SO I HAVE A
ONE QUESTION OF FOR A STEPHANIE
I'D LIKE TO- KNOW IF YOU- YOU
KNOW. AND I KNOW YOU TOUCHED ON
THIS A LITTLE BIT BUT BUT DO
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT TACK
CORPS NADINE WITH OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY BUT I WANTED
TO KNOW IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
WORK BEING DONE IN. OUR
PARTNERSHIPSWITH ANY CHILD
CARE CENTERS. WE ACTUALLY
DELIVERED A CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND OBEY OUR LOCAL ARE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE-
PROVIDED IS A LIST THAT THEY
WERE AWARE OF. WE KNOW OF
SEVERAL IN OUR OWN AREA AND
MANY OF THEM ARE SHOWING UP
TOWARD DISTRIBUTION SITES SO WE
JUST GOT THEIR INFORMATION OF
THE DISTRIBUTION SITE SO THAT
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO COME OUT.
TO PICK UP WE JUST DELIVER
STRAIGHT TO THEM. AND CAN YOU
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
HOW THAT WORKS BECAUSE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU I'M A LITTLE
I'M FAMILIAR WITH IT SURE IT
WILL BECAUSE WE'RE ON THE
SUMMER FOOD SERVICE PROGRAM
WERE ABLE TO SERVE ANY STUDENT-
EIGHTEEN UNDER ANY CHILD
EIGHTEEN AND UNDER. SO AS AS WE
DISCOVER OR FIND OUT ABOUT
CHILD CARE FACILITIES THAT
WE'RE UNAWARE OF OR EVEN THOSE
THAT WE ARE AWARE OF. THE JUST
PROVIDE US A ROSTER OF THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE ATTENDING AND
THEN WE PROVIDE THEM THE MEALS
I HAVE FOR THEM TO PROVIDE TO
THE STUDENTS. AND MANY OF THEM
COOK ON SITE SO WE PROVIDE THEM
AND- IT I MEAN IT WE LIKEN IT
TO LIKE A HELLO FRESH OR BLUE
APRON BOX THAT YOU CAN ORDER
ONLINE. WE PROVIDE THEM THE BOX
OF INGREDIENTS AND LAUGH MEALS
FOR BREAKFAST LUNCH SUPPER AND
AN AFTERNOON SNACK FOR THOSE
STUDENTS BECAUSE MANY OF THOSE
CHILDREN ARE WITH THEM FROM.
SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
UNTIL SEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE
EVENING. DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEIR PARENTS ARE WORKING- SO
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM ARE
COMMUTING AND WORKING AND
FLAUNT FAR DISTANCES FROM US
SO. WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HELP PROVIDE THEM WHAT
THEY NEED IF WE NEED TO COOK IT
HERE WE COOK HERE AND DELIVER
IT TO THEM HOT- OR DELIVER A
COLD BREAKFAST OR A COLD LUNCH
TO THEM. SO WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF MENUS AND WE JUST PROVIDE
THEM WHATEVER FITS BEST. FOR
THEIR- AB. THANK YOU AT ANOTHER
QUESTION JUST KIND OF PULL UP
ON THAT OUR TOPIC FAIR SO IS
THIS JUST A SPECIFIC BIT TO PUT
THE PALM SPRINGS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DOING SOMETHING SIMILAR WHERE
THEY'RE PROVIDING FOOD TO DATE.
AT DAY CARE CENTERS. MANY
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THIS I'M
I'M ON ZIEHM CHATS WITH
DIRECTORS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE. AND MANY OF HIS HEARING
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OR DOING THAT
I KNOW OF SEVERAL DISTRICTS IN
THE SACRAMENTO AREA WHO ARE
DOING THAT- AS WELL AS THE
FRESNO AREA WHICH IS WHERE MY
FAMILY'S FROM. SO I I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH ALL OF THEIR
EFFORTS AND ANY OF THEM WHO
HAVE STEPPED UP AND ASKED FOR
THE MEALS. THEY PROVIDED THEM-
MANY OF THEM OF HAVE FOUND THEM
THE WAY WE HAVE AS WELL THEY
SHOW UP TO THEIR DISTRIBUTION
SITES ONE IN TWENTY FIVE MEALS.
SO THAT USUALLY PEAKS OUR
INTERESTING WE FIND BETTER WAYS
TO PROVIDE FOR THEM SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THEIR
FACILITY TO COME GET THE MEALS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS A
WAY FOR US TO IMPROVE AB. TWO
BIT TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE STATE. YEAH I THINK
IT'S COUNTY BECAUSE COUNTY
OFFICES NO OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND IF THEY COULD PROVIDE THE
DISTRICTS WITH THE LIST OF
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT'S WHAT ARE
COUNTY OFFICE HERE IN RIVERSIDE
DID. AND WHEN I TALK TO OTHER-
DIRECTORS WHO ARE NOT WITHIN MY
COUNTY AND THEY FIND OUT I JUST
YOU KNOW GIVE YOUR COUNTY
OFFICE A CALL HERE'S THE OFFICE
THAT PROVIDED IT TO US. I MEAN
IT'S TYPICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AT THEY'VE
BEEN VERY HELPFUL THE BEEN A
GREAT PARTNER THROUGH ALL OF
THIS AND HELPING US. IMPROVE
ACCESS. NO I LOVE I LOVE THS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
INFORMATION AND- NO DISH OKAY
WE HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION
CENTER PAN THANK YOU IN TERMS
OF- THE AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THE WORK TO GET THE
FOOD OUT TO THE KIDS AND SO
FORTH- IS THERE ANY ISSUES IN
TERMS OF STAFF WHO ARE OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY DELIVERING OUR-
DISTRIBUTING THE FOOD- WITH
GETTING ACCESS TO PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEED TO
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE AND OF
COURSE PREVENTING SPREAD OF.
THE VIRUS. IS THAT AN ISSUE ARE
PEOPLE ABLE TO GET ACCESS TO
THE PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THEY
NEED. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
GET ACCESS AND I CAN TELL YOU
AND I'M SURE LISA CAN TO THAT-
CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS ARE
PROBABLY THE MOST CONCERNED
WITH SAFETY AND ALWAYS HAVE
BEEN. WE'VE WORN MASKS IN OUR
DEPARTMENT FOR YEARS AND
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CENTRAL
FACILITY. AND SO WE HAVE GLOVES
MASKS AND WE PROVIDE. THEM AT
HAND WIPES AND ALL OF OUR MEALS
WE'VE GOT HAND WASHING
STATIONS- SANITIZING STATIONS
WE HAVE A PROTOCOL ON HAND
WASHING- AND IF THEY'RE OUT
DELIVERING THEIR PROVIDED HAND
WIPES AS WELL SO THAT THEY CAN.
AT LEAST- WHY PAT DOWN THEIR
HANDS OR SOME OF THEM ARE
WEARING GLOVES AND JUST. CHANGE
THE GLOVES WITH EVERY DELIVERY
AND THEY'RE ALL THEY ALL REMAIN
SOCIALLY DISTANT WE'VE HAD TO.
AN HI I'D LIKE TO DESIGN FLOOR
ARE CITY IN OUR- NOW. PEOPLE
CAN ACTUALLY STAND SO IF YOURS
IF YOU'RE MOVING AROUND- OKAY
AS LONG AS YOU STAY DISTANT BUT
IF YOU'RE STANDING IN ONE PLACE
YOU HAVE TO STAND IN CERTAIN
LOCATIONS. TO ENSURE YOU STAY
SOCIALLY DISTANCE- BECAUSE IF
YOU'VE EVER HUNG OUT WITH THE
LUNCH LADY BEFORE WE ARE
FEELERS AND HUGGERS AND- WE
CONGREGATE SO. THAT'S BEEN THE
MOST DIFFICULT THING- I THINK
FOR NUTRITION SERVICE PERSONNEL
BUT I'M WE HAVE NOT HAD A
PROBLEM WITH ACCESS TO ANYTHING
AND PROVIDE EVERYTHING THEY
NEED. EXCELLENT WE HAVEN'T
EITHER WE GET EVERYTHING WE
NEED- WITH WITH THIS NEW-
BRINGING THE KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL WITH LIKE I SAID WE HAVE
THE A. M. PM CLASSES. SO IN
BETWEEN THEM EVERYTHING GETS
CLEANED AND STERILIZED BETWEEN
EVERY SET AND- WE'RE WE'VE GOT
EVERYTHING WE NEED WE'VE GOT
THE GLOVES LIKE YOU SAID WE GOT
THE MASS. THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
WHICH IS A VERY BIG DEAL AND
YEAH WE'VE GOT THE SAME THING
EVEN FOR THE KIDS WHERE THEY
WALKED AND WHERE THEY STAND. IN
LINE THEY'VE GOT THEIR START
SPOTS TO STAND ON. A VERY VERY
CONSCIOUS OF ALL OF THAT IN OUR
AREA. EXCELLENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M GLAD TO HEAR
THAT THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK
THE PANELISTS- YOU KNOW
PARTICIPATING TODAY THE SCHOOL
MEALS PROGRAMS ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO APPRECIATE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THAT MAN. YOU KNOW. I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE DAY CARE
COMPONENT THAT'S NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART- SPECIFICALLY SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PROVIDING
THAT INFORMATION AND FOR ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU DO- AT THIS
MOMENT TO WE ARE GOING TO OPEN
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL
AND NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE FOUR SEVEN FIVE. SEVEN ONE
THREE FIVE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING PORT
CALLS. COMMITTEE CHAIR MADE
INTO TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE AND ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
DO WE HAVE. THE BOSTON. HERE I
AM AGAIN. AND SINCE I CAN'T
TAKE OFF MY MASK I'LL TAKE OFF
MY GLASSES BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE
WITH THE MASS BECAUSE MY
GLASSES FOG UP DR PAN DO YOU
HAVE THAT PROBLEM IT'S
CHALLENGING. YOU SAID A MINUTE
THAT WHAT I'M GETTING. TWO
MINUTES TWO MINUTES OKAY WELL.
I'VE BEEN KNOWN TO FILL ANY
NUMBER OF MINUTES IN THIS ROOM.
HI I'M HAVING TO THINK ON MY
FEET TODAY BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
WANTED TO READ A POEM THAT I
LOVE. AND THAT FELT MORE
RELEVANT TO ME BUT THEN THIS
TALK COMES UP ABOUT. THIS
IMPULSE TO WANT TO FEED
CHILDREN. AND IT SOUNDS
AUTHENTIC. BUT THEN I LOOK BACK
INTO THE HISTORY OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THIS LEGISLATURE
AND HOW THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
TIED WHAT I SEE AS A BASIC
HUMAN NEED A BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS. TO VACCINE STATUS. CAL
WORKS CALFRESH WICK. THESE
THINGS. ARE NOW STANDING IN THE
WAY IN CALIFORNIA. OF CHILDREN
ACCESSING FOOD. AND SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE DIRECTION
OF THIS LEGISLATURE IS SUCH
THAT THIS WILL CONTINUE. AND I
KNOW THIS PROBABLY ISN'T REALLY
A QUEUE IN A PANEL BUT I SEE
DOCTOR PAN SITTING UP THERE AND
HE HAS ORIGINATED. QUITE A BIT
OF THIS LEGISLATION MA'AM I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO
REPORT TALKING ABOUT FOOD. I'M
TALKING ABOUT FOOD BEING
ACCESSED BY THE CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEM HAVING TO
BE VACCINATED IN ORDER TO BE
FED. AND I'M FINDING THIS
CHALLENGING. BECAUSE MY IMPULSE
WAS TO READ A POEM YESTERDAY
SENATOR MELISSA. BECAUSE AFTER
YESTERDAY I THOUGHT MAYBE I
NEED TO TAKE IT DOWN A NOTCH
MAYBE IT'S ME BUT THEN I GO
INTO THE LEGISLATION AND I SEE
THIS LEGISLATURE TYING FOOD TO
VACCINE STATUS. THAT CONCERNS
ME. BECAUSE MANDATED MEDICINE
OKAY TO MESS UP- IF WE CAN
PLEASE. IF YOU RUB YOUR FINAL
STATEMENTS AND WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TWO MINUTES IS WHAT I'M
BORED PROVIDING EVERYBODY.
CORRECTION WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT RECESSED BECAUSE
THERE'S A DISRUPTION IN THE
ROOM THANK YOU.
HI PLEASE BOB
GOOD. WITH TODAY'S TOPIC WAS A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT OF
DISCUSSION FOR- JUST JUST ONCE
AGAIN I WANT TO JUST RE
EMPHASIZE THAT WE HAVE A TWO
MINUTE LIMIT FOR COMMENTS AND
IF IT COULD BE PLEASE STAY TO
WHAT'S ON THE AGENDA- IF IT
FITS NOT I HAD THE DISCRETION.
TO LIMIT YOUR- YERGER I'M ONLY
THE TOPIC DON'T. I KNOW IS THE
NAME. EVERYONE NEEDS RIGHT SO
TODAY'S TOP OF DISCUSSION WAS
IMPORTANT- BUT THERE IS SOME
STUFF THAT WE LEFT OUT AND
THAT'S ABOUT YOU SENATOR
MELISSA. YOU VOTED NO ON SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. WHICH
EXPANDS PROTECTIONS FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TO TAKE CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER. AND YET YOU'RE
SITTING HERE DISCUSSING HOW TO
FIGHT HUNGER WHAT IF SOMEONE
NEEDED A PAID FAMILY LEAVE. TO
HELP AN ELDERLY FAMILY MEMBER
TO GO GET THEIR GROCERIES OUT
OF SPEC AT SPECIAL HOURS. HOW
CRITICAL IS IT TO SIT THERE AND
DISCUSS TO DISCUSS SUCH A
SENSITIVE TOPIC I STARTED
VACATION. WHEN YOU HAVE VOTED
NAY TO ESSENTIALLY GIVEOTHERS
THE OPPORTUNITY IF THEY NEED TO
HELP A FAMILY MEMBER. PERHAPS
THE UPCOMING LESSONS ON ANTI
DISCRIMINATION SCHOOL MIGHT BE
OF ASSISTANCE TO YOU SINCE YOU
ALSO. OPTED OUT OF VOTING J. R.
NAY ON AB. TWO FOUR TWO FIVE
FOUR TWO. THAT BILL PROHIBITS
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN
CRIMINAL COURTS YOU VOTED YES
TO ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
WORKERS TO QUALIFY FOR STATE
TAX RETURNS. BUT YOU HAD NO
VOTE REGARDING THE RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN CRIMINAL
COURTS. ISN'T THAT
DISCRIMINATION. HOW CAN ANYONE
IN GOOD FAITH HERE. TAKING MORE
DOT JUDGMENT ON FIGHTING HUNGER
WHEN YOU PICK AND CHOOSE WHO
GETS HELP HOW CAN ANYONE WHEN
YOU PICK AND CHOOSE. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL OUR
PEOPLE HERE IN THIS FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE WHO WISH TO COMMENT.
TWO MINUTES. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD. HI SENATOR
MELISSA WE MET YESTERDAY I HOPE
YOU WILL CUT ME OFF TODAY. SO
TODAY WAS ABOUT FOOD AND
NUTRITION HELLO LET ME STATE A
COUPLE OF ITEMS. THE NUTRITIOUS
ONCE MASHABLE'S RICHARD LATER
IN AND SPRAYED WITH THE LIFE
FOR SAY. CORNSTARCH TOFU SOY
SAUCE SUGAR. RICE POTATOES
WHEAT CORN THEY ARE ALL GMO ALL
ALONG IN ADDITION TO THE LIFE
FOR SAY. I DON'T KNOW WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THAT HOW
IS THAT NUTRITIOUS TO THE
SECOND GRADER THE DEFENSE TO
ORDER THE TOLD GREATER. YOU
PALM THEM ON CARBOHYDRATES AND
SUGARS AND YOU CALL THAT THE
TREASURES. I DON'T. AND SHAME
ON YOU THAT YOU DO. BUT THE
BACK CAN HONE IN ON WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY. THAT IT
IS. TITLE EIGHTEEN CODE ONE
ZERO FOUR ZERO. FRAUD IN
REGARDS OF MAJOR DISASTERS OR
EMERGENCY BENEFITS DECLARING
DISASTERS TO GET FUNDS
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WHICH I
BELIEVE YOU GUYS ASKED HERE FOR
TODAY. AGAIN THAT IS FRAUDULENT
AND IT IS AWARDED. BY YEARS
SPENT IN PRISON AND IF YOU
STAND BY IT IT WILL MEAN YOU AS
WELL. THANK YOU AND- IF THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT TìM.
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE WE WILL BE
MOVING ON TO ROOM ONE ONE TWO.
SIGNON WE ARE MOVING ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR MISS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. AND CAN YOU PLEASE. YUP
PROVIDE US WITH THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. SURE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN AT LONDON'S
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE. WELL FIRST
GOLD CAROLINE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HELLO AGAIN SELEPAS IN
IN THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THANK BILL
BALLENGER HOLDINGS OF HEARING
TODAY AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE PANELISTS FOR
DRAFTING THE NEEDS OF BOTH MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ACTUALLY OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN
EFFECTIVE SETTINGS TO ADJUST
THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN AND USE.
A COMPREHENSIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE WHOLE CHILD
APPROACH WILL BE HELPFUL TO
PROVIDE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
FOOD ASSISTANCE. TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOU. AT MY- WE
SHOULD PRACTICE AND ASSIST DOES
WITH DIED AND- WE DO SO AN
EQUITY. RECOGNIZING THAT OF
COURSE IN BECAUSE IT MIGHT
THAT'S ON AFTER AMERICAN AND
THE STUDENTS AND FAMILY. WE
KNOW ARE IN PERCENT LEARNING
BUT MANY STUDENTS AND ARE ALSO.
FROM NEEDS AND SUPPORT. EACH
OTHER BASICS. AS A RESULT OF
CLOTHES AND HOME. WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE L. A. AND ON THE TO A
GROUND SHOWING WHERE THE ARE MY-
AND MOST OF. AND THOSE REASONS
WE- WITH OUR LOW. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO HELP THEM WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE NOW. IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THEMES WE KNOW THAT
THE COLD NINETEEN KIND. HAS
CREATED A GREATER. AS FAR AS
THOSE WHO ARE NOT INCOME. AND
OTHER CHALLENGES. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE G.
HELP US AS THE NEEDS OF COLOR
DAY. WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
SCHOOL HAVE FOR OF ALL BE
APPROPRIATE AND- HOPE FOR
EDUCATIONAL FUNDING. AS WELL AS
HEART DISEASE AND ABILITY TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE OUT OUR OWN
COUNTIES AND REGIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE COMING. DAYS AND ON. THANK
YOU. THANK AN UPDATE WE NOW
HAVE A AND LIKE YOU WELL NEXT
GOAL TO LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBER LIBBY SANCHEZ AT
THE AYE YEAR CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
HIGHLIGHTING THE VERY REAL AND
WIDESPREAD NEEDS OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS. ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS ARE SOLELY RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS AND ENROLLING
INDIVIDUALS APPLYING FOR ALL
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
BENEFITS. WOULD ALREADY BE DEAD
WE SAW AN OVER 2100% INCREASE
IN HEALTH SLASH APPLICATIONS
DURING THE EARLY MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE RODE NOT ONLY TO
THAT CHALLENGE BUT TO THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY SIMILARLY
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN
APPLICATION FOR ALL PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMMING
ACROSS THE BOARD. DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY AND THEN GOING OUT
AND RECORD NUMBERS. MITCHELL DO
YOU IN LARGE PART TO
FLEXIBILITY ACCORDED BY THE
STATE AND OUR COUNTY EMPLOYERS.
SHOULD ONGOING CONCERNS WE HAVE
ARE INSUFFICIENT STAFFING IN
CONCERT THE LOCK THAT THE PP
AND INCONSISTENT EXERCISING
HELLO WORKING OPTIONS BY SOME
OF OUR EMPLOYERS SH IN ONE
COUNTY WE'VE HAD APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS CONTRACT COVERAGE.
CAUSING AT LEAST TWO FOLD UNIT
QUARANTINES. ENSURING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
WORKERS AND ENSURING WE HAVE A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF WORKERS TO
DO THE JOB IS THE SUREST WAY TO
ENSURE THAT ALL ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS ARE IN BOLD. AND
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE LIFESAVING
BENEFITS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MAX ARTICLE I NUMBER
TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME LIZ AND CAN
RECORD TO SCHOOL ADVOCATE
CATERPILLAR AND FOR LATER.
SUPPORT NEARLY A HALF PUBLIC
SCHOOL THIS THROUGHOUT THE CAL.
THE CALIFORNIA- CAL KIDS IN HIS.
WHICH PROVIDE ALL WITH PREPARED
LOCAL GROUND AND EDUCATE ABOUT.
ARAMBULA THE ONE YOU ABOUT AT
PUMP YEAH SHOULD BE A MODEL THE
REST OF THE STATE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AFTER. CANDLE MAKING
IT. PART WITH THE- TO RE AND
FOR THE BANKS TO. A TO TWELVE
POINT KNOWING MEALS DATE. AND
LAUNCH ROWING THE TABLE
INITIALLY WITH PHILANTHROPY.
THIRTEEN REGIONS AND CAL AND
BARS THE COR ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SMALL SCALE FARMS BY
BUYING PRODUCE AND IT'S OF MORE
AND- WHICH IS LANCASTER AS
FRESH BOX AND- MEALS JOSH MOST
INSECURE. THREE NUTRITIOUS
MEALS. ENGINE YOU CAN BE CLOSE
AND PREVIOUSLY NOTED ONLY
PROGRAMS ARE TRUSTED INCLUDING
UNIQUE PROVIDING JOBS LEFT
LOCAL FARMERS AND THE MILLION
OF. I SHOULD HAVE LONG TERM ON
AND CHIU AND QUALITY OF OUT
PARTICULARLY FOR THE OF COLOR.
MARK THAT THE MERGER OF THE
AUTHOR DURING BECAUSE NINETEEN
COUPLED WITH A LOT TRADITION
LEADING. ARE TYPICALLY
COMMITTEE AND ABSENCE OF PEOPLE.
PLACE A MAJOR DATA BURDEN ON%
DISTRICTS GENERAL LAWMAKER BY A
LIFE TO. ARE WE STUDY BY CENTER
FOR EAGLE THAT LINK THIRTY NINE
CALLED THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
RIGHT OVER IN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
DEAL THAT 92% ONLY DEPARTMENT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING BUDGET
DEFICIT THAT AT THE START OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR. THE ESTIMATED
WILL BE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE ALREADY FACING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IN BUDGET
DATA WHICH CONTINUES TO GROW AS
THE SCHOOL YEAR PROGRESSES.
EDUCATIONAL THANK YOU
UNFORTUNATELY MOST. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO- A COMMON
ON IT YOU KNOW OURS HUMAN
SERVICE COMMITTEE- WE- IT WERE
AT TIME LIMIT HERE- IT MADRE
CAN WE ON THE NEXT COLOR. YES
THE AUTOMATIC FROM TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE CALL. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ELIZABETH AFTER VALVE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE BECAUSE
OFFICERS INCLUDING CHILD
NUTRITION DIRECTOR. WE CAN
COMMITTEE FRANKLY IN THE SCHOOL
PERSPECTIVE AND THE HEARING ME
NO GUIDANCE CONTINUES TO EVOLVE
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT COLEMAN
AND APPRECIATE THE STATE
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IN RESPONDING TO
ADVOCACY EFFORTS TO FACILITATE
PULLED THE BILITY TO CONTINUE
CUTTING ME OFF. I DIDN'T WANT
TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
THAT YOU'RE EXPERIENCING A
DECLINE IN APPLICATIONS THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAM DUE
TO CHALLENGES. AND GETTING THE
FORMS RETURNED. AND FOR YOUR
EIGHT STANDARD WAIVER UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY ONE. THAT
MADE DIFFERENT. WARM RETURN.
THAT'S THE LEAST ARE ONE PARA.
I'M STRATEGY AND COMMUNICATING
WITH PARENTS BUT THEY WILL
FUNDING CAN BE MAINTAINED OR
INCREASED BY THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND SUBMITTING THE
FORM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR THE HEARING.
THANK YOU. MAXIM OF THE LINE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YES HELLO.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS A ON TRUCKS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
IS MEDICINE COALITION. AND- I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. PROVIDE COMMENT TODAY- ON
THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF
MEDICINE. COALITION CONSISTS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
NONPROFIT AND COMMUNITY BASED
AND WE SERVE A UNIQUE AND
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE POPULATION
THAT- NEED NUTRITION SECURITY
AND- FINALLY LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIVING WITH CHRONIC AND ACUTE
HEALTH CONDITIONS OR UNABLE TO
SHOP AND COOK MEALS. THAT NEED
TO OCCUR SO MANY OF THEIR
ILLNESSES- MEDICALLY VULNERABLE.
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY IMPACTED BY
KOBE NINETEEN- PARTLY BECAUSE
OF THE LOW INCOME AND ALSO THEY
ARE AN EXTREME RISK FROM THE
VIRUS. SO FOR MANY OF THE
CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE IT'S NOT
SAFE TO BELIEVE HOMES TO GO TO
THE- BANK AND THEY'RE UNABLE TO
PREPARE MEALS. SO ARE
ORGANIZATION. MEDIC TAYLOR TO
NUTRITION MAILED TO THEIR HOMES
WE HAVE VERY SPECIALIZED-
SERVICE- STAFFS EXPERTISE IN
THE FIELD- AND DURING A
PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE INCREASE
IN DEMAND FOR SERVICES. I WOULD
NEARLY DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
MALES WITH PRODUCING I WILL
PROVIDING. I'M NOW ANNUALLY
SERVING APPROXIMATELY. THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
COLLECTIVELY. SO- I WANTED TO
CLOSER TO POTENTIAL OF YOU
AROUND NOT A IN. AND- MEMBERS
PRESENT ON BECAUSE I'M ARE SOME
PEOPLE ARE AWARE OF THIS.
SERVER WE ARE. CORTINA TO
COLLAPSE WITH BANKS AND WITH-
YOU KNOW HOW WE ALL AND OTHER
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY. I THE SAME
TIME OUR SERVICE ARE YOU
BECAUSE THEY ARE MEDICAL
TAILORED AND THERE'S BEEN
PROVEN EVIDENCE OF THE ANSWER
TO AND THE MAILS- AND THEN.
SERVICES WE PROVIDE. AND IN
BECAUSE HEALTHCARE AND REDUCING
HOME. WHICH IS INCREDIBLY RIGHT
NOW TO DO PRESSURE ON HAWK. AND
FOR INCREASING HEALTH HELP- ON
THAT IT HEALTHCARE. SO I JUST
DON'T AGREE WITH A COURT TO
BRING THE STUFF THAT WE WANTED
TO BRING A DISH- ARE THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AS MEDICINE
COALITION TO YOUR ATTENTION-
DURING. THE CRISIS WE HAVE
ACTUALLY NOT. A WIDE SUPPORT-
AND- ALTHOUGH MENTAL GOVERNMENT
HOUSE FOURTEEN STEPPED UP TO
THE TO- COMMEMORATION OF THE
FOR THE INCREDIBLE OF YARN.
THANK YOU YOUR TIME. AND ARE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE DOING
TO ADDRESS FOOD SECURITY THANK
OFF NOT YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE-ADDITIONAL COMMENTS GET MORE
WELCOME TO SUBMIT THE- V. OUR
WEBSITE- TORTURE SERVICES
COMMITTEE. AND WE APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING. TIME TO COMMENT
TODAY. THANK YOU MODERATOR ME.
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT LINE. YES
MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY
HYUNDAI LEVINE WITH WIDENING
GROUP PUBLISHED IN THE NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL WE LIKE
TO THINK THAT THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE HOLDING THE HEARING-
THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL AND
TIMELY ISSUE AFFECTING
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES ALL
ACROSS. THE STATE AND I THINK
HAVE BEEN STATED BY PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS INSECURITY HAS ONLY
BEEN HEIGHTENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC MOVE BACK OF. WILL I
WILL ACTION. ACTUALLY THE BEER
FOR BLACK AND WHITE HOW. IN THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN COOL THANK
BECOME AN EPICENTER DELIVERY
SCHOOL TO. THANK YOU A MAJOR
INCREASE DEMAND AND NUMBER
STATE AND FEDERAL THAT HAVE
BEEN CAN TO FAMILY. YET MORE
STIFFNESS. IF NEEDED AND I
THINK IF THEY MADE CLEAR BY
NUMBER ANALYSTS. WE ARE WORKING
THAT THERE WERE CONTINUE TO BE
BUDGET CHALLENGES AND COMING
FISCAL YEAR- BUT WE MUST ENSURE
THAT. NET INCLUDING NEAR GEORGE
ARE NOT ONLY NOT ONLY PREPARE.
BY STRENGTH. WITH EQUITY KEPT
IN MY- ONCE AGAIN THANK YOUNG.
FOR THE COMING HOLD THE MISTER
HIGHLIGHTING THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE URGE YOU TO COMPLETE
THE FIRST ABOUT THE FOR. BUT IF
THE- ARE AND GO IT'S ACTUALLY
DURING THE WEEK AND PANDEMIC
THANK. THANK YOU MODERATED YOU
PLEASE PRAY WITH AN UPDATE ON
THE OF PEOPLE TO TESTIFY. YEAH
WE HAVE TO MORE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. CEMEX ALMOST LINE
NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN OKAY.
THANK YOU THIS IS- JERRY CALL
SENIOR ADVOCATE WITH NEAREST
CALIFORNIA FORMERLY KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR ELEVATING
THE IMPORTANT TOPIC OF FOOD
INSECURITY DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE ALSO WANT
TO COMMEND THE NUTRITION
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS WE HEARD
FROM TODAY AND ALL THOSE ACROSS
THE STATE FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
FOOD AND NUTRITION BENEFITS
UNDER THE MOST CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE NEED A VERY
DETAILED WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE WHICH INCLUDE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
THE BIBLE NUTRITION PROGRAMS
DISCUSSED DURING TODAY'S
HEARING IN MY BRIEF VERBAL
COMMENTS NOW I JUST LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE KEY OPPORTUNITY
WE'VE IDENTIFIED RELATED TO
SCHOOL MEAL. BEFORE THE
COMMUNITY CRISIS OVER TWO
THOUSAND SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE SERVE UNIVERSALLY FREE
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH TO ALL
STUDENTS UNDER THE FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY. PROVISION OR CD.
SHOULD YOU BE IN THE- STANDARD
FOR SCHOOL. THAT THE ALLOWED
SCHOOLS TO NOT TO COLLECT ANY
PAPER FROM PAM. AND STIGMA A
WITH PREMIUM AND COULD ALONE
SCHOOL MEAL DEBT. WITH MANY
MORE FAMILY TIME FOR IT A THIS
RIGHT NOW IT HIGHLY LIKELY MANY
SCHOOLS BE ELIGIBLE TO SWITCH
TO UNIVERSAL WE BRING US MODEL
UNDERSTAND P. FIFTY CITY THAT.
ACCESS. A TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
TO APPLY TO UP UNDERSTOOD YOU
ANIMO. RECENT DATA MANNER AND
TAKES IT OFF GO FOR BY.
TARGETED AND- TO ENABLE
IMPLEMENT OF NEW. PRETTY BACK
IN LINE AND WHERE THE WERE
THEY'RE GETTING A SUBSTANTIAL
NEED AMONG STUDENTS BUT- WILL
MAKE THE- OF. MEAL ON IT. ARE
UNSUSTAINABLE. BUT BUT ALSO
DRAW DOWN EIGHT DOLLARS FEDERAL.
FOR ONE DOLLAR STATE AND- WE'LL
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
ANTI PARTNER THAT LED. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE URGENT
BOLD ACTIONS TO EASE ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE THE BURDEN
OF CALIFORNIANS WILL YOU HELP
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. TO NEXT LEVEL TO
ALIGN NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SENATOR HER TODD ALLEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ALSO FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY ABOUT
THIS VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT MY
NAME IS KEVIN MCALLISTER AND I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH
MEALS ON WHEELS SACRAMENTO. WE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING TWELVE
THOUSAND MEALS A WEEK PASSED
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
SENIORS I WAS ALSO RECENTLY
NAMED PRESIDENT HAVE MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS WHO SPEAK
WITH A UNIFIED VOICE FOR
NUTRITION PROVIDERS TO BRIGHTEN
THE IMPACT OF OUR PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF SENIORS ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES THERE ARE TWO KEY
FACTS WE HOPE YOU TAKE AWAY
FROM TODAY'S HEARING PERSONAL
LEVEL OF FOOD ASSISTANCE NEEDED
IN OUR COMMUNITIES HAS
PROFOUNDLY INCREASED SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED. AND SECOND
THE PANDEMIC HAS REQUIRED US TO
CHANGE A LOT OF OUR PRACTICES
AND HOW WE PROVIDE MEALS BUT
THESE FACTORS HAVE INCREASED
OUR COST SIGNIFICANTLY FROM
MARCH OF THIS YEAR WHEN THE
PANDEMIC SEVEN TO FEBRUARY OF
THIS COMING YEAR BUILDING WILL
ESTIMATES WE WILL SERVE MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN MILLION MEALS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A
NEARLY 75% INCREASE FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR THIRTEEN OUT OUR
MEALS ON WHEELS PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE HAVE INCREASED THEIR
NUMBER OF MEALS SERVED. BY MORE
THAN 1100% IN THIS SAME PERIOD
AREA SURVEY INDICATES OUR
CLIENT BASE HAS INCREASED
NEARLY 70% MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CLIENTS. IN
ADDITION TO INCREASING DEMAND
FOR OUR SERVICES COVERED HAS
REQUIRED US TO MAKE A NUMBER OF
THINGS NEVER AGAIN CHANGES AND
HOW WE PROVIDE MEALS WE CAN'T
DO CONGREGATE MEALS AT THIS
TIME. SO WE HAVE HAD TO ADD
HOME DELIVERED IN DRIVE THROUGH
PICK UP MEALS WHICH REQUIRE
MORE STAFF AND WHILE WE NEED
MORE STAFF THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. WE HAVE FEWER VOLUNTEERS
DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC WE NEED PP. WE HAD TO
PIVOT TO MANAGING A REMOTE
WORKFORCE AND NAVIGATING SOCIAL
DISTANCING FOR INTAKE OF NEW
CLIENTS. ASSESSMENT AND HOME
DELIVERY. IT IS CHALLENGING
RETRAINING STAFF THAT I'VE
CONSTANTLY HAD TO PIVOT DURING
COLD IT ESPECIALLY WITHOUT
RECEIVING HAZARD PAY. WHICH
ISN'T TO WORKERS SHOULD RECEIVE.
AND THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT
OUR CLIENTS WILL BE THE LAST TO
COME OUT A STAY AT HOME ORDERS
AT LEAST UNTIL A VACCINE
BECOMES AVAILABLE AND IS WIDELY
DISTRIBUTED. IN MOST OF OUR
MEMBERS ANTICIPATE THAT MOST OF
THE GREAT PLACE PROGRAMS WILL
CONTINUE TO NEED SERVICES ONCE
I PROGRAM EXPIRES. THE STATE
MUST PLAN FOR THIS LIKELY
SCENARIO. FOR THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE SERVE THE
MILITANTS ALSO CONNECTION WE
PROVIDE THEM ARE ALL THAT IT
KEEPING THEM FROM HUNGER AND
ISOLATION. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY FOR SENIORS ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT. AND MODERATE WILL JUST
GO AHEAD AND IF YOU CAN PLEASE
TRACK JUST ONE MORE TIME TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY. SURE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS THE ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN LONDON
ZERO COMMENTS. I DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE ELSE MAKE YOU. BOTH
THANK YOU- HAVING HEARD ALL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS POINT. NOW
WHAT I WANT TO GET THIS- YOU
KNOW OPPORTUNITY TO- SAY THANK
YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT TO AB
TOOK THE TIME TO BE ON THE CALL
OR IN PERSON- TO PROVIDE
COMMENT TO BE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT- YOU KNOW
FOOD INSECURITY HERE AND IN
CALIFORNIA- TRANSFORMATION THAT
YOU PROVIDED TO DATE THE INPUT
IS GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL
MOVING FORWARD WE GOT TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THAT WE ADDRESS FOOD
INSECURITY- I KNOW THE COVER
NINETEEN HAS AFFECTED ALL OF US
AND YOU KNOW DIFFERENT WAYS
AND- YOU KNOW BY NOTE. FEEL
COMPANY TO WORK AND GET THROUGH
THIS OP ONLY WE DO IT TOGETHER
SO THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO PARTICIPATE TODAY FOR
LISTENING FOR ANSWERING ALL OF
MY QUESTIONS AND THE QUESTIONS
OF ART YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BOB YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY AND
BUSINESS LEADERS ARE YOU KNOW
REALLY RETHINKING ABOUT HOW WE
CONDUCT BUSINESS AND OUR
WORKFORCES CHALLENGE TO JUSTICE
THE WORKING CONDITIONS ARE IN
IT SO GOING FORWARD WILL BE
INCUMBENT UPON THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO WORK TO
PRESERVE THESE IMPORTANT
ATTRITION PROGRAMS AS WE FACE
DIFFICULT BUT BUDGET IT DID.
BUDGET DECISIONS AND BE COMING
YEAR- I WANTED TO THINK KERRY A
GREENER FOR SHARING THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES I KNOW IT'S.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO- YOU
KNOW WHAT. SHE AND KIND OF YOU
KNOW RELIVING THOSE SUCH THAT
YOU WENT THROUGH A- WE WANT TO
BE HELPFUL SO I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE THE REST OF THE PANELISTS
FOR THEIR TESTIMONY AND YOU
KNOW ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK TO
COME BACK ADAM HUNGER I THINK
WE'VE ALL LEARNED A LOT TODAY
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS ONCE AGAIN WHO
CALLED AND PARTICIPATED IN I
WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THOSE THAT ARE HERE- IN IN.
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT ARE.
MAKING SURE THAT THIS ALL
HAPPENED SAID TO AND THAT EVERY
VOICE IS HEARD. I THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE COOPERATION WE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMISERATED COMMITTEE IS NOW
TRYING TO.